hi guys in this video we'll be covering
everything you need to know about
digital marketing we'll do this with the
help of our instructor rob sanders so
let's start with an introduction to
digital marketing a digital marketing
course video and some of the best
digital marketing tools we'll also have
a look at what is seo an seo tutorial
seven tips and tricks for seo how to
perform keyword research how to rank
number one on google and google tag
manager greetings everyone this is rob
sanders and today we're going to talk
about what is digital marketing so
thanks for joining us here at simply
learn and let's get started let's start
talking about why digital marketing is
important so let's start there on the
why so we're just a fly on the wall and
we're in an office environment we're
looking at two friends having a
conversation about digital marketing so
really if we're listening in
everybody every marketer is using
digital marketing for his or her
business now digital marketing has
become more popular than traditional
marketing that's not a surprise
so in response hey over the past few
decades digital marketing has evolved at
a rapid pace these days a lot of people
spend most their time on the internet so
what happens in the internet every 60
seconds well a lot happens every 60
seconds so according to social media
today i mean there's a lot of snaps
there's a lot of clicks there's a lot of
text there's a lot of videos watched
there's a lot of pictures being taken
there's a lot of
voice activated activity going on a lot
of tweets emails swipes there's a lot
going on here in 60 seconds so there's a
lot of activity on the internet a lot
and so the one gentleman says hey can
you also mention a few differences
between digital and traditional
marketing systems and then the expert
responds of course i can
certainly clarify a few differences
between digital and traditional and so
he goes on to say what the differences
are between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio billboard newspaper tv
anything that's not on your mobile or
laptop so we know with traditional
marketing reach is limited
with digital marketing reaches maximum
and what we mean by that is hey when you
print something you're printing it for x
amount of people if you're trying to
promote an event and you
basically create a thousand flyers okay
you figure it's going to a thousand
people maybe they'll share it so you're
looking about 2 000 people maybe just to
be generous well digital marketing we're
promoting an event we can promote it to
a whole lot of people depending on the
platform so 2000 is nothing when you're
targeting an audience on facebook or
google search traditional marketing
non-versatile
and with digital marketing very
versatile so again going back to our
flyer printing an eight and a half by
eleven okay that's it you know with with
digital marketing you're running display
banners you have 468 by 60 200 by 200
250 by 250 300 by 300 i mean the list
goes on on the types of different
display sizes not to mention text ads
not to mention video or multimedia
so there's a lot you can do
to get your message out there okay with
traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so
meaning if you're trying to get that tv
spot there might not be a spot open
until one in the morning okay well with
digital marketing there is no hours okay
you can certainly get your point out
there and have people see it
instantaneously so with traditional
marketing there's a lack of real-time
results i mean this seems like uh it's
obvious but you know digital marketing
that's one of the biggest benefits
instant real-time results instant okay
nowadays
go to analytics you can look at
real-time reporting okay so we can see
real time results okay traditional
marketing can be very costly i mean if
you're not only doing postcards and
printing postcards but you have to mail
those postcards so there's postage fees
where with digital marketing it's very
very very cost efficient i mean meaning
you could pick and choose who you want
to target when you want to target where
you want to target what you want to
target and if you're doing search you
can put your bidding in place you can
put your hours in place you can really
control how much you actually spend so
that to me is one of the biggest
advantages to digital marketing not only
do you get real-time results but you can
control costs and then obviously
optimize based on the amount of cost
you're spending based on those real-time
results and with traditional marketing
it's difficult to reach a target
audience you know with digital marketing
it's easy to reach a target audience i
mean you know i don't want to bash
traditional marketing too much i mean if
you're gonna put a tv ad in place you
know you're gonna do it on a tv show
that tends to
gear more towards your target audience
but that doesn't guarantee anything here
we can simply go to facebook or twitter
or linkedin and just pick and choose
specifically who we want to target when
we want to target them so it just
becomes a lot easier to reach a targeted
audience on a digital marketing platform
and then with traditional marketing poor
campaign measurement with digital you
have easy to measure and optimize
campaigns and what we really mean by
that is because you get instant time
results because you can control cost
because you can reach your target
audience more easily all those a result
of okay you can measure and optimize
based on what our audience is seeing and
how much they're spending to see it we
can quickly make adjustments in order to
optimize the campaign for better
performance so that's generally that
means that's a culmination of pretty
much everything that we've listed as a
benefit for digital marketing okay so
now
why digital marketing's been answered
with all the benefits that
it carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so
you know that
you know you want to do digital
marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just define it
digital marketing it's just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device when we
talk about technology it could be an app
it could be
you know a cloud-based platform okay it
could be a piece of software okay so
a lot going on on the digital side in
terms of variations and what you can do
but that's in a nutshell what digital
marketing is you're really just using
technology to promote your product or
service so
we know because of the benefits in
digital marketing you can promote your
campaign on different platforms okay so
all those benefits we mentioned about
instant real-time results cost
efficiency
optimizing campaigns you could do that
on search you could do it on social via
email on mobile apps etc so that's what
we mean by with the help of digital
devices and technology well these
digital devices and technology come in
the form of search engines and emails
and mobile apps etc
so
when we want to go
and promote our product or service using
a campaign we have different options so
there are different types of digital
marketing channels that we can choose
from and let's just go through that list
of digital marketing channels and the
first one is what i consider the king of
them all and that's seo so seo stands
for search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with seo because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic
on the search engines including google
so depending on where you're located in
the us market google tends more has a
large market share so you want your
pages on your website to be found and
clicked on organically and so that means
that somebody types in a keyword you
want that relevant page to show up first
on google so somebody can click on that
link okay and we know that millions of
people
specifically in the us but worldwide you
search on a daily basis so if you're
ranking for those relevant keywords you
can imagine how much traffic you can get
okay so that's seo okay and here's an
example so you type in online shopping
well you can see the first listing here
is a paid search ad and we're gonna get
to that in a minute the second
organically is amazon okay so online
shopping you think maybe walmart you
think maybe
alibaba or you're thinking probably
amazon okay so no surprise amazon's
ranking for the keyword online shopping
and so if somebody clicked on their
listing that's traffic for amazon let's
move on to search engine marketing you
know known as sem or pay per click or
cost per click or ppc or cpc or
sponsored search or google ads i mean
there's a lot of different names
synonymous with sem so search engine
marketing is really just using paid ads
on search engines just as we saw the
previous example
if you want to be found for keyword you
don't have to worry about organic if
you're willing to pay for it you just
bid on that keyword and voila you have
the opportunity to appear number one in
the search results at the top of the
page for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay google if
it's google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well
myus.com
is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happened to click on that listing then
myus.com is gonna pay google something
depending on what the cost per click is
and so that could be anywhere from one
penny to a hundred dollars it depends
depends on the keyword depends on who
else is bidding on the keyword depends
on the location depends on the time of
day
depends on quality score there's a lot
of factors involved and regarding what
you pay however
the benefit of sem is visibility and
getting traffic to your website for
keywords you're not found for so that's
why sem's such a popular choice for a
lot of companies okay let's talk about
digital marketing that's a traditional
type of digital marketing channel it's
been around a long time you know we all
send emails on a daily basis and we
probably all receive emails on a daily
basis this is an effective way to
capture leads and convert them to
customers because with email you can
personalize your emails and you can send
your emails to a segmented audience okay
so if you have emails from
females who are 35 years of age to 44
that live and say this southern part of
the united states you can segment that
and send them an email and cater that
email directly to that audience and of
course you can put some nice call to
action in there you could design it
really snazzy and you could track it
just like you can any other digital
marketing channel so email is a very
effective way to really reach a target
audience because everybody for the most
part has a functioning email account so
basically here's an example of an email
that could go out you're selling a
product and the products promotion is
about to end well you know get that
email out to your target audience let
them know hey you have until tonight to
purchase product and if you purchase it
you're going to get 30 off and you can
put the coupon code right in there with
a nice call to action and you can
measure how many people click on that
email go to that web page and purchase
the product using that coupon code so
that's an example of email marketing
okay we have affiliate marketing so
affiliate marketing is an effective way
for digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting
merchants to promote your products and
services and you're using usually a
third-party broker like commission
junction or cg.com as an example to
introduce you the the person selling the
product the merchant with the affiliate
so that affiliate could likely be a
merchant him or himself and they can
basically be a good partner of yours by
publishing your product or service on
their website so
that they can sell in order to get
commissions so it's all based on a
commission so you basically are going to
use a third-party affiliate like cj
get all these affiliates to work for you
they're gonna promote your product or
service if they do sell your product or
service you're gonna pay them a
commission that's more or less how it
works with affiliate marketing and you
know with affiliate marketing to me it's
a good way to you know really promote
your product or service and you can pick
and choose the affiliates or the
publishers of whom you want to work with
so here's an example
of affiliate marketing at work okay you
basically see a banner basically you
could see earn up to 12
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that and purchased for
example or joined you could pay off that
commission okay let's turn our attention
to social media marketing so social
media marketing you know i would say
it's fairly new i mean if i think about
it we're in 2019
and i remember talking about facebook
back in 2006 so you're talking about 13
14 15 years of social media it's
definitely evolved over the years and
but the concept remains the same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on pinterest or
instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're gonna promote but we
know social media can be effective
because people use social media i mean
facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you could
certainly pay to have an ad on facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your social platforms
like linkedin and twitter and facebook
and pinterest and instagram they'll have
a paid form of advertising that you can
use to promote your product or service
or you can go the organic route and you
know post content organically in hopes
of driving traffic back to your website
so with social you do have two options
here but social is interesting because a
lot of different social media platforms
out there really depends on your product
or service okay so an example of social
media marketing especially on facebook
with facebook you got mobile and desktop
and you obviously have the opportunity
to post something organically and have
that liked or commented on or shared or
you could post an app and get that liked
commented or shared or clicked and have
people go back to your website and
fulfill the goal of what you want them
to do so moving on to content marketing
so content marketing is really an
effective way of really distributing
valuable content online and when we talk
about content marketing you know we're
talking about different types of assets
so it could be simply text in the form
of a blog post or it could be a video or
it could be an
infographic or it could be an image okay
there are lots of ways to create content
these days especially in digital
marketing and the great thing about
content marketing is you're writing
content for a targeted audience so
if you're trying to targeted audience on
say instagram then you know who your
audience is and you know what the type
of content you're going to post on there
so it could be in the form of a video or
infographic or just a graphic and so
that's the beauty of content marketing
really putting yourself out there
and
depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example we look at
youtube
you can see this video here about
digital marketing certified associate
well hey you don't need to always write
the content you can produce the content
in the form of a video and post it on
youtube this is a form of content
marketing so that's content marketing
and then let's talk about mobile
marketing so content marketing again
different types but if we go now to
mobile marketing you can kind of segue
from content to mobile because the only
difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so
mobile marketing is really a strategy on
its own that helps
you the company promoting your product
or service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically sms or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example
of a mobile marketing via app install
and so you can even compound that by
running a say google ad as an example
and running your google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bid adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension so there's
lots of ways to
really promote your app or your product
or your service via mobile marketing
okay let's talk about the customer life
cycle
so we know why we want to do digital
marketing we want to net we want we know
what the digital marketing channels are
because we just talked about them from
seo to social to affiliate to mobile to
content to sem okay you have a lot of
different digital marketing channels at
your disposal so now how do we go ahead
and approach our customers so that's
what we're going to talk about first so
we're going to talk about different
stages of the customer life cycle okay
and the first one is the awareness stage
so we need to get our customers aware of
what we're selling or what we're
promoting okay so the awareness stage is
really
what product does your brand offer
that's a question we want to get out
there and we want to answer okay what
does a customer need your product or
excuse me why does a customer need your
product that's a question we want to
answer with digital marketing okay what
solution does your product provide okay
that's an answer to a question we want
to make sure people understand so these
are questions that we want to be able to
answer in the form of digital marketing
whether that be mobile or content okay
so getting our information out there
that answers these essential questions
and if we could do that then somebody's
going to become aware of our product or
service okay so what product does our
brand offer why does the customer need
it and what solution does it provide
okay those are some key questions that
people tend to ask themselves when they
look at a brand okay and when they look
at a product hey do i really need this
is it gonna help me in my life okay and
who who is selling this i mean who is
his brand i mean that's those are just
things that run through people's mind
intuitively that with the right
messaging
the right channel the right type of
asset the right targeted audience you
can quickly make somebody aware of your
brand's product or service in this stage
it's help potential customers discover
your brand with the help of these
different marketing channels so in the
awareness stage you know content is key
so it's to me if we have a website we
need a blog because if somebody does
come to our blog from say organic search
seo then we can write about that product
or service via blog and talk to our
customer talk directly to our targeted
audience through that blog and if we're
not ranking organically we can use paid
search to promote it because paid search
on google for example basically we can
be right at the top of the search
results and so somebody can actually see
when they do a search because we know
millions of people you search on a daily
basis you could do
social media marketing okay so you can
publish that product or service on
facebook while you're building your
community and you can use affiliate
marketing to help get the word out by
using cg.com as an example build up a
sales force of people these publishers
that are going to put your product or
service out there so to me in the
awareness stage these are the the
digital marketing channels you could
focus on now i will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing
you could use display because you can
reach a large number of people so even
though it's listed here low priority in
the awareness stage display
ads mean that if you're on google's
display number you could pick and choose
your sites your demographics keywords
topics an audience you could focus on
all those different demographics to
really attract a large number of people
so low priority but it's probably also
good to focus on in the awareness stage
okay so content marketing you must
create a high quality content that
people are searching for without content
it's hard to get found and so to me this
is you know where the blog comes in seo
take that content get it optimized okay
sem if we're not ranking organically we
can make sure we're at the top of the
paid search results or the the search
results for a particular keyword we want
to be found for and then social media
marketing using different channels
depending on the channel if we're
selling you know training like simply
learn does you know linkedin is a good
platform for us okay and then affiliate
you know basically building up a nice
network of publishers to get the word
out so these are all good channels that
we can focus in on so traffic sources
may include paid unpaid social referral
display email or direct so they they
could come in the awareness stage from
all different types of channels even
though you're focused on content i mean
you could still get
traffic from mobile or email so now that
we got the word out via all these
different marketing channels there's
that consideration stage so
you know people are aware of us now
they're considering us and that's kind
of the next stage in the process okay so
a few essential questions to address on
the consideration stage hey what
features make your product valuable to
others and how will i increase customer
engagement towards my product so those
are answers to questions you want to ask
okay what features make your product
valuable you want to basically separate
yourself from the competition basically
that's what you're trying to answer okay
so if you're promoting your product or
service on paid search and other people
are bidding on the same keyword how are
you going to stand out and then how will
i increase customer engagement towards
my product so for example if you're on
facebook okay and you're trying to get
people over to your site to purchase
your product then how are you going to
improve that engagement you got to
create something really snazzy or really
it's going to be attention grabbing or
something that's going to get them to
become aware of it that's going to
separate your post from all the other
posts that are in somebody's facebook
news feed okay so you really have to
work hard to really convince somebody to
get their consideration towards your
product or service so in this stage your
customer considers your product so help
them understand how your product is
valuable okay to me email works really
good here because if you have a targeted
audience this gives you the opportunity
to really answer these questions in that
particular channel email you could
support that with a promotion and
display i think display is a good option
here too because even though you know
people are trying to become aware
you know you can really hone in
and really get them to take that next
step okay with display you can even do
remarketing so if somebody's been to
your site because they're aware of your
product they're curious you can cookie
them and remarket to them via display so
display to me is a good a good channel
to use here okay so you have email
mobile display you know sem these are
all you know good channels to use on the
consideration stage especially on search
because somebody's looking for something
and they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering a promotion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so
people are aware we're moving them
further along the funnel with email
marketing we have the opportunity to
promote the product by sending an email
directly to our audience so with this
stage plan your campaigns around
welcoming emails newsletters we can talk
about product descriptions add ratings
and reviews in the email you know we
really just want to encourage people to
purchase the product that's we're trying
to sway them over so email is a good
source to allow us to do that so with
mobile marketing we can promote the
products by sending relevant messages to
our target audience display again
retargeting because we can retarget an
audience that has been to our website
already did some research about our
brand our product or service and now
we're going to reach back out to them to
sway them so remember we want to
encourage customers to buy a product by
creating detailed articles about the
product that always helps and that's
content okay we want to opt for a
customer testimonial okay that helps
sway people and add some guest blogging
okay we can have ambassadors blog on our
behalf or we can go out and blog on
somebody else's site okay so blogging
works both ways it's ways of of showing
yourself and telling people hey
we know you're looking for this product
here's why you want to choose us okay
moving on from the consideration to the
purchase stage so they're aware of you
they're considering you and now we're on
to the purchase stage so the questions
we want to really make sure we address
here are how are my prices compared to
my competitors and is my brand more
credible than others okay so they're
considering you but
that price point and it may not even be
the price it could be the shipping for
example the price could be good but the
shipping cost could be high so you
really want to do some due diligence and
research on what your competitors are
doing credibility that goes back to the
consideration stage and testimonials you
want to make sure you have reviews and
testimonials to really elevate what
you're trying to tell customers and that
that is hey i have a good brand i have a
good product i have a good service come
buy my stuff come buy my product and
service but you really need to support
that claim you just can't go out and say
it and so supporting that comes in the
form of what other people say and that
could be reviews that could be comments
on a social media platform it could be
you know stars on say yelp or google my
business you know make sure you do
your due diligence and make sure
you get people to you know review you or
provide testimonials because people are
going to do their due diligence before
they purchase especially if it's on
google my business or yelp or trip
advisor or whatever it is you're trying
to sell they're going to be able to see
those reviews and so do your due
diligence to get the reviews and if it
is a negative review hey that's okay you
can't please everyone you're gonna get
them that's the world we live in just
make sure you show your upper hand and
respond even to the negative as well as
the positive reviews that you get that
actually bodes well to some people
because hey it shows that i made a
mistake and you're willing to correct it
and so people actually see that that
could be the tipping point to getting
them to purchase hey look hey this brand
really cares because they're really
responding to people they're not
ignoring negativity okay just those
small things that can get people to
change their minds now with the purchase
stage according to e-consultancy 83 of
the online audience require
encouragement to complete a purchase
encouragement what does that mean well
it could mean providing a promo giving
them that extra incentive you know if
you don't offer promo consider it
especially on the email and the example
we looked at earlier sending in an email
means that if the promo is going to end
at midnight send that email out and tell
people they have until midnight and if
they purchase today you'll even increase
it to 20
and email is a good channel for that
mobile can reach a lot of people through
sms okay social media reaching people
instantaneously
and then you know really with the
purchase stage it gives prop prospects
an offer to help them make that purchase
so you have plenty of channels to choose
from in fact most of these channels the
only one really that doesn't fit the
instantaneous mode is seo but you can
really focus on affiliate even though
that's a low priority here you can
really you know coordinate with your
publishers who especially those
publishers that have proven their worth
and have sold your products in the past
you get them to help promote it and
incentivize their
audience so let's move on from the
purchase to the purse post purchase
stage so this is after somebody
purchases
okay so some essential questions we want
to be able to address here so what
additional product could my customer buy
now that they're my customer what else
could i sell them what you know without
being too pushy could if they buy a coat
well a hat work or a pair of gloves or
you know blouse you know you want to be
able to
not push a product on your customer but
think about how you can complement that
purchases that purchasers or customers
product and then how to improve the
customer buying experience
so
again this goes back to you know what we
just said about reviews get somebody to
offer a review and if they don't give
you
a full compliment of five stars they
only give you three and a half stars
then you know what that's great feedback
because then you can learn from that and
then the other question is will the
customer refers to others and if so why
so that's
definitely something you want to be able
to address in the post purchase date so
let's take a look here so with post
purchasing stage you know it's me emails
at the top of this list because if
somebody purchases something you can
send a nice thank you email because if
they purchase they're giving you their
email in return because you're likely
going to be sending them the receipt via
email so email to me is a nice
channel you send in a nice message even
you know social media
you know you can thank your community
for supporting you on this recent
campaign that you ran you know even
throwing an extra five or ten percent on
a future purchase is a thank you and
that's easily done on social media
you know you could even post a blog you
know
promoting you know the success of a
product and then offering a promotion
okay so there's a lot of things you
could be doing here on the post
purchasing stage so to me even looking
at content again you could even you know
put a survey together you could even put
a survey together for your affiliates
okay you could even post a poll on
facebook so it's just working in with
these different channels to get some
feedback about your product and service
so with email mobile you can engage
customers with follow-up emails or
customer care content you know with
mobile if you have somebody's mobile
number hey text them a simple thank you
goes a long way you know you could say
hey look if you're satisfied let us know
give us a call you can even in the ee
mobile text message you can put a link
to a survey send emails to active
subscribers give rewards for customer
feedback so if somebody does provide
feedback give them an extra 10 off you
know you want to be able to reward
loyalty
loyalty comes in the form of a
partnership if you're giving somebody
discounts and you have a good product or
service then they're going to recognize
that they're going to say hey look i
really like this product and they're
giving me 10 i'm going to go ahead and
purchase from these guys again so give
those discounts to those active
customers or on the affiliate network
give referral opportunities to your
customers so if it's an affiliate
publisher hey if they're getting people
to your site you know reward them or if
it's an email and you put a four to a
friend get an extra 10 off it doesn't
hurt because you're incentivizing people
to help you sell your product so with
social display and content use those
banner ads or
use that content that you display on
social or the blog you're going to write
to give customers advice in order to
maximize the value of the purchase so
again you can use these platforms to
also enhance
what they purchased so hey you just
purchased this product thank you very
much did you know you could do this this
and this with it and so that's the idea
of a post-purchase stage is to maximize
these channels to be able to answer
those essential questions about what
else could they purchase you know do
they like how do i get these people to
become loyal customers okay so with the
first purchase stage if a customer has
bought a pair of sports shoes for
example running shoes you can recommend
cross product sale a cross sale it could
be a pair of shorts or a water bottle or
an accessory with an exclusive discount
so that's another example what you can
do on the post purchase stage so in
today's world everywhere you go it's all
about digital so today this lecture is
going to be about all the different
marketing channels available piece them
together kind of put together a little
digital marketing course for you so
first off before we get started we're
going to talk about what is digital
marketing and really digital marketing
covers a lot of areas it's very broad
and really what it refers to just
marketing
that
a company does a person does an
individual a group an organization
and they do it in the form of an
electronic device or with the aid of the
internet that's really what digital
marketing is it's just having something
digitally not something tangible like a
billboard or newspaper or tv and with
that there are lots of places where you
can apply digital marketing and so
electronic devices we think of mobile
devices and so you could certainly use
mobile as a form of digital marketing or
to help you with your marketing efforts
digitally okay you can create apps you
can run advertising on mobile you can
communicate with different people your
target audience the via different
devices like whatsapp and messaging okay
uh there's also search engines search
engines is where a lot of people get
their information from at least start to
do their research to get information you
got social media
lots of different social media platforms
all the way from you know tweeting to
blogging to
social sharing to social content okay so
a lot of of platforms under the bucket
social media you also have traditional
forms of digital marketing like email
you can use different email platforms to
send out emails so lots of different
ways to communicate your product your
service your message to a large number
of people that are really targeted to
your efforts how is digital marketing
useful well we know provides different
metrics why do we know it provides
different metrics because it's all
digital okay so anytime you send out an
email or post something on facebook
you're going to get data back when you
get data back you could take that data
to determine how well that post or that
email performed and if it didn't perform
up to expectation you can make changes
to improve performance that's called
optimization okay so that's the great
thing about digital marketing it's
useful in that we get data in some cases
instantaneously and we're able to make
changes in order to optimize that
campaign we can also
you know provide personalized user
experience so meaning if we know who our
target audience is on say twitter or
linkedin or facebook we can really cater
our messaging to that group probably
most importantly is that digital
marketing compared to traditional forms
of marketing allow us to really reach
a global audience very easily very
easily at a very low cost that's the key
so if i want to target people in india
or or nepal or pakistan i can certainly
do that and i can do that with the snap
of a campaign and i get data back and
based on the data i can tailor that
experience even better really just
allows us to really hone in on a
particular audience anywhere in the
world very quickly so these are just
three of the main reasons why digital
marketing is useful some other
experiences or uses for digital
marketing again it provides a
cost-effective alternative to
traditional marketing so
you know for those that are familiar
with purchasing advertising on say tv or
radio you have to pick a spot you have
to pick a program and then pick a time
slot associated with that program so
somebody's watching a program and and
that program tends to draw on a specific
target audience then you want to show
your ad around the time when that
program is slotted to air on tv uh
because you know you're likely going to
reach your audience however to purchase
that time slot could be competitive and
could be very costly where there are
forms of of advertising and paying for
advertising digitally and those forms
are cost per click or cost per
impression and so using a cost per click
or cost compression model allows you to
really go head to head in kind of an
auction style format where you can
control how much you pay and potentially
get that prime spot in front of your
target audience so it really does become
cost effective and it allows you to make
small investments to get a really
substantial return on roi so let's just
say your cost per click is only ten
cents but you're selling a product for
ten dollars well all you need is one
click and one sale to generate a very
substantial return on investment and so
knowing that you get metrics back on a
campaign you could slowly or quickly
optimize that campaign towards a very
positive roi and then another use for
digital marketing just enables targeting
users based on their actions and
preferences so again we can really hone
in on who we want to target it really
depends on the platform but if you take
google ads for example and you want to
target the display network well we know
we have demographics we know we have
topics we know we have interest we know
we have retargeted audiences in segment
audiences we have age we have gender so
you have a lot of options available to
choose from to really hone in
on who you want to target and we talk
about remarketing is another form of
digital marketing so you can set up a
marketing campaign so if somebody comes
to your website and does not purchase
the product or service that you're
offering you could take action on that
behavior so i can re-target a group of
people who didn't purchase that's
retargeting or you could do it via
remarketing and basically that's the
beauty of digital marketing allows you
to really target users based on their
actions some other uses for digital
marketing it helps build brand awareness
and reputation of your business so when
we say brand awareness if you're just
launching a company and nobody knows who
you are if we use google ads as our
preferred method of digital marketing
and establishing campaigns we can choose
that display network that display
network on google ads reaches a large
amount of people so you can really get
your name out there and really target
your intended audience and allow that
targeted intended audience to really
understand who you are because they're
going to see your ad in the form of a
banner or in the form of a video or in
the form of text and so that's the
beauty of digital marketing you can
really reach a lot of people and a lot
of people who might be interested in
your product or service and then digital
marketing provides a platform for you to
be interactive with your audience
helping you stay relevant and
competitive and the best example i can
give here is youtube and so youtube's a
really it's a search engine for videos
but it's a video sharing platform and so
if i upload a video
then i can entice people to comment on
that video or like the video or share
the video and i can really interact with
that audience by responding to their
comments or
you know putting together a playlist or
giving them more videos okay so i can
really interact with my audience and i
could do that on multiple platforms not
just youtube and video i can blog and
and interact based on somebody's
comments i can have a website and have
live chat and interact with my audience
so there's lots of different ways to
interact with an audience and that's
what digital marketing provides
so i already mentioned a few examples
based on the uses of digital marketing i
mentioned google's display network i
mentioned youtube and blogging and
social media platforms like facebook
well there are lots of different types
of digital marketing channels out there
and we're going to talk about a few of
them today we're going to start with
search engine optimization and so search
engine optimization
as you probably know from the name
involves search engine and it involves
really making your site relevant in the
eyes of that search engine so if you're
in the united states you know that
google has a large market share meaning
a lot of people use google on a daily
basis so we want to make sure we do
everything we can to optimize our site
in order to make our site relevant for
those coveted keywords now why do we
want to make ourselves relevant for
those coveted keywords that we want to
be found for on search well because a
lot of people use search and when a lot
of people you search and you're found
for those keyword queries then it's
going to increase the flow of organic
traffic to your website so the higher
you rank in theory the more traffic
you're going to get and so when we
talked about optimization okay how do we
optimize our site in order to be
relevant in the eyes of google well it
really comes down to a two-pronged
approach you have on-page seo you have
off-page seo on-page has everything to
do with your website in order to make it
relevant off-page has everything to do
with your website but not on your
website it means that how can we become
relevant by linking to other websites
for example how can we become relevant
by getting our content on other
platforms so we become relevant in the
eyes of google so that's off page seo so
seo is always going to be two-pronged
what you do on your website and what you
do off the website to make sure your
website your domain whatever that domain
is dot com or dot org is relevant in the
eyes of google
and so let's take a look at on-page seo
first so like i mentioned it involves
optimizing your website and when we say
optimizing your website there's a lot of
things you can do on your website to
make it relevant in the eyes of google
and we can look at the content okay we
can look at the source code and so there
are a lot of different components to be
looked at here so you have the header
tag you have the meta description you
have the alt tag you have how fast your
page loads you have internal linking you
have a site map you have a lots of
different things going on here and so
for me
one of the first things you should do
when you create a page on your website
is to make sure the title tag is unique
and includes those keywords so if we
look here at this example the title tag
is important because that's what shows
up in search results here you can see
the title tag on google is up to 65
characters so you always want to include
that keyword in the title tag then you
have your url and then you have what you
call a meta description so that's
underneath the url underneath the title
tag and again this is in search results
so organic search results somebody types
in a keyword you want to be found and
you want your title tag to stick out and
you want your meta description to
specifically describe what it is you're
offering okay so again if somebody's
looking for
stock imagery then you want to make sure
that you know that person who's looking
for stock imagery can come to your
website and they can in this case search
for millions of royalty free stock
images photos videos and music and so
you want your description to really get
that person to click on your listing an
organic search that's the whole point so
that's the point of a title tag and a
meta description is you really want to
be found for what somebody's searching
for and you want to be able to show them
that you have what they're looking for
you have something here underneath your
organic search results called site links
and site links are just other are links
to pages on your website and so
unfortunately this is not necessarily in
your control this is in the control of
google so if google wants to offer up
site links underneath your title tag
meta description they will add them and
it's based really on the amount of
content you have and that goes with site
search so you can see also their site
search there underneath the meta
description all of that is contingent
upon your website do you have a lot of
content and if you have a lot of
relevant content then google will
naturally add in site links underneath
your organic listing to links to other
pages on your site so that's on page seo
and now we're going to look at off-page
seo okay so off-page seo involves using
promotional methods beyond just
optimizing your site for example
optimizing your title tag meta
description might not be enough to get
you to rank for that coveted keyword
query so we need to do
some link building we need to get our
name out there on other websites okay so
we need to be able to establish some
external links or backlinks from high
quality relevant sites to our site and
it may not just necessarily have to be a
link because google recognizes linkless
backlinks so just having a reference on
a high quality site may be good enough
to get you in the eyes of google to
become more relevant okay so that's
off-page seo in definition so really
what we want to do is we want to
establish a way to get links from other
websites to our own or references on
other websites to our website we want to
build those links to help us gain in
ranking so there's lots of ways to do
that you have social media again you
have social content sites like reddit
medium quora you have blogging okay
there's lots of ways to establish
yourself out there on the internet you
just need to make sure they're quality
sites and you need to make sure they're
relevant and so when you do get a link
on an external site pointing back to
yours you want to make sure it's a
follow so you want to make sure that
google knows to follow that link from
that site to yours so if you're out
there establishing content on a
third-party website or another website
and they're gonna link back to you just
make sure that it's a follow do follow
not a nofollow okay and i'm gonna show
you an example of what that looks like
here so if you're not sure what the
difference is here i'm on backlinko.com
and
really a nofollow versus a do follow is
simply in the href so
in the href if you don't have anything
in there other than the link then
the search engines are going to follow
that link from that external site to
yours and
if you have a no follow in that link
then the search engines are going to
ignore the link so you're not going to
pick up the backlink or external link to
your site and that's simply that site
just adding the rel equals nofollow okay
so if you see that in the link pointing
to your site from that external site
then that means you're not going to get
credit for that backlink so you always
want to shoot for
a do follow link because that means
you're going to get credit for the
backlink okay so again do follow links
allow searching and crawlers to follow
the link and if they can follow it
you're going to get what they call link
juice and that's going to establish some
reputation to your domain a nofollow
link basically doesn't allow the search
engines to follow that link so
it doesn't pass on the link juice now
again search engines like google are
smart enough to pick up the association
between
a website that talks about your website
and your website so meaning if you don't
have a link and you don't have a if you
have a nofollow link on that site don't
fret because you know google has come a
long way they're not necessarily focused
on links though it does help so for
example if you are on a very prominent
site and there's no link then you still
may get credit because google does
recognize linkless backlinks and that's
what they call a linkless backlink it's
just having a reference on that site but
you always want to try and get that
follow not the do not follow okay so
here you can see an example of off page
seo okay like tripadvisor would be a
good example a link that redirects from
tripadvisor to
you know the oprah magazine as an
example so the oprah magazine is going
to get a
back link from tripadvisor to the site
so if google crawls trip advisor then
they're going to be able to see this
link and if it's a follow link they're
going to give the oprah magazine that
domain credit from tripadvisor so for
seo because there's a two-pronged
approach involved you have on-page and
off-page and a lot of tools here a lot
of tools so let's take a look at some of
these tools we're gonna look at google
keyword planner we're going to look at
moz ahrefs we'll get some tools that
will help you with both on-page and
off-page seo so let's start with
google's keyword planner so why are we
using google's keyword planner because
we want to find keywords okay so we
can't do on-page seo we can't optimize
our title tag and meta description
without a good keyword that we want to
be found for so what we want to do is we
want to go into google ads now that's a
pay-per-click platform okay so if you
want to be found via paid search you're
going to use google ads but from an
organic search perspective we can use
google's keyword planner so we need a
google ads account if we have a google
ads account then all we need to do is go
to tools then we need to go to keyword
planner and the keyword planner is a
good tool because it allows us to find
those coveted keywords so we can
discover new keywords and that's exactly
what we're going to do so for example
we're going to find you know use the
keyword mail delivery if we have a
business that delivers mails to people
what keywords do we want to optimize for
so we're going to be in google ads we're
going to go to tools we're going to go
to keyword planner we're going to
discover new keywords and we're simply
just going to type in a keyword so we're
going to click get results and google's
keyword planner is basically going to
give us some information so the keyword
we chose was mail delivery and they're
telling us that on average over the last
12 months there's 22 200 search queries
on average over the last 12 months okay
so i could see if i click hover over the
graph here i'm going to be able to see
the average over 12 months okay so here
i can see the average over 12 months
from july to june 2019. so here what do
i want to do i want to look for trends
because here i can see the averages go
up and down a little bit but 22 200 is
the average over 12 months and then
google's keyword planner also tells me
how competitive that keyword is so
if it's highly competitive but it's got
a lot of search volume it could be a
keyword i may want to covet but the
beauty of the keyword planner is that
they also give you other keywords to
look at okay so mail delivery service
that's 49 500. okay so here you got some
other ones best food delivery service 9
900. again some of these are very
competitive but some of them aren't and
so you want to be able to
do your due diligence do some analysis
and figure out
what keywords work best for you that
aren't going to be competitive but at
the same time give you some search
volume so if you do rank for that
keyword you should expect x amount of
clicks on that keyword based on the
volume so that's google's keyword
planner alternatively you can use a tool
like moz.com so if i log into moz we
have a tool called keyword explorer and
so here i can just type in that same
keyword mail delivery
targeting the united states in english
and moz is going to give me some
information on the keyword so here
they're going to give me a range in
terms of the monthly volume and they're
going to give me a difficulty score so
they're going to tell me how difficult
this keyword is so out of a score of 100
it's 53 and they're going to tell me
what my expected click-through rate
could be if i'm ranking for that keyword
more importantly they're going to
give me some other keyword suggestions
just like google's keyword planner so
here i can see prepared mail delivery
mail delivery service mail delivery
companies so there's a lot of different
suggestions of keywords that i can
choose from and if we scroll down we
could see
basically some mansions we could see the
analysis who's ranking for these
keywords so we can really get some
insight as to who's ranking how much
volume how difficult it is what my
estimates could be if i'm ranking etc so
a lot of information built into moz's
keyword explorer tool so moz's keyword
explorer tool could be a good option for
you if you don't have access to google
ads and google's keyword planner so if
you're working on seo for a website and
you curious is about
what the off-page seo situation looks
like well you can use a tool like age
reps it's free tool you can go here if
you're working on a specific domain and
you're focused on off page you can
simply type in that domain here and then
you can check the back links for that
domain okay so i'm gonna go ahead and
type in my my domain and now i'm gonna
get a sense of what my backlink profile
is for my domain so here i can see the
number of backlinks the total backlinks
and notice 85 of them are do follow
links so google is able to recognize
those links and then i could see
referring domains so i have a 124
different domains pointing to my website
and so here i can get a snapshot of the
top 100 backlinks pointing to my website
and so this just gives me a snapshot of
what's going on with my off-page seo
performance again it's a free tool it's
good to use because it gives you an idea
of what your off-page seo situation
looks like okay another tool you could
use is pingdom okay you can set up a
free trial here it's good for 14 days
and it allows you to you know look at
page speed it allows you to monitor the
site itself in terms of you know
visitors maintenance etc so you can use
pingdom as well
however it's only a 14 day free trial
but it does give you some good insights
into seo now page load time is one of
those on-page seo factors and so if
you're doing on-page seo for domain you
certainly want to go into google
analytics and you want to measure the
page load performance of the pages on
your website and so here if i go to
google analytics and then i go to
behavior and i go to site speed and i go
to speed suggestions here i can see the
pages how many pages i've received over
a period of time and the average page
load time now if you see the average
page load time is slow
and in my opinion anything over two to
three seconds is going to be slow you
need to be able to
take action and so the great thing about
google analytics the page load time
reporting is it actually gives you some
suggestions so page speed suggestions so
all you need to do is click on the link
here in this case this particular link
or url on my website has seven
suggestions if i click on that then page
speed insights is gonna open up and
what's gonna happen is google analytics
slash pagespeed insights is gonna
analyze this page and give me some
feedback on how the page is performing
not only on desktop but on mobile as
well and so here i can see if i analyze
this page i can see
some of the opportunities to improve the
page load time on desktop and again on
mobile here so here you can see a lot of
the opportunities and a lot of the
issues i have that i can address now if
you're going to manage seo for a website
then you're going to need an seo
platform so again moz is a good example
because we showed you the keyword
explorer but they also have many other
tools available built right into the
platform for example rankings okay you
can get crawl information so when the
bots crawl aside what kind of errors are
coming up here i can get some page
optimization so i can choose a keyword
and
i can choose a page and moz is going to
be able to give me feedback to see what
more i could do to improve my on-page
seo performance okay we mentioned
keyword explorer in terms of looking for
keywords okay you also have something
called link explorer as well so if i go
back and choose link explorer from my
list here then i'm going to go to a link
explorer and i can type in any domain
and just like on the hrefs except mods
goes a little bit deeper here okay so
they're telling me how many linking
domains and what my keywords are ranking
okay
and then i have some other reports that
i can leverage for off-page seo i can
look at spam scores for certain websites
that are linking to me because you can
disavow yourself from us being
associated with those sites here you got
a link intersect tool so you can compare
one domain against another
to what links are pointing to that other
website so a lot of different
reports and tools available to you for
off-page seo under moz's link explorer
so moz has a lot of different tools
available and again my recommendation if
you don't use moz there's sem rush
there's bright edge there's a lot of seo
platforms out there to use but if you're
gonna focus on seo you are going to need
an seo platform now if you have any more
questions on seo you feel free to go to
simply learns youtube account you'll be
able to find a video there for seo
tutorial for beginners you know take a
look at the video it goes really in
depth about everything we just covered
about on page and off page seo so take a
look at the video and if you have any
comments about everything we covered
with seo feel free to comment underneath
this video here and we'll be sure to
respond accordingly uh especially if you
have any tips and tricks that you do for
seo so let's move from search engine
optimization to content marketing and so
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves
simulating interest in a brand's
products or services by creating and
sharing
online material so when we talk about
online material that can come in many
forms or assets so some examples are
blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
ebooks all of this is content generated
it's just in different forms and so you
want to be able to take any one of these
forms of content and be able to
distribute that in some form or fashion
okay so for example blog can be part of
your
website a video could be something you
upload to youtube an infographic could
be something you actually share on
linkedin so all these other assets could
be integrated throughout they could be
shared or used on your website okay for
people to grab and share and use and
comment on okay so that's what content
marketing is you need to be able to
push out content so that people have a
better understanding of your product or
service the process of content marketing
is you really want to decide what goal
you want to achieve with your content
marketing campaign you want to define
your buyer personas to determine the
audience best suited for your content
okay so
what are you creating who's it for and
then you want to run content on it to
determine the best type of content that
can be used and when we talk about
content audits we're talking about you
know content that's already been posted
are people sharing it are people
downloading or people viewing it and so
you want to be able to understand over
time what people are reacting to so that
you can reuse or continue to use that
content that seems to resonate with your
target audience so you want to choose an
appropriate content management system so
if it's a blog you want to use wordpress
maybe so you want to start brainstorming
for ideas for new content ideas so in my
opinion maybe put together a content
calendar and jot some ideas on that
content calendar then you want to settle
on a particular type of content you want
to create and then you want to be able
to publish and manage your content so
some top popular tools used for content
marketing you have buffer you have
buzzsumo followerwonk hootsuite so let's
go ahead and take a look at an example
of a content marketing management system
and we're going to use wordpress and so
if we go into wordpress here on the back
end we're logging a login and so the
reason why we use wordpress is because
we can post blogs so in wordpress if i
go to post here i'm going to be able to
see all the different posts that have
been posted over a period of time and
the great thing about wordpress is you
can optimize it for seo so if i go in
here and look at this recent blog post
that has been posted i can go ahead and
edit it and when i edit it okay i'm
going to be able to look at this blog
post in a visual format and i can also
look at it in html form so notice i the
great thing about wordpress is i can use
imagery i can insert videos i can insert
infographics i can attach a white paper
case study to it and then again we have
something called yoast seo plug-in so
we've installed a plug-in here so
that'll help us
with optimizing that particular blog
post for that particular keyword we're
trying to target and so here you can see
our focus keyword is remarketing and
retargeting okay so we have that in the
title tag okay we also want to make sure
it's in the meta description and so here
we have an internal link we have it in
the introduction okay we have it you
know spread throughout the content so
yoast does a good job of allowing us to
make sure we're integrating that keyword
into our blog post but the key to blog
posting is we want to again follow the
process we want to be able to choose
content for our intended audience in
this case with a blog post we can write
up to
you know 500 to 3 000 keywords and the
whole point is we're trying to introduce
our audience to a particular topic that
resonates with our product or service
and so that's the great thing about
blogging that's the great thing about
wordpress is that you know very easy to
use uh you can integrate it with seo
you obviously have commenting you have
different plugins that you can add in
there uh very easy to edit and so a lot
you can do here with wordpress and
blogging so another example of content
marketing is video so with video you
have the ability to upload this video to
popular video sites like youtube or
video and you can optimize
that particular video with title tags
and and hashtags and descriptions and
you could see the interaction here so
you can see how many views how many
likes shares the ability to share the
ability people for saving it and there's
just a lot of interactivity when you
have video you can also use video as i
mentioned on your blogging platform if
it's wordpress you can also use video
and social media platforms like twitter
linkedin and facebook so video is a very
popular form of content marketing lots
of good video tools out there to create
a video a high quality video is what you
want to put your product and service in
the best forefront okay so that people
can react they can share they can
comment they can follow they can like
okay so that's what you want to do is
think about video because video is very
versatile and powerful in terms of
getting your message out there so let's
move from content marketing to social
media marketing and social media
marketing really involves creating
content it's that blog if it's that
video that you created for content
marketing and really using different
platforms to increase your visibility
whether that be traffic whether it be
engagement whether it be brand awareness
or any other marketing goals that you
have that's what social media is good
for because social media will take that
content take what you're trying to get
out there and really allow you to hone
your marketing goals against that okay
so if it's facebook and you got some
videos that you want to post up there
okay what's your goal is your goal to
then post the video to get traffic to
your website or to build brand awareness
or to just get people to react by
sharing or liking and so that's what
social media is good for it's really
good for taking content and really
distributing it to your target audience
okay so
uh sharing content allows you to you
know generate
user generated content or it allows you
to create interactive content and again
you can use infographics or you can
apply content with imagery or post
videos or do things that are interactive
like polling and contest so a lot of
flexibility in terms of the content that
you could share on social media and so
you want to establish a process for
social media marketing so this is the
digital marketing course of it so you
want to be able to have a process and
you want to be able to set up goals that
you want to achieve with your social
media campaign because just posting
content for content sake is really not
going to generate anything for you so
you want to set up those goals ahead of
time then you want to understand what
content would be best suited for your
target audience so if our goal is to
generate brand awareness
then maybe
an infographic is what we want to do
okay maybe that's the best choice of
asset for our target audience based on
the platform with social media we also
want to research what the competition is
and find out what works for them so it's
very easy to do on social so if you
already have a competitor on facebook
you can always go to your competitors
website and you can always see
you know what they're posting and what
kind of reaction engagement they're
getting for a particular post so it
doesn't help before you go live to do
some due diligence about your
competition you can also conduct a
social media audit again what we mean by
audio just like on the content side we
want to be able to see what's worked and
what's not worked in the past and with
digital marketing recall you can get
instant metrics back so if you posted
something last year and you're thinking
about posting it again you probably want
to do an audit to see
over the past year what posts have
worked and have not worked for you then
you want to pick and choose the social
media channels or platforms and to find
a strategy for each of them because if
you have a video
then the video may work on say youtube
or instagram but may not necessarily
work for linkedin and twitter and so you
want to be able to pick and choose the
asset the strategy and align it with the
appropriate platform then you want to
take inspiration from case studies and
other famous brands so again continue to
learn i mean that's the beauty of social
media marketing most big companies
medium-sized companies even smaller
companies that have performed well are
out on social media so take a look at
some other companies that inspire you or
some other companies in your industry or
even again your competitors and see what
they're doing and what they're posting
and what kind of engagement they're
getting so you should always you know be
able to seek out what others are doing
on social and to me this is important
create a social media content calendar
and this isn't necessarily
the very end of the process this goes
back to the beginning of the process so
when you are establishing goals and
you're establishing what kind of type of
content you want to use that should all
be part of a social media content
calendar and i'm going to show you an
example of one here shortly and then
again you want to be able to
test evaluate and adjust your strategy
because again you're getting metrics and
if you post a video on facebook and it's
taking off then meaning in terms of
likes and shares you probably want to
consider maybe doing another one that
complements that so here's a broad
example of a content calendar again it's
in a spreadsheet again by no means
there's one size fits all but just to
give you an idea if we're blogging what
we want to do is we want to pick our
target audience maybe that be country or
particular demographic and you want to
come up with some topics ahead of time
here and you want to maybe put the
status up there of you know it's just a
draft or an idea when it actually does
go live you want to turn it on live you
want to pick your date add some comments
okay create your content
and you know what's good about a content
calendar is you can also work in seo so
you can assign keywords and then you
could add those keywords to moz for
ranking uh you can create your title and
meta description then you can carry that
content forward and choose a particular
social media platform to post to so
that's the beauty of a social or excuse
me a content calendar is it allows you
to think about things up front and then
prepare the content accordingly so you
can optimize it for organic search and
post it on social media for off page seo
and for social media marketing and so
you just want to get organized ahead of
time using a spreadsheet in this case
google sheets to lay out the topics
ahead of time so you can write the
content for your intended audience that
to me is the way to go now remember
there's lots of different forms of
content that you can use with social
media marketing here we have video so
you can see this video could be posted
on youtube or linkedin or wherever and
the whole point is you want to be able
to measure engagement here you can see
this is just an image it's just a file
and this has been posted on facebook so
here we can see many likes and comments
and then shares and so you want to be
able to leverage different forms and
different assets across social media to
see actually what works and what doesn't
work and again look at what other
companies have done whether they be
competitors or not see what type of
assets they're posting and what's
working for them now when it comes to
social media marketing there's lots of
tools available okay you got buffer
hootsuite sprinkler post planner later
sprout social i mean the list of social
media marketing tools is endless and
just like seo you will need a platform
to work with so with seo we showed you
moz as the seo platform with social
we're going to show you sprout social
because with sprout social if you have a
content calendar if you have a lot of
different assets you want to be able to
organize those assets and content across
multiple channels and the great thing
about using a social media calendar is
yes you can publish and organize your
post accordingly you also have most
social media platform tools have
listening so you can listen in on
keywords and audiences different brands
and industries and conversations that
are being had about a specific topic
okay and again most social media
platforms if not all
have reporting and so this is important
because you can actually see
you know what how your post or different
assets are performing in terms of
engagement and so to me that's important
if you're going to focus on social media
as a platform as a channel you want to
have a social media platform tool that
will help you organize your content
publish it accordingly listen in and and
get that report to help you figure out
what's engaging and what's not engaging
again so that you can you know react to
the content that you're using and
sharing so that's sprout social as an
example but you will need a social media
platform now the other benefit to
social media is in some cases you could
actually
pay to have your post out there and so
for example on facebook we could set up
a paid campaign to target our intended
audience and so with facebook facebook
owns instagram so you have the ability
to really put your content out in front
of your target audience on facebook and
instagram and so
what you need to do is go to facebook
ads manager and simply just create an
account or campaign um you want to be
able to create a campaign and by
creating a campaign that means you're
going to have to go
through a particular process here so if
we first we want to do is choose our
objective okay so you always want to
have an objective for your campaign so
is it going to be brand awareness is it
going to be to drive you know traffic
is it going to be to drive conversions
so you want to choose a goal or
objective if you're advertising really
on any platform then you want to be able
to choose your audience so who are we
trying to target so with facebook you
know you can target any specific age
gender demographic based on interest and
behavior so you can choose specific
placements and you can assign a budget
okay and then on the ad side you have
different types of ads that you can use
you can do a single image or video you
can do a carousel okay meaning you can
rotate different images as a collage or
different videos as a collage and again
you can choose exactly where you want
your ad to be shown for example desktop
or mobile news feed
facebook in-stream video
you got instagram feed you got even
messenger so you have a lot of options
available to you on where your ad or
video is going to be shown and then you
can support that with a headline
description and
you can send that traffic back to your
website you can even test call to action
buttons okay so you can append your ad
with a call to action button and so you
can do a lot here this is just facebook
you can really do a lot of specific
targeting now with facebook advertising
it's a cost per click model so anytime
somebody does click on that ad you're
going to pay but it allows you to really
get your content out there in front of
your intended audience if you're not
doing it organically meaning you're not
posting on facebook on a regular basis
or maybe you want to supplement those
organic posts then
doing this is a good way to really get
your brand out there if it's awareness
if it's to drive traffic or to convert
facebook is a good option linkedin
twitter all these social media platforms
offer that up that option up to do paid
advertising now if you want more
information about social media we have a
great video on youtube already how to
start social media marketing it really
goes into the details about organic
social and what i just covered with paid
social specifically on facebook so take
a look at that video and again if i
missed anything on the social media side
feel free to comment or add in your best
practice whether that be part of the
process or a different platform that you
use for social media okay let's switch
to our next digital marketing channel in
search engine marketing
so search engine marketing is an
advertising model
that is good for driving traffic to your
site because you're paying each time
someone clicks on your advertisement now
how is that an equal trade well
because you can advertise on channels
like or search engines like google or
bing or adroll which has a a big network
that includes google you can actually
pay your way to the top of search engine
rankings and so if you're at the top for
paid search and
somebody searches something like shoes
or something to that effect your ad can
appear at the very top even above local
search even above organic search and so
the visibility is there it's a good way
for you to then
get that traffic that
that you you covet for certain keywords
and because you're getting
traffic or have the potential to get
traffic you're going to pay each time
somebody clicks on these ads so
you have multiple choices on the type of
asset you want to use including text
image video etc so
there's more to it than just google bing
ad role i mean you have linkedin you
have twitter you have facebooks you have
lots of different ways to advertise and
get your ad in a more prominent position
you just have to pay for it and i just
showed you that under social media
marketing facebook you can create an ad
have your ad targeting your audience and
in return you're gonna pay facebook
works the same way for most of these
networks okay so when you actually set
up a campaign
like anything you do when you set up a
campaign you want to determine the goal
you want to achieve for the campaign you
want to do that up front especially when
you're talking about pain per click if
you're paying per click then you
definitely want to make sure you
determine what your goals are so you can
measure them accordingly then you want
to choose in this case a relevant list
of keywords you could do it for your
brand meaning you could choose your own
brand keywords you could choose keywords
related to what your brand is trying to
offer whether that be a service or
product and
once you choose a relevant list of
keywords you can finalize those keywords
and then bid on them so
once you start bidding on them then what
you're going to do is align those
keywords with a headline so it's all
done within the framework of any
platform you're advertising on really
the key here that i want to really
emphasize is when you establish a
campaign or set up a campaign you need
to establish what the goal is because
when you actually choose your keywords
and write your ads and launch the
campaign and start paying google or bing
or whomever
it is you're advertising with you want
to be able to measure those goals so
that's really the important part here
because
regardless of where you advertise you're
going to be able to monitor campaign
results and so with google you can even
import conversions into the campaign so
for example if i go to google ads for
example if i go to tools okay you can
see i'm running campaigns what am i
trying to accomplish with these
campaigns well in this case i'm trying
to get donations people click on
donations so i can go to tools click
conversions and then i can see what
conversions are added to my account and
that way i can measure my campaigns
against these conversions okay if i
don't see a conversion error i can
certainly create one or import it from
in this case google analytics so that's
the important thing you want to be able
to measure your campaigns
with your conversions and then just as
important you want to be able to
optimize your campaign because if it's
not performing if you're running a
campaign you're running up costs and
you're not getting conversions you're
probably not going to be continuing to
run those campaigns so you want to
optimize your campaign and retarget
potential customers so retargeting is
always a good option retargeting is
targeting someone who that went to your
website and basically
acted in a certain way meaning they went
to a certain page or abandoned the card
or actually purchased or downloaded
something okay you define what action
you want that audience to take in order
to retarget to them okay so the whole
point is you can configure your
retargeting campaign based on certain
behavior on your website and the whole
point there retargeting is you're
pulling people back to your website so
in addition to optimizing you know
search campaigns you can one of the
benefits of search engine marketing is
you can run retargeting campaigns so
here's an example of an ad okay so here
you can see
it's a good ad in the sense that
it's using everything available to it so
for example here i could see three
headlines so google in this example
allows you to add in three headlines so
here you can see simply learn official
site get certified get ahead then you
can see simplylearn.com
so they're taking advantage of three
headlines and then here you can see two
description lines and so each
description line you can have up to 90
characters and so you want to be able to
take advantage of what google gives you
the more information you can add the
better well here you can see some other
types of ads here you can see a banner
ad for slack okay here you can see
betterment.com running an ad okay so
this looks like an ad that is on youtube
so because you can see
after a few seconds you can skip the ad
okay so here's a video ad here's an
image ad here's a text ad so depending
on what platform you advertise on you
have an option on what type of asset you
want to use you know the one thing i
like about facebook is they offer up a
multitude of options in terms of assets
so you can run a single image ad you can
run a carousel meaning you get a
multiple images you can run a video you
can run a combination video image you
can obviously run text okay with a
thumbnail so you have a lot of options
in terms of the type of ad you can run
so before we move into our next channel
let me just show you an example of you
know how an ad actually looks on a
particular website so here you can see
i'm on buzzfeednews.com
okay here you can see
uh volkswagen golf is running an
advertisement in spanish on this
particular site so
they're either using google or some
other platform and having that platform
if it's google post their ad on this
particular site so here you can see it's
a banner app and if we're in google ads
and you're setting up a text ad let me
just run through you with that text that
looks like remember you want to always
take advantage of what's offered to you
because especially text ads you have
very few characters and with very few
characters it's hard to get your message
across so with google you have your
final url which is where people are
going to go to after they click on your
ad but you have one not one not two but
three headlines that you can take
advantage of so we're talking about help
and child hunger help today you know you
can always add in visit our website for
more info
i mean you want to take advantage of
what's available to you now
again here you can see in this example
i'm only allotted 30 characters and so
if you go over then your ads not going
to get approved so you really have to be
cognizant of the character counts and
getting your point across because
writing text ads is not the easiest
thing to do when you're limited to
characters now with google you have what
they call display path so after the
domain you can add in a couple of
keywords in there and then you have
description line one and description
line two so again take advantage of
what's available if you're not sure what
copy to write grab some from the website
and paste it in there you want your ads
to be healthy
and to have as much information as
possible and then the one thing i will
say about google ads is they also have
extensions so extensions are exactly
that they're extensions to your text ad
so here you can see i have four
extensions these are actually site links
so google ads offers up something called
ad extensions so it could be call outs
site links can be location extensions
app extensions they have a number of
different extensions that they can
append to your ad so take advantage of
that as well remember the whole point of
ads is to make a compelling case for
your product or service so that somebody
can click on the ad and go to your
website and then perform the action you
want them to perform now if you have any
more questions about google ads feel
free to check out our in-depth video
about google ads it covers everything a
to z on google ads you know we also have
videos on our simply learn youtube
playlist for facebook uh twitter social
media marketing so if you're curious to
know a little bit more about search
engine marketing you know check out any
one of these videos that we have listed
on our youtube channel okay so let's
move over to affiliate marketing now and
so with affiliate marketing
really it's interesting and unique and
that affiliate marketing involves paying
out commissions and who are you paying
commissions to while you're paying
commissions to website owners or
publishers or people who have websites
with lots of content or people who have
websites that attract a lot of users and
so the whole point is you want to be
able to find those websites to advertise
your product or service okay these
people who are selling your product or
service on your behalf are going to get
commissioned or incentivized based on
whatever action you put out there so it
could be registrations just getting your
affiliates to help you with
getting people registered or signing up
for your email or
you know for a lot of you conversions
you're trying to sell a product so you
want help in selling that product or it
could be subscriptions okay signing up
to something okay so
you determine what it is you want to
incentivize your affiliates for you also
determine how much you're going to
incentivize them and that's the great
thing about affiliate marketing it's
it's no different than having a sales
team um to support you what are the
steps for affiliate marketing well you
need to find a platform there are lots
of different affiliate platforms out
there you know commission junction or
cj.com comes to mind because these
platforms are going to help you find
these affiliates or partners okay so
they're the broker and all this and so
once you set up your platform you're
going to establish rules guidelines post
images and banners and assets for those
affiliates to use on their websites and
more importantly again you're going to
establish the commission so the
commission doesn't have to be the same
for all affiliates it could simply be
you know your top affiliates get a
higher commission as opposed to just
some other affiliates who get a starting
commission you establish everything on
the platform the affiliate platform that
you choose now affiliates apply to
advertise on your behalf so they're
going to say hey i'm interested in
selling your product or service so
you're going to use that platform if
it's commission junction to approve or
disapprove the re affiliates request to
advertise on your behalf and really what
you want to try and do is leverage the
platform as best as you can a lot of
these affiliates are out to make money
and some of them are really good you
need to be able to choose the affiliate
that is going to represent your brand
product or service the best so it's
simple customer clicks on an ad or link
okay on that affiliate website and they
go to your website and they perform an
action so that could be a purchase or
registration a subscription a download
an email sign up you determine that and
the great thing is these affiliate
networks the cj's commission junctions
of the world will record everything
they're tracking not only traffic from
the affiliate website to your website
but they're also tracking the
conversions the transaction is validated
and credited to the affiliate by the
broker and then the affiliate has paid
his or her commission so that's how it
works so the more the affiliate sells or
converts on your behalf the more they're
going to make and that's the beauty of
the affiliate network so here's an
example of affiliate marketing okay here
you could see uh an advertisement here
okay so you can see profit from our
experience earn up to 12 advertising
fees with a trusted e-commerce list
leader so somebody clicks on that link
joins and then this person is going to
get a commission based on somebody
joining for free again i mentioned
commission junction there are also some
other affiliate marketing tools out
there
uh
amazon associates a win trade doubler
max bounty i mean there's there's
there's a lot out there
cj.com is the one i've used in the past
but you know give some of these other
platforms a chance okay it doesn't hurt
to even be on multiple platforms you
have nothing to lose okay when you're on
a platform basically the platform again
is acting as the middle person they're
introducing you to affiliates and so
every time you actually pay an affiliate
a commission they're going to get their
cut of it so they're going to get a
small percentage as well so just keep
that in mind but you know give it a try
try one or two of these affiliates if
you find you're getting quality
affiliates that are selling your product
or service great if you don't then you
know feel free to change you know
affiliate networks it's that simple but
the key here is
find the affiliates you think are going
to best represent your brand product or
service because those affiliates are
likely going to be the ones to convert
for you and if you're small business
starting out and you need some help
affiliate marketing is the way to go
okay let's move over to native
advertising okay so native advertising
so negative advertisements means that
your ad is showing up next to content
that basically
naturally fits so these are advertisers
that are featured on a platform
alongside the content okay that isn't
paid for okay so for example
here you can see a paid post okay this
is by spotify okay this paid post okay
was on buzzfeed this particular post was
probably on a news article related to
music because they're talking about your
bands that probably won't exist without
led zeppelin okay so for spotify
you're using native advertising allows
them to put their ad next to content
related to their ad here you can see
another buzzfeed article okay 11 great
amazon deals that will be music to your
ears if you're an audiophile here you
can see
an advertisement next to the article so
you can see the ad about led zeppelin
and here you can see the actual article
is about music so the whole point about
native advertising is making sure
there's a connection between the ad and
the article so spotify is advertising
okay their product and service on an
article on buzzfeed which happens to be
about music so a good example we used
buzzfeed just a second ago so if we go
to buzzfeed here you can see i'm on tv
and movies and here you can see got an
ad here if we scroll down
uh keep scrolling down we can see
another ad here for hbo and so this ad
makes sense because
it's placed on tvs and movies so people
who go and read the content are gonna
see an ad related to that content so
that's generally what native advertising
is you need to be able to be able to
place the ad on the right pages okay so
you're gonna need it and network for
that so we talked about paid search
advertising we talked about google ads
so google ads has the ability to place
your ad natively on particular pages
that are relevant to that ad so that's
really what native advertising is all
about making sure that your ad is placed
next to content that's naturally
relevant so if you need more information
about affiliate marketing feel free to
visit simply learns youtube channel we
have a nice uh in-depth video about
affiliate marketing to get more
information about the platforms how it
works and all the tips and best
practices about how to run a successful
affiliate marketing campaign so let's
turn our attention to email marketing
now so email marketing very traditional
form of digital marketing it's been
around the longest it's kind of the
grandfather of all digital marketing
channels so email marketing really is
used to personalize emails in order to
convert that recipient or that
perspective user into a customer and so
like all the other digital marketing
channels we want to follow some type of
flow or process or methodology and the
first step in email marketing is you
have to identify your target audience
okay when you identify your target
audience you're gonna create a segment
okay so in other words you don't want to
send one email to everyone because not
everyone is going to be interested in
that email so in order to get somebody
interested you need to be able to send
an email tailored to that audience okay
so that audience can respond and react
accordingly so once you target that
audience and create segments email
segments you're going to create the
campaign and set up an appropriate call
to action one note here is when you
create the campaign and set up that
appropriate call to action that call to
action is going to be aligned with your
goal so what is the goal of the email
campaign is it simply to get people to
click on something and purchase or is it
simply to get people to click on
something and sign up or watch something
or submit some information or download
or whatever the case you need to
establish that up front just like you
would with a search engine marketing
campaign or any other type of campaign
you want to run so
there are lots of tools out there just
like with affiliate marketing you want
to choose an appropriate email marketing
tool there are plenty to be had each
work in a very similar nature
some
offer different pricing models meaning
you know you can send an email to ex
recipients for flat fee or you pay a
small amount per email address each one
is slightly different in terms of how
they price but in terms of the features
they all work in a very similar fashion
and we're going to show you an example
of one here shortly so when you choose
that email marketing tool you're going
to test your emails before you send them
out and then when you test your emails
you're going to use that email marketing
tool to actually send the campaign after
it's been tested okay so you want to
send the campaign you can immediately
send them out or you can schedule them
now a best practice with an email is
when you actually send one out you're
sending an email out to your target
audience you want to create probably two
emails per segment audience why because
you want to add an attractive subject
line and copy to the email but if you
send two emails to the same target
audience then you want to test the
subject lines you want to be able to see
what subject lines going to entice
somebody to open the email okay that's
the beauty of email marketing is you can
do that okay so you can set up your a
design based on your target audience but
it's always the subject line that people
see first so you want to write an
attractive subject line and copy that's
going to entice somebody to open the
email so wanna send two emails to each
target audience that way you can see
what email subject line works best so
that's the whole idea about performing a
b test to test out different ideas it
doesn't necessarily have to be a subject
line it can be the same subject line two
emails but the difference being the body
of the email it's totally up to you but
the idea here is to always split out
your emails per target audience and just
like any other channel whether it be
affiliate or search engine marketing
organic search you want to analyze
performance and in the case of emails
it's always about open rates how many
people are opening then how many people
are clicking and then how many people
are actually responding are they
converting or downloading or whatever it
is you want them to do you need to be
able to monitor the behavior because for
example if your open rates don't work or
they're low then you know something's
wrong with your subject line so you want
to be able to make an adjustment so
here's an example of an email from
airbnb it's a simple email okay they're
just simply trying to get somebody to
click on that call to action to take the
survey okay that's really all it's about
here with this particular email so who's
their target audience well their target
audience could be somebody who's already
stayed at
a airbnb property or it could be
somebody who used the app probably
airbnb has already targeted this
audience and they're sending this survey
to a particular audience so that they
can get the best results okay so that's
a good example of a targeted email with
a good call to action that's getting
somebody to take the survey so they're
probably measuring how many people
opened it how many people clicked on the
cta the call to action and then how many
people actually filled out the survey so
you need to follow each step and track
each step accordingly okay so again some
popular tools used in email marketing
let's take a look at mailchimp here
but i will mention like marcato is a
good marketing automation tool
now owned by adobe marketo allows you to
send those drip campaigns so if somebody
doesn't purchase right away you could
send up follow-up emails like say one
day out or seven days out or 14 days out
so hubspot works in a very similar
fashion you want to be able to
methodically plan out your emails that's
the point i'm trying to make here so
let's take a look at mailchimp so if we
go over into mailchimp a very easy
interface okay here if we go under
audience we can actually see who our
audience is and we can break out our
audience into different groups you can
have a simple test list you can have
people who purchase people who subscribe
to something okay so you can break out
your audience into different groups okay
when it comes to campaigns you can see
campaigns that are already been built or
you can create your own campaign okay so
in the case of mailchimp we can actually
see
what campaigns have been dropped or sent
out already and then we can see
the opens the clicks and then the
conversions so mailchimp has some nice
reporting so you want to be able to
measure
the reports or how well the campaign
performed so here we can see
specifically how many people open
clicked how many people bounced or email
addresses bounced and how many people
unsubscribed from the list and here we
can see
you know the top links that have been
clicked okay the subscribers with the
most opens did anybody perform any
social media activity okay what
locations open the email okay so you can
actually see a lot of good information
here right in mailchimp and you want to
be able to react to the emails you send
out so if an email is not performing
okay you want to learn from that so you
don't make the same mistake again great
thing i like about mailchimp too they
have a lot of nice templates to use so
if you're trying to create a template
here you got some templates that you can
leverage so that's mailchimp kind of in
a nutshell
mailchimp you could pay upfront buy
credits and with those credits you could
send out emails to a number of people
okay so that's how mailchimp works they
do have a free trial so you can set up
an account using the free trial now if
you need any more information about
mailchimp or email marketing in general
take a look at the email marketing
webinar we have set up on our simply
learn youtube account now let's finish
up with online pr
press releases so we talked about seo
and social and search and affiliate and
email marketing and content native
advertising let's talk about online pr
here because with online pr
it really does involve
working with digital publications or
blogs or other content related websites
for example
content related websites could be
newspaper digital newspaper sites like
the new york times okay the whole point
of
online pr is you want to try and get
some publicity on those on those
websites publicity means awareness for
the brand it means traffic to the
website and eventually some loyalty
future customers and conversions
channels that can be used to maximize
your online pr efforts for example you
can connect with reporters on social
media to develop a relationship so you
can just follow some reporters see if
they're covering specific uh industries
or verticals and if they are similar to
what you're offering then it's probably
a good idea to reach out to them you can
use engaging user reviews to help
humanize your brand or you can respond
to comments that help generate
productive conversations so those are
all certain things you can do to
generate awareness and buzz for your
brand so really the one thing i want to
point out about online pr
is
basically you can also hire a pr firm
and they can do some of the heavy
lifting for you or like i said you can
reach out to different reporters or
different influencers even to help push
your product or brand now if you're
trying to go at it alone on the online
pr what you could do if you don't reach
out to reporters or influencers or
you're active in trying to build your
brand
through a conversation you can always
use a third party service like pr.com so
pr.com allows you to you know basically
create your own profile you know submit
content to your own profile or even
submit press releases if you submit
press releases then other news agencies
are going to pick up on those press
releases so it's a good way to get your
press releases out there likes of yahoo
and google might pick up those press
releases and give you some you know much
needed visibility you can also use other
tools like you know pr newswire for
example so it works in a very similar
way
again it's a press release distribution
network so you can go ahead and sign up
for an account get that press release
out there and they do the distribution
for you or you can also use aggregation
sites so there are lots of different
aggregate sites out there and so what
aggregate websites do
is they help disseminate and distribute
your content so here you can see
some of the new aggregator websites of
2019 you got feedly
panda tech mimi
metacritic e science news the morning
news so you have a lot of options
available
to get your content out there okay so
what these sites do is basically pick up
articles that fit their website fit
their theme fit their target audience so
you do have options in the form of
third-party tools as well okay so if you
don't hire a pr firm which could be
expensive you can certainly go at it
alone by signing up for any one of these
particular products or services today
we're going to talk about digital
marketing tools so fasten your seat
belts and let's get started so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a look at some of the
best digital marketing tools so past
present and future digital marketing
tools is the way to look at this uh with
a good focus on a lot of different
marketing channels here so we're going
to focus first on seo talk about some of
the tools related to on-page and
off-page we're going to switch over to
paid search talk a little bit about paid
search tools we're going to talk about
email marketing and some of the email
marketing platforms and the tools within
those platforms the center of it all is
web analytics so google analytics is the
tool we'll be taking a closer look at in
today's webinar and all that it has to
offer okay affiliate marketing we'll
talk about some of the
tools available to you and for affiliate
marketing we'd be remiss we didn't talk
about social media and all that it has
to offer and all the metrics and tools
available
all the platforms available so we'll
hone in on a couple of examples there
and then we'll also talk about some
competition tools available for you so
there's a whole suite of tools the one
caveat being hey if you have your
favorite tool continue using it in fact
if there's a tool that we didn't mention
in today's webinar feel free to mention
it in the comment box below this video
we'd love to hear what you're using to
manage your particular digital marketing
channel okay and so the goal for today's
webinar is hey we hope you get something
out of this in terms of using new tools
there's some tools that i use some tools
that my colleagues use everybody uses
different tools so it'd be good to kind
of see what else is out there so if you
have something to share share it by all
means what we're trying to do is share
what we think are
you know best practices and
some of the most
popular or most used tools out there in
the industry so that's what we're going
to do the goal is to get you to
better understand some of the tools
we're using a little bit more detail and
what we're going to do is start out with
search engine optimization okay so
search engine optimization or organic
search we have a mixture of paid and
free so there's a lot of different
platforms but if you're focusing on seo
you certainly need to
use an seo platform so there's sem rush
okay you also have google search console
which is free so if you don't have a seo
platform you definitely need to be using
google search console and so we'll take
a closer look at that there's google
keyword planner which is actually
situated under google ads and so if
you're running google campaigns on
google search network or even the
display network you have access to a
great tool called keyboard planner and
if you know anything about seo you'll
know that using google's keyword planner
is a good tool so we'll take a look at
that moz is a freemium tool meaning they
have a free trial that you can sign up
for to test drive it but it's another
seo platform and it does cost money got
a great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in
ahrefs that help us with all aspects of
seo primarily focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
gonna hone in on but this is just a
small subset of what really is available
out there on the market so let's go
ahead and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about seo is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is google's
keyword planner and google's keyword
planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested
in
optimizing for because not only one are
they relevant but two they're going to
have high volume and low competition so
let's take a look at an example in
google's keyword planner so here i am
i'm in google's keyword planner and as i
mentioned before google's keyword
planner is situated under google ads
okay so you have to have a google ads
account to use google's keyword planner
and so when you're in google ads you
simply go to tools and then under tools
you're going to select keyword planner
so what we want to do is look for
keywords we're focusing on organic
search not necessarily paid search so
organic search we want to hone in on
some keywords so let's just use one of
the examples that google's given us here
mail delivery so we're going to just
type in mail delivery and get some
results so notice i can enter a domain
as a filter and so in other words hey i
could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if i wanted to
but i'm asking google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
i'm going to click click get results
notice i can add another keyword if i
wanted to but i'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that i can certainly hone
in on if mail delivery is my business
and so let's just hone in on that one
keyword mail delivery we want to be
found organically for that keyword so
what google keyword planner does is not
only give us the keyword and other
keywords relevant to that but it gives
us the average monthly search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months and notice here i
get a
column for competition so
i'm able to see whether that's a very
competitive keyword or not and then just
to give you an extra edge when you're
choosing keywords you can get a sense of
what the keyword may cost if you wanted
to bid on that for paid search so for
mail delivery i can see it's anywhere
between
seven dollars and forty six cents and at
the top of the page high range sixteen
dollars and sixty one cents so that
should alert me to the fact that hey if
i'm gonna try and optimize for this
keyword i know it's competitive because
not only google is telling me it's
competitive by telling me high
competition but i know that the cost per
click seems a little bit high and what
is a little bit high well you know i can
see some other keywords here that you
know a dollar to three dollars okay i
could see some other ones that are even
lower than the seven dollars they're
suggesting so that's a indication that
the keyword is highly competitive so the
idea here using google's keyword planner
is one we want to get an idea of what
other keywords are out there that are
relevant so it helps stimulate some
ideas for relevancy two we can get an
average monthly search volume so we want
to know on average over the past 12
months how many search queries i can
expect from this keyword and then three
i can get a sense of the competition how
competitive is this keyword so if i try
to optimize for this keyword and i want
to rank for it organically is it
competitive if it's competitive then
it's probably going to take me a bit
longer to be found for this keyword on
page one of google so that's the whole
idea behind google's keyword planner and
note that you could change some of the
settings here so if you want to choose a
different language okay you can hone in
on a longer shorter period of time you
can even choose a specific location so i
chose taxes i can certainly choose the
entire united states to get a sense of
what the volume would be for the total
u.s so you have settings that you can
change and manipulate to get you the
data you need to choose keywords so
that's the whole idea behind google's
keyword planner to find relevant
keywords high volume low competition now
alternatively i can certainly use
another tool
to find keywords so
i have a moz account so i logged into
moz and moz has a tool called keyword
explorer so if i use that same keyword i
used in google's keyword planner mail
delivery i'm going to ask maz to give me
some data on that keyword so this is for
the entire united states and again i can
change that if i wanted to okay so i can
hone in
on a specific country or different
country so what moz is telling me hey
for this keyword in the entire united
states i'm looking at anywhere from
eleven and a half thousand
to thirty thousand on monthly volume now
what moz does is they give you a
difficulty score so a difficulty score
is a score between 1 and 100 and so i
could see this is pretty much right down
the middle in terms of difficulty okay
so if it's zero it's an easy keyword if
it's if it's a hundred it's very
difficult and then that means
you have a lot of competitors who are
optimizing for this keyword that are
ranking for this keyword and so
moz gives us the volume they give us the
competition and they just like google's
keyword planner gives us some other
keywords that we can potentially hone in
on so
here i could see
keyword delivery plans delivery services
etc so i can see a lot more suggestions
than what's listed here so moz delivers
a bunch of other analysis
related to the keyword you know they
also give you some good keyword
suggestions so moz is a good alternative
tool and we'll be coming back to moz
related to seo for some other of its
features but for now if you don't want
to necessarily use google's keyword
planner because maybe you're not running
google ads you can always use mazda
remember moz has
basically a freemium version meaning you
could sign up for a free account and you
could sign up for a free account as a
test trial and you could test it for a
period of days and leverage its tools
during that free trial to get a better
sense of how these tools work so we want
to be able to use mods we want to be
able to use google's keyword planner not
only to search for all those relevant
keywords available to you but we want to
be able to choose keywords with high
volume and low difficulty low
competition we also want to select
primary and second keywords wisely so
remember when you optimize you're
optimizing a page for more than one
keyword so you want to be able to have a
nice
portfolio of diverse relevant keywords
with high search volume and low
difficulty and then you want to be able
to identify those keywords that your
competitors are ranking for so moz gives
you that information
and so we want to be able to leverage
the tools available to us to choose the
right keywords so if you need any more
information on this
we got a nice webinar on keyword
research for seo so take a look at that
video on youtube and to get more
specific details about using seo tools
for keyword research and all about
keyword research in general for seo so
let's talk about some other reasons
under seo what we would use some of
these tools available to us well we want
to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor
backlinks okay we also want to analyze
linking to our web page okay which ones
are good which ones are not good okay we
also want to perform some competitor
analysis so these are some of the
reasons why other than keyword research
why would we use some of these seo tools
so we have tools available to us some
majestic hrefs again moz let's take a
look at google
search console and i want to hone in on
google search console because it is free
and it's a must if you're going to work
on seo you need to be working in google
search console and so the whole key
behind google search console is you have
a website and you need to get that site
verified once it's verified when school
can recognize that you are
associated with this website then you're
going to be able to see
some important information so here i'm
looking at a website and what am i
looking at i'm looking at something
called coverage under index so what does
coverage mean well going back to what we
just said we want to be able to
understand how google's crawling and
indexing our pages and so what google
does is through this platform search
console is there letting us know once
they go to our website and start
crawling it and they pull these pages
back to their server they're letting us
know
if we actually have any issues so here i
can see
i have some issues with 112 pages and
some of those issues are listed down
here so there could be a crawl issue a
you know redirect okay so
you could see there's some five unique
issues across 112 pages so here i could
see submitted url marked no index
there's a hundred of those pages we have
some redirect errors there's seven pages
that you fall victim to this error and
so we can really hone in
um what the error is and address the
error okay so if google's telling us hey
this is an issue and you want that page
indexed by google
then we should probably address the
error and so that's the great thing here
about going into google search console
is you can under index go to coverage
and get a sense of what google is
indexing and what they're not indexing
okay so these are the errors i could see
they've certainly were able to crawl and
index 9115
pages they were able to crawl okay and
they excluded 54 000 plus pages and then
we also have some pages with some
warnings so this is kind of an overview
of
what google sees when they crawl our
site so when they say crawl they're
coming to our site they're following
links on the site and every link they
follow they're either going to index
that page or they're going to report to
you an error or an issue that they found
if we want these pages indexed we need
to
address the issues the errors and so
that's the beauty of this report here is
google is telling us firsthand what the
issues are so we also want to take a
look at the sitemap so you have an
opportunity to submit a sitemap and a
sitemap is just a formatted file that
includes all your website urls and so
you're going to
have this file
sitting in your root directory and
you're probably going to call it or
should call it
sitemap.xml xml being the format so once
you have this file you're just going to
let google know that that file exists so
you're going to enter in the sitemap url
so if it's in the root directory all
you're going to do is type in
sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what google's going to do is say
hey look we see you've submitted this
and we last read it a couple days ago
and we could see
that we discovered
1419 urls so i can go back under
coverage and i can see some of the
issues that they found but if i go back
under site maps i can see that these are
the urls they've discovered via the
sitemap and so the whole point of a
sitemap is we want to be able to get and
push the urls to google not have google
come to our site and discover them so
this is a quicker faster more efficient
way to communicate with google all the
urls that you have on your site that you
want google to index and so that's the
beauty of search console now while we're
in search console we might as well take
a look at some of the other features it
has and so one of the most important
features under search console is this
mobile usability report okay so google
is a staunch believer in mobile first so
nowadays most people start and finish a
lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so they begin it on
mobile and they may end it on mobile so
if they don't end it on mobile then you
know perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
google is a staunch believer in
definitely a lot of what's going on
today starts with mobile so they want
you to understand
how your site fares
via mobile and when i say fares via
mobile is it mobile friendly is it
responsive is it loading quick enough
you know is it formatted to google
standards and so if there are any issues
google is going to let you know what
those issues are so here i could see
google's recognized 206 pages before
different issues okay so here i can see
what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are and so here i can see for
206 pages text too small to read click
elements too close together
the viewport not set to device width and
then content wider than the screen so
there's 10 pages that fit under this
error and if i actually click on it the
error i can see what those 10 pages are
and so when we're done we can actually
when we address the issues we can
actually have google validate whether
the fix has been made so you can
definitely use this as a means of
communicating directly with google
telling google look i see what the
issues are i'm going to fix them and
then i want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with google and let them
know hey
we do recognize the errors we are fixing
the errors please validate them you know
it's going to draw google's attention
google's going to validate them and get
these pages indexed quicker
so if you ignore the issues and the
errors especially for mobile then you
stand the chance of your pages not
getting indexed so the mobile usability
report to me is an important report
because we want to better understand
whether google's picking up issues on
mobile and if they are we want to
address them get google valid them so
google can index them quicker now
there's another report that
is of interest to you or may be of
interest to you in google search console
and that's the links report so the links
report in google search console shows us
what pages have the most links okay so
here we can see the home page has 26 000
plus links if we hone in on interior
pages we can see the links to those
pages okay so we can get a sense of what
are the top link pages from external
links meaning links on other websites
pointing to these pages i can also see
internal links so google is recognizing
links from within my website from one
page to another so external links
internal links both factors for seo when
ranking so then i can see top linking
sites what sites are linking to my site
and then i can see top linking text so
google search console has given me kind
of an overview of what my leaking
structure looks like okay so externally
i want links from other websites
pointing to various pages on my site and
i certainly want my pages linking to one
another on my site and so i'd be able to
better understand what that structure
looks like using google search console's
links report okay there's one more
report that i think's of interest in
google search console and that's the
performance report so the performance
report is a report that actually you can
link up with google analytics so you can
see the same report and analytics if
you're able to link up google search
console with analytics and you should be
able to do that all you need to do is
make sure you use the same email address
that you use for analytics and search
console so it needs to be the same email
address you could certainly link up the
two and have this data imported into
google analytics so what is this data
that we're talking about well it's
called performance so what we can
actually see is the queries the actual
queries people are typing in to google
so when they're typing them into google
we can actually see
how many impressions the keyword queries
received and how many clicks the keyword
queries received and then i can see
click-through rate and average position
okay so here i can see
for this particular keyword on the first
line i could see
over the course of the last three months
it received 209
297 impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used at le
or typed in as a query at least that
many times and that's how many times my
listing appeared in the google search
results pages based on this particular
query and so as a result
of somebody typing in this query 209 000
plus times this site received 120 000
plus clicks so to get a sense of the
click-through rate all you would need to
do and google can obviously do this for
you is you would simply just divide the
209 000 297 into the 120 000
397. okay so that's really going to give
you that's going to give you a
click-through rate and the click-through
rate in this case is 57
so
over half of the clicks occur
when
this listing appears for this keyword
okay so we can get a sense of
the click-through rate for each one okay
and you could simply just use the
filtering here now we can also see
average position okay so
we could see a little bit more than that
too we can go from queries to pages we
can go from pages to countries so we get
a sense of how many impressions and
clicks i'm receiving by country and
importantly we can see by device so here
i can see a majority of the people who
conduct a search related to my website
primarily do it on desktop now i
mentioned the beauty of the google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to google
analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
google search console and then from
there you can choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so i can
see the same data that i see in search
console but this time i'm looking at it
in google analytics and so here i can
see what my search queries are my clicks
my impressions my click-to-rate bike
search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when i
link up google search console with
analytics i'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we're going to use these seo
tools available to us and so we already
listed a number of different reasons
ranging from
site maps to keyword research but we
also want to hone in on you know what
domains are
driving links to our site so i showed
you an example in search console we also
want to
hey maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks so search console is a great
tool for that because if we don't want
to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and no follow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates and impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report we
can identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
google search console report but if you
have a platform like moz you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see
for the keywords that we've chosen that
we want to optimize for we could
certainly see where they rank the great
thing about moz is it's a great tool not
only for rankings and on-page
optimization but
for off-page optimization as well so
if i go ahead and take a look at a
domain for example i'm just going to
type in this domain
i'm going to be able to get what they
call a domain authority so a score out
of 1 in 100 i'm able to see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links i have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well
so here if i click on the linking
domains i'm going to be actually able to
see
the actual domains
pointing to my site as an external link
and not only can i see the domains i can
actually see the domain authority of
those domains so if there's a domain for
example that
doesn't have a good domain authority and
the site appears a bit scammy per se
then we can disavow that so i can
certainly look at all the domains that
are linking to me and then i can
highlight the ones that have poor domain
authority what mazd even takes it a step
further they also give me a spam score
so moz is able to measure how spammy a
website is so if i have a combination of
say a low domain authority
and a high spam score then i probably
want to disavow myself from that site
and so i can use this report here you
can see here as i keep going down for
example i could see this particular
website has a domain authority of 26 and
it has a spam score of 16
so not a good combination this should
alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has
so many links pointing to me or it has
at least one link pointing to me that i
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is i'm
able to hone in on not only who's link
linking to me meaning domain but how
many linking domains does that domain
have what's the spam score of that
domain what's the domain authority of
that domain and then i can get into a
little bit more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about
backlinks domain authority
spam etc everything you need to use in
order to measure off page seo so that's
the great thing about moz is they have
not only on-page seo tools but off-page
seo tools and moz is a freemium so to
speak so
here you can see if you just go to
moz.com
free dash
tools you'll be able to use some of
these tools available to you not just
for seo but also for local seo as well
so here you like some of these tools you
can start your free 30-day trial so i
use and lean on moz a lot for all that
it has to offer from
choosing keywords to rankings report
to checking issues on my website to even
checking who's linking to me so this
fits in the mold with everything i need
to do for seo so in addition to that
keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on seo so
we've done a webinar on seo tools and
we've also done a webinar on seo tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or seo in general take a look at those
two videos and
check them out and that should kind of
complement what we talked about with
using some of the tools google's keyword
planner
uh moz and google search console okay
let's switch over to email marketing
tools and so with email marketing tools
we have a lot available to us
in the form of
reporting in the form of platforms in
the form of you know tools that really
help us go from a to z on our email
choosing you know what email to send out
to creating a list to measuring how the
email campaign went and so we could
start with mailchimp because mailchimp's
a freemium version when we say freemium
meaning they have a free trial available
then you're expected to upgrade but you
know mailchimp to me is a tool i use i
like the interface very easy for
beginners so we're going to take a look
at mailchimp but there are certainly
many others available you know marcato
is a good tool you know marcato is a
good tool because
if you have a business and you're trying
to funnel people through
your pipeline so to speak meaning
they sign up as a lead and you want to
nurture that lead from the beginning to
the end meaning at the end they're
actually going to turn around and
purchase well marketo is a good tool for
you to use because you can then set up
trip campaigns or also known as email
campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a hubspot a very powerful tool
it does a lot from creating landing
pages to a b testing to social
to
you know email so
this is another freemium tool that you
could use you have another freemium and
send in blue
email platform and then you also have
convertkit another email platform
there's more dimension that we can't
even fit on this screen now if you have
a favorite email marketing tool that you
use constant contact vertical response
there are plenty out there emma you know
feel free to to note that in the comment
section below this video i'm curious as
to how many people actually use you know
different tools because there are so
literally so many email marketing tools
out there why because email marketing
has been around probably the longest
amongst all the other digital marketing
channels and a lot of people use email
on a daily basis so
it's no wonder why there's just so many
tools available and so with these tools
you can certainly send bulk emails now
in the case of marketo you could send
emails to a segmented audience and so
that's
actually what you want to do as a
strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around that particular audience so you
know you have a good tool when you can
do that when you can really segment for
your audience okay you want to be able
to use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users you know use
transactional emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like i
mentioned with marketo you want a
workflow set up where
hey if somebody does this you're sending
email b etc so you want an email
marketing tool that's flexible enough to
handle what your business strategy and
goals are okay so you want to be able to
also use a tool that
you know has various email templates
available okay you don't want to be
stuck with just a vanilla template again
you want to be able to customize an
email for your audience you want to be
able to manage your list appropriately
meaning
if you have 10 000 users or emails in a
list you want to be able to manage them
accordingly you know break them up or or
have sub lists so to speak and then most
importantly you want to make sure you
have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning you know what percentage of
users opened your email what percentage
of of recipients clicked on your email
what links do they click on you know
which which emails bounce so you want
some detailed insights right in the
platform that you're using it just makes
it more simpler and easier and more
effective to manage you certainly want
to create those smart automated
campaigns meaning you don't even have to
send out the email and then you want to
be able to have some flexibility to set
up email delivery based on a specific
time of day so these tools also allow
you to
you segment contacts based on
geolocation you want to be able to use a
tool that allows for multivariate
testing
again you want to analyze performance
and optimize campaigns you want to
trigger automatic responses
somebody purchases something are you
using a tool that will automatically
send that email out so these are all the
reasons why you would use an email
marketing tool so let's dive in and take
a look at an example and we're going to
use mailchimp as our example today so
let's dive in and take a look at
mailchimp so with mailchimp once you log
in you know you're going to be able to
see
some historical campaigns that you've
sent out or you're going to be able to
create your own campaign and so
this is kind of under campaigns you can
kind of see an overview of the ones
you've sent out or if they're in draft
mode you'll be able to see they're in
draft mode so you can go ahead and edit
them so here we have one that was set up
on august 26th and it's still in draft
mode so we can go ahead and edit that so
if we just click edit you know we have
the flexibility to
you know pick and choose who we're
sending this to who it's from what the
subject line is and then we can
certainly
design the email so if we click design
email again this is important because
with email marketing you want to be able
to
cater your email to your intended
audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with the intended audience and so
here you can see mailchimp allows us to
do that okay you can see
some of the layouts here okay you also
have themes that you could choose from
okay you could search for different
themes or you can even just code your
own so you can just paste
your code in or you can import it so
mailchimp allows that flexibility you're
not stuck with one of their templates
and so if we go back to the dashboard
the one thing i like about mailchimp
though is the reporting okay so
yes it is easy to choose a template and
map that template to your audience but i
really like the reports that they have
to offer
so you know here you can see there's
some lists that we've sent to
and if we choose one of our audience
list
then we can see some really detailed
reporting here and so
here i could see this email that was
sent out in june i could see it was sent
to 95 000 plus subscribers okay of the
subscribers i saw 2000 plus open it and
157 clicks so i can view this report in
more detail just by clicking on view
report so again we want an email
platform that's going to be able to give
us some detailed information about how
that email campaign performed and so i
can get down really to the nitty gritty
i can actually see
you know on the content what was clicked
and what wasn't clicked so here i sent
two different subject lines so i'm able
to compare the two against one another
okay so i can really go into detail
about one of them here so if i click
view report i can specifically see what
the average for this list is so here i'm
able to compare against the list average
and it's 16
i only had an open rate of 2.5 percent
so the industry average
is 18
and so here i'm able to see the list
average for the click rate and the
industry average for the click rate as
well so then i can see some specifics
about it how many people unsubscribed
then i could see
a graph i could see the top links that
were clicked okay the top subscribers
with the most opens i can link social to
it if i want to and then i can see
geographic information so the point
being is mailchimp really goes into some
nice detail here
about
the email campaigns and how they
performed so the great thing is too with
the mailchimp you could link it with a
google analytics you can link it with
e-commerce okay so if you have an email
and you're you're selling products and
somebody purchased that product
mailchimp is able to integrate in with
your
shopping commerce platform for example
woocommerce so if somebody did purchase
you can send out that thank you email
mailchimp even goes a step further and
if somebody did click on a link go to
your shopping cart add something to the
shopping cart and then abandon the cart
you know mailchimp allows you the
opportunity to retarget them via email
so mailchimp is flexible and that's what
you want in a email marketing platform
you want something that's flexible that
you can cater to your audience you can
manage your audience list and you can
get detailed reporting on your different
campaigns for that audience so that's
mailchimp in summary and so most email
platforms do a lot of similar features
or have some similar features but that's
what you ideally want to look for in an
email marketing platform so here's a
tool that doesn't get talked about
enough when it comes to email marketing
and that's google's url builder and the
reason why we're going to talk about
this tool today is because most people
in the us
use google analytics as their web
analytics tool and the one thing about
google analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
google you can certainly track the
performance right in google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
mailchimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call utm
tracking so for example
if i have a url that says visit florida
and i'm going to send out an email i
have up to five parameters that i can
use okay so here's my email or url that
i'm using in the email so i have up to
five parameters that i can use to track
this particular email so let's go
through some of those parameters
so the first one is campaign source so
what's the source of the campaign well
we could certainly identify
male champion for using mailchimp as the
source now the the thing about the url
builders you always want to use
lowercase because google analytics is
case sensitive so as a rule of thumb
just stick with a lower case so our
source is going to be mailchimp because
that's the platform we're using if
you're using you know constant contact
or vertical response or
you know some of these other one
convertkit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now for the
medium which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site let's go
ahead and put in email because that's
what we're using to drive traffic to
this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're going to call this the summer
promo so the summer promo here is visit
florida beaches okay so we're going to
send this email out to the masses and
particularly not only the masses but the
masses in the north because we're gonna
say hey look come to florida for the
summer come visit our beaches that's the
point of the campaign so that's what
we're gonna use for the campaign name is
whatever the campaign is it's a summer
promo now
notice i got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email i would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do i say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say
you have 10 000 recipients
i want to be able to split out the email
into two segments one segment that's
going to get subject line one
and one segment that's going to get
subject line two so
in this case i'm gonna put whatever
subject line one is
in the campaign content field so now i
have four parameters
and once i've entered in my variables in
those parameter fields i now have a
revised or appended url so my original
url was visit florida.com
ian-us
florida-beaches.html
my original url i've now appended that
with some utm parameters
and now i see my original url appended
with the utm parameters based on those
variables so i can copy it just by
clicking the copy url
i can go to my browser i can paste that
url in there and i want to check to see
if it works so here i could see this
particular page loaded florida beaches
with my utm parameters appended to the
url so that's for the first subject line
that's for the audience that's going to
get the first subject line i want to do
another one for the second subject line
so now i'm going to change my campaign
content parameter to subject line
underscore 2. i'm going to copy that url
i'm going to check it
okay so i can see that the page loads
with those utm parameters and so now
what am i gonna do i'm gonna use the
first url
and the second url in my email okay so
any link that i have in this case i'm
using subject line two so for the email
with the second subject line going to
that segmented audience this is the link
i'm gonna use in the email so if you
have one or two or three links in the
email this is the url you're going to
use because when somebody clicks on that
link you're going to be able to see that
that click in google analytics so if i
jump over to google analytics after i
send out my email i'm going to go to
acquisition i'm going to go to campaigns
i'm going to go to all campaigns now
based on the variables i put into
my parameters meaning source medium
campaign name content or term that's
what i'm gonna look for in google
analytics so we could start with source
and medium so if i click on source and
medium as my primary dimension
here i can see mailchimp and the actual
date was used as part of the variable
for for source and then i will can i see
the medium being email so now i can see
for this email that was sent out in
mailchimp in may i could see
how many users how many sessions and
more importantly how many conversions so
we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to
if we choose some of the other
parameters available to us so here i
could see the campaign name okay so i
could see exactly what campaign what
source what email
drove in traffic and conversions and if
i'm doing subject line testing i can
choose content as my parameter so here
i'm going to change it to content and
now i can see the subject lines in this
case if i go back to
my source medium i'm going to be able to
see what subject lines from my emails
generated
the most traffic and not only the most
traffic but also conversions so that's
the whole point behind using the url
builder again you're taking a url that
you're going to use in email and then
you're going to pan that url with
different parameters campaign source
campaign medium campaign name and then
optionally campaign content or campaign
term okay once you've entered variables
into those parameters you're going to
get an appended url which you can then
use in your email so when the email gets
sent you're going to go back over to
google analytics
and you're going to look at the results
of that campaign of that source of that
medium of that content i.e subject line
and so that's why
the url builders so important because
mailchimp gives us some good insight
as to how the email performed in terms
of open and click rates but what we
really want to see
is how that campaign performed once it
drove traffic to my website so that's
the whole idea behind the url builder if
you're using google analytics you'll be
able to
use the url builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools and this is an
important section because web analytics
tools kind of the central focal point of
all digital marketing and it starts
really with google analytics google
analytics is a freemium meaning that
they have a free version that you can
use there is also a paid version of
google analytics but given the advent of
google its popularity especially in the
united states a majority of users are
using the free version of google
analytics so it's a very popular tool
especially for marketers but there are
also other tools available so it's not
just google so we have adobe analytics
which is also freemium you have kiss
metrics you have spring metrics you have
youtube analytics which is
part of google but
youtube has its own separate analytics
insights so
a lot of these as you can see are free
to use they're available
no reason why you should not be using uh
an analytics tool to measure your
marketing campaigns or website behavior
and why would we want to use these tools
again well again we want to really
measure behavior we want to measure
what's going on with our website so we
want to be able to identify the location
of where our website visitors are coming
from and a lot of these analytics tools
use ip address to identify the location
of a website visitor so if you're trying
to target a specific country then you
want to be able to see that the visitors
to your website are coming from that
specific country or location we also
want to measure the engagement of our
website behavior so
we get traffic to the website what are
they doing how long are they staying
what pages are they visiting so this is
the overall nature of really why we want
to use web analytics to measure how
successful our website is at treating
our website visitors with the same
courtesy you would if you had a brick
and mortar store somebody comes into
your store you want them to find what
they're looking for quickly you want
them to be happy with their experience
you certainly want them to pay for the
products very quickly and easily and
efficiently and you want them to come
back and that's no different than a
website so we want our website to
perform in a manner that's going to suit
our audience and that's why we want to
track engagement so why else well we
want to really look at who's coming are
they returning visitors or new visitors
you know ideally you want a nice mix
between
50 new and 50 returning because you know
returning visitors are loyal there's
some loyalty to that they already know
your brand they're coming back to your
website new visitors are curious and you
want new visitors because that means
more traffic so you want a nice balance
between that analytics tools will help
you measure that you want to be able to
measure organic traffic whether you like
it or not whether you know it or not but
google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing utm
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non google campaigns you
want to use utm tracking and google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically google analytics will help
you
see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with utm tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do i.e are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you can turn around and improve
performance so if your bounce rate is
high well how do you lower bounce rate
well we need to do something about that
and analytics tools will help us
identify what's not working from our
site perspective and from a channel
perspective and we can take action to
improve performance so that's the whole
idea behind optimizing our site's
performance so let's jump into google
analytics and let's take a look at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with utm tracking all those
good things that we can get in a good
analytics tool so adobe
mix panel spring metrics you know they
all work in a similar fashion in that
they're really measuring website
behavior and so if we're in google
analytics really what we're doing is
we're measuring the performance of our
website broken down into four components
audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so what do we want to do we
want to look into each one of these
sections so let's start with audience
and so audience and google analytics
tells us who is coming to our website
now they're not going to specifically
tell us hey rob sanders came to your
website but they are going to say that
somebody from san francisco california
came to the website and these are the
pages they looked at and this is the
language and
they came from this device and they're a
returning user so they're painting a
picture for you okay so they're not
giving you a list of names that would
not be legal but
they are
providing you with a good picture of who
is coming and when i say picture we have
to paint that picture and so if we look
at say demographics for example and i
got a demographics overview here's a
picture i'm painting well i can see that
25 to 34 year olds are the majority of
the age group that is coming to my
website okay i can see on the gender
side of it i can see that 63 of my
traffic and again this is year to date
that i'm looking at is coming to my
website so two-thirds of my traffic is
female one-third male and they're
between the ages of 25 and 34. so i'm
painting a picture about you know gender
and age coming to my website well i can
also look at geo so where specifically
might these people be coming from so if
i go to location under geo i'm going to
be able to see a breakdown of country or
i can even hone it down to city or
specific location and here i could see
the united states is the primary driver
but not by much so we have 16 almost 17
percent from the us
and then 16 percent from argentina 13
from mexico 10 from india so we have a
nice mix
of traffic from different locations in
the world coming to our website so
that's geo but more importantly let's
take a look at mobile so if we go to
mobile overview how are people coming to
our website are they on a desktop or
laptop are they using their mobile
device are they using a tablet and so
google analytics breaks it down very
nice for you and so we could see
percentages and actual numbers by device
category and so in this case i could see
year to date i can see 62 percent are
coming from desktop 35
are coming from mobile and so that's
important because most people start
their journey
from mobile and that is growing
and that's going to continue to grow so
you want to keep an eye on mobile so to
me this is one of the more important
reports under audience because people
who come from mobile have a different
not only experience because the website
should be responsive to the mobile
device but their mindset is going to be
different they're actively looking for
something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to
acquisition so acquisition reporting
tells us how the traffic was driven to
the website so if audience tells us who
is coming to the website acquisition
tells us how that traffic
got to the website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexing your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and i'm a believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines are indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents a
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we could see it
broken down by channel if i go to all
traffic channels report i can see in my
dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic and this is
year to date then i can see paid search
then i can see direct which means
somebody went directly to the site i
could see referral email
social then i could see more paid search
broken out so these are the different
marketing channels
now analytics allows you to look at a
specific source and medium so the source
would be the actual website or search
engine and the medium would
differentiate how that traffic actually
got to the site so if we're talking
about a search engine did they come to
the site via paid search or did they
come to the site via organic search and
so all we need to do is change our
primary dimension from default channel
grouping to source and media and we
could see specifically the breakout of
the different sources and mediums
driving traffic to the site so here i
can see google organic at 71
and then google
cpc or cost per click at 15 16
of our traffic so then i can look down i
could see email in here being organic i
could see some referring sites i could
see some social in terms of mobile
facebook okay so
we could see a mix of the different
sources of mediums driving traffic to
the site okay so you don't always have
to look at channel per se you can look
at it via source and medium and if
you're running google ads under
acquisition analytics has a whole
section of google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on google ads
remember we looked at the keyword
planner in google ads so if you're
running campaigns on google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also
see
campaigns other campaigns that we're
running so remember that utm tracking
that we set up for email well we want to
be able to
track the performance of email and any
other non-google campaign with utm
tracking so when we do that we'll be
able to go to campaigns all campaigns
and we'll be able to see the campaign
performance if we look at source and
media we'll be able to see what
campaigns drove traffic to the website
so here i can see vertical response
email as a driver of traffic so that's
the campaign reporting and then also if
you have search consoles so we looked at
search console earlier we talked about
seo tools well remember i said you can
link up search console with google
analytics well here's search console and
we could see queries devices landing
pages countries so all the performance
metrics that we could see in search
console because we have it linked up
with analytics we can see it right here
so this gives us a nice snapshot
of what keywords are driving traffic to
the site organically i could see the
impressions i could see the clicks then
i could see the click-through rate and
then the average position so in theory
the higher something ranks the more
traffic you're going to get so that's
the idea behind it we want to make sure
that we're ranking for our coveted
keywords and if we are we want to be
able to measure how many times our
listing was seen and how many times it
was clicked so that's the great thing
about you know google they have a family
of products and those products tend to
talk to one another in the form of
google search console and google ads you
can connect them directly to google
analytics so let's move from acquisition
to behavior so
here in behavior
we have a number of different reports so
behavior tells us once the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving and so
really what i would do is from there go
to site content all pages and so this
gives us an idea of how many pages were
actually viewed so site content all
pages tells us what page and how many
times it was viewed during a period of
time and again we're looking at year to
date so i can see engagement related
metrics associated with the page so this
particular page here on line one i could
see how many pages unique pages which is
equal to sessions so i can have a
session come to the website and look at
a page multiple times in that session i
could see the average time the person
has spent on a page and i can also see
the bounce rate so a bounce rate
indicates that they arrived on the page
and didn't go any further they left the
website from that page that they arrived
on and so i can also see percentage of
exits
meaning what page did people exit the
site from so these are all engagement
related metrics so here is where i want
to react and optimize my website
performance so i if i see a page not
performing well meaning it has a high
bounce rate or maybe low time on page
then i'm probably going to optimize it
meaning test it or change it to improve
performance so these are all pages but i
could certainly look at landing pages
okay so landing pages tells us the
behavior of the page when somebody
landed on it so a landing page means
that somebody came from organic search
or paid search or another channel landed
on this page so here i could see this
particular page on line one had
4970 sessions okay and i can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because paige isn't
performing in terms of bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how
fast or how slow our pages load so this
is important from an seo perspective
because if a page isn't loading very
fast then chances of it getting ranked
in google are not very good so google's
organic search basically takes page load
time seriously so if a page doesn't load
very fast then we need to be able to fix
it so we can go to page timings i can
get a good sense of the average page
load time of a particular page and what
google does here is under speed
suggestions they actually will
give me some ideas and speed suggestions
on how to address a page that's loading
very slow and so
when we load up the speed suggestions
report what google does is say hey we
know that this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called page speed insights and page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here i can see if i
scroll down this is desktop and these
are some of the opportunities that i can
address
when trying to improve the page load
time of that particular page so here i
could see there's some server response
time issues image sizes probably need to
be resized i can remove unused css okay
so there are a lot of different things i
can do to improve the page load time on
this particular page okay this is for
desktop i can also see mobile so mobile
a lot of the same issues so if we
address these these opportunities then
we could see a lift and page load time
we see lift and page load time we're
going to probably see a lift in organic
rankings or even user engagement because
if a page takes a long time to load a
user is probably not going to stay on
that page very long so to me
site speed is an important report under
behavior now one more report here that i
want to point out under behavior is
events and to me
events are important so if you're trying
to measure engagement on your website
you need to make sure you have event
tracking set up and when we talk about
event tracking we're talking about
measuring things that analytics doesn't
measure by default so if you have a
button on your website if you have a pdf
download if you have a submit button on
a form submission if you have a
subscribe button if you have a video if
you have an external link anything that
is going to trigger engagement on your
website you need to measure with event
tracking and event tracking is simply
set up by breaking out the event into a
category an action in the label and so
here
we could see for our particular website
we have categories already set up for
event tracking so here for example i can
see on line six video i could see how
many people actually watched our video
okay so here's the action video start
okay so over this period of time i could
see
i had 49 unique events 50 total so
that's how many people actually watched
the video and you can always report to
label and that'll tell you what page
people watched in this case the video so
event tracking is important because we
want to be able to measure engagement so
if you go to events
under behavior and you don't see any
events listed you probably need to get
that set up and that is set up through
google tag manager so
what you want to do is you want to be
able to set up your events through
google tag manager which is another
google platform but you certainly want
to do that so that's where you set up
your events when you set up your events
for your website with a category an
action and label you'll be able to
measure those events in analytics under
behavior under events and the important
thing here is you'll be able to measure
engagement so i'll be able to see how
many people came to the site and how
many people clicked on a button
downloaded a pdf submitted a form
played a video
did whatever we wanted them to do so
events are important so let's move from
behavior to conversions and this is
important because
we want to be able to measure
conversions on a website so analytics
has four types of conversions so if i go
to admin down at the bottom and then i
go to goals i could see that i have four
different types of goals that i can use
now right now
i have event related goals set up for
the website for this particular website
so we just talked about event tracking
so if you're measuring a button click on
your website you can certainly turn that
into a goal and so all you need to do is
tell analytics hey this is the
particular category this is the
particular action so for example
if i click on this particular goal and
take a look at it i can see that we have
a category set up that anything that
resembles donate now okay or donate go
ahead and fire this event as a
conversion okay so event is one type of
goal another type of goal is destination
so somebody goes to a specific page like
a confirmation page we can turn that
into a goal so here i could see if
somebody goes to donation dash
confirmation then analytics is going to
fire that goal as a conversion and we're
going to see a conversion against a
different metric or different dimension
like channel or audience okay so
destination is the second type of goal
the third type of goal is duration so
how long did somebody stay on my website
so in this example if they stayed at
least one minute and 30 seconds or more
then analytics is going to count that as
a goal conversion okay so duration is
the third type and then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if i look
at this example here
if a user came to my website and looked
at more than three pages in that
particular session then analytics is
going to fire a goal conversion so four
types of goals you don't have to set up
all four different types my
recommendation is at least have one goal
set up if you're not sure what goal to
set up then at least set up a duration
or pages per session okay so at least
you can measure how long somebody stays
on your website or how many pages they
went to okay so when you actually do
have these goals set up you can go back
into conversions we can go back into
goals we can go back into overview and
we can measure
our goal completions over this period of
time so here i could see 313 goal
completions total with a goal conversion
rate of point eight eight percent and
then i could see it broken down by goal
type so remember the only goals i have
available and set up are event related
goals so 69 newsletter signups 156
donate click buttons i have 32 contact
form submissions 37 email click
completions and then 11 phone number
click completions so i can measure
engagement as a goal and so goals
generally are important to the business
so you want to make sure that if you
have a goal for your website then you
want to be able to set that up as a goal
in google analytics so that way when
you're looking at example
channels if i go back to my channels
report i can then measure
channel by goal conversion so these are
all goals but if i want to look at for
example
how many people from organic search
clicked on the donate now button i could
see that i could see year-to-date 10
887 users which meant 11 000 sessions 76
clicked on that donate now button and
that's comes out to 0.65 percent
conversion rate okay so that's important
so you want to be able to measure
any dimension whether that be channel
source medium keyword campaign
mobile device could be demographic
gender or age you want to be able to
measure any dimension against the goals
you have set up so you can measure
performance and that also includes pages
or landing pages as well so that's a
quick overview of what you can expect to
see
in google analytics again audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
a lot of data in google analytics but
you want to be able to take advantage of
the data in order to improve website
performance now let's jump over to
youtube analytics because if you have
videos on youtube if you have a channel
set up some playlists you'll be able to
get some really good insights as to how
your video is performing and so here i
could see
i'm in youtube all i did was i went to
my account then i went to the beta the
studio version of youtube and then from
there i went to analytics so my account
youtube studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
i could see over the last 28 days my
videos produced over 8 600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over 17
and
i've netted 48 subscribers and this is
an overall
okay so i can actually see when i
publish videos and i can see the date
they were published and here i'm looking
at you know total views over this
particular date range i can also see
specifics on a particular video so i
could see the top video in terms of
minutes here i could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here i could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview i could certainly look at some
other information if i click on reach
viewers i could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so here i
could see the different traffic sources
so 29 came externally okay here i could
see 25 came within youtube itself i
could see how many times a video was
viewed and played via playlist via
suggested video so i could see different
ways in which the traffic found my video
and actually watched it here i could see
externally how people were able to find
my videos and i could see 46 percent
found it via google search see some lots
of information here about sources of
traffic how the traffic got to these
videos so i could see then once the
traffic found my videos how many times
they actually saw it and viewed it and
then watched it so that's how many times
i was able to reach viewers via
different sources and then their
reaction to that how many times i saw it
and watched it here i can click on
interest viewers so again i could see
the top videos in terms of
watch time i could see the top playlist
so here i could see my partners playlist
was the top playlist so i could see some
interest here in terms of average view
duration and then here we have build an
audience so we can look at specific
audiences if we have them built in
youtube to see how many people actually
watch my videos so here i can see 88
of the people who watched my videos over
the last 28 days were not even
subscribed so that tells me a lot of
people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in youtube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if i just click on one particular
video i can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself i could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via youtube search i could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it i could see all sorts of information
on a particular video
itself or
an overview of my channel so that's all
available to you in youtube analytics
under youtube studio so take advantage
of that so if you're publishing videos
on a regular basis you want to hone in
on how your videos are performing so if
you have any additional questions about
youtube analytics or youtube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
youtube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into youtube itself especially
youtube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about youtube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spying tools very
important to keep tabs on what the
competition is doing and there are a lot
of tools out there so when it comes to
social we can use a freemium tool like
sprout social to listen in on our
competitors we can use another freemium
tool social blade there's a popular tool
out there called spyfu that's freemium
as well moz we looked at moz earlier for
keyword and organic mozz is a great tool
for also
leveraging our competitors in terms of
backlinks and buzzsumo so that's another
freemium tool get there lots of tools
out there these are just examples of
some of the tools that we use here at
simply learn i use personally and
professionally to get a sense of what
our competition is doing so why would we
want to use a competitor spine tool well
it may sound like a very straightforward
question but there are lots of reasons
why and so let's look at some of these
reasons and the first reasons we really
want to identify you know our
competitors backlinks and monitor
changes in the ranking so the reason why
we have this is the top bullet point is
because seo organic search is a long
term strategy on page off page website
very technical and creative there's a
lot going on with seo
a lot going on and
sometimes it takes a long time to rank
for something and a lot of seo does
depend on relevancy relevancy being how
many quality backlinks are linked to you
so it's always good to leverage what
your competitors are doing so you can
see how you stack up and so that's why
this is up there as number one we want
to be able to really take a look at what
our competitors are doing another
example would be
hey how much uh traffic a competitors
gaining on certain keywords this could
go either way for paid search organic
search what are competitors bidding on
are they really getting traffic from
those keywords so there are tools out
there that help us leverage what our
competition is doing okay we can also
identify our competitors top performing
content for relevant topics okay we can
determine what our competitors website
referral traffic is okay we can pull our
competitors data and compare it with our
own campaigns so lots of tools out there
to help you do this and we may want to
track the total amount of clicks a
competitor receives and how much they
pay for each keyword so let's go and
take a look at a few examples how we can
leverage all these bullet points that we
just discussed and so we're going to
start out with sprout social and sprout
social is a tool i use it's a social
media platform there's a lot of things
you can do with sprout social definitely
generate reports for your social media
platforms you could set up posts that
get published at a certain time and day
but there's also one particular tool in
here called listening and so what we
could do is we just put in for example
rv rentals in twitter so what we're
doing is we're actually listening to see
who else is tweeting about rv rentals so
we could do this for twitter we could do
it facebook some other social media
platforms the whole idea here on sprout
social is to get a sense of what our
competitors are doing so we could have
easily put in a brand name we're just
going general here because we want to
rank for the keyword rv rentals and so
here we could take a look at you know
what some of these particular brands are
doing like go rv rentals cruise america
rv we could see just scroll down and we
can get a sense of in particular what
people are tweeting about what other
companies are tweeting when it comes to
this particular keyword rv rentals now
if i want to hone in on a particular
competitor i could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand names
or every share so here i can take a look
at you know what they're doing when
they're posting or tweeting how long ago
the time of day get an idea of what
they're actually saying what campaigns
they're promoting okay i can get a sense
of everything about this tweet and so
here i can scroll down and i can see
what's been shared by other people for
this particular brand and i can see a
lot of people are as an example
retweeting this particular giveaway and
so to me it just gives me a sense in
this particular example on twitter as to
what our competitors doing okay let's
turn our attention to seo so remember
that first bullet point we want to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
when it comes to backlinks and so moz
has a great tool called link explorer
and link explorer there allows us to
actually compare link profiles so for my
domain i can go ahead and put my
competitors domains in there and
definitely get a sense of
you know how many links my competitors
have external intel internal i can get a
sense of the domain authority i can get
a sense of page authority linking
domains so i can really do a
comparison
across my domain and my competitors
domains to get a snapshot of how i
compare against my competitors so this
gives me an overview of everything i
need to know organically now moz also
has another great tool under link
explorer called link intersect and i
like link intersect i use it a lot
because if our competitors really have a
number of external links and domains
pointing to their site and they have a
better domain authority and page
authority then you know i want to be
able to you know see what they're doing
where they're linking who's linking to
them i want to get be able to get a
snapshot of why is their domain so much
better than ours in terms of authority
and so the link intersect actually
allows me to do that so i can go ahead
and put my competitors domains in there
and then i can find opportunities and so
you just click on opportunities and you
can see where
my site intersects with their site and
if it doesn't actually intersect then i
have an opportunity to
actually try and get a link on that
particular site so that's what the link
intersect report does it allows me to
see where my links intersect with my
competitors and if it doesn't intersect
then i have an opportunity to generate a
backlink so that's ideally what the link
intersect tool is in moz it allows me to
really get a sense of you know where i'm
linking and where my competitors are
linking now what we can also do is also
take advantage of another report under
moz's link explorer and the discovered
and lost report so we could put in our
domain or we could put even our
competitors domain in there and we can
get a sense of what domains were found
and linked to them so really within mods
we can get a good snapshot of what web
sites are linking to our competitors we
get a good snapshot of the overall links
to our competitor sites and specifically
with sites so the whole idea is if it's
good for our competitors meaning they're
linking from a site that has good domain
authority and low spam score then it's
probably a site i want to be able to
tackle as well okay so you have
discovered and lost okay you have
comparing link profiles and you have
link intersect so those are three good
reports you can leverage right in moz's
link explorer tool now there's one more
report we can leverage in moz and that's
the inbound links report and so we can
go ahead and type in our competitors
domain here and again we can get a
snapshot of what their domain authority
is page authority for the home page but
really this is what we're after linking
domains so this particular domain has
over 9 000 linking domains so what we
can do is actually go through and see
based on domain authority i could sort
by domain authority where these pages
are being linked from and so here i can
see reddit reddit reddit so a lot of
reddit here which is a good site for
backlinking new york times so
you know there's a lot of different uh
sites here washington post so i can get
a good snapshot of my competitor by
seeing every link that's pointing to
them now of course i don't want to go
through 9 000 links i can really just
hone in on a specific link source or
link type or link state so i can really
filter it if i wanted to i can export
the report and do some further analysis
but really the whole idea here as i
could see what url
is linking to this particular competitor
site what the anchor text is what the
page and domain authority is so this
gives me a really really good insight on
all the backlinking that my competitor
has and again if i'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so if we're not on reddit
then we probably need to be on reddit
because if that's where our competitor
is and they're getting good link juice
from reddit which has a domain authority
of 90. then hey if it's good for the
goose it's good for the gander so they
say so
inbound links is it just another good
report you can leverage in moz under the
link explorer reporting tool now if i
want to get a good snapshot as to what
my competitors doing on search exactly
well look no further than spyfu so spyfu
is a another tool that you can leverage
from a ppc seo perspective you know from
an seo perspective you got some back
linking data as well just like you did
in moz from a ppc perspective you can
get some good keyword insights and so
here i just went ahead and typed in the
domain and what this is going to do is
just give me an overall snapshot for my
competitors domain so here i could see
you know how many organic keywords
they're found for the estimated monthly
seo clicks they're getting based on the
volume of those keywords okay i could
see here the keywords their top
competitors also rank for the rank
history 12 years so this particular
domain has been around a long time okay
so that's on the organic side flip over
to the paid side and i could see that
they are doing paid search i could see 5
000 plus keywords they're bidding on
okay based on that what they're actually
paying and then i could see you know
some of the other competitors listed
here from a paid perspective and an
organic perspective i could see the
shared keyword overlap okay now again
you can pay for this because it's
freemium and get some really good
insights as to how your domain compares
to your competitors so i'm using the
free version and here the free version
spyfu is just giving me some overall
data on the specific domain i entered in
and so i entered in my competitors you
can certainly enter in your own domain
to get a sense of organic keywords and
paid keywords so you can see top
keywords top paid keywords okay this is
google ads okay so this is what
recommendations as to what to purchase
okay here you can see some even some at
google ads history i could see exactly
what ad copy my competitor actually
wrote and for what keyword and then i
can see some organic ranking history
here as i keep scrolling down this
overview report so i can see for rv rent
where they rank and then i can see
inbound links just like i did in moz
spyfu is providing me with some insight
as to hey what links are pointing to
them and what the domain strength is and
how many clicks they expect to receive
so this is all free data take it or
leave it but it's all free data
available to you under spyfu so spyfu
gives you kind of an overview for free
some really in-depth analysis if you
actually pay for it and it just really
hones in on what your competitors are
bidding for paid wise and what they're
ranking for organic wise and so spyfu is
a really good tool to leverage if you
just want to get a snapshot of how your
competitor
overlaps with you so let's turn our
attention to google analytics because in
google analytics under audience i can go
to benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports allows me to see
what the industry as a whole is doing
compared to my own website now the
caveat here on this particular report is
that it's all anonymous data so i can't
exactly see what competitor is doing
what in this report but if i hone in on
my industry in this case autos and
vehicles and i hone in on a specific
country or adjust the size of the daily
sessions that i get then i could see hey
analytics in this case in this example
i'm sharing 8 863 web properties okay so
they're sharing the data for over 8 000
web properties and i can compare those
web properties against my own so if
we're all in the same industry it gives
me a sense here as to how i stack up
against the industry as a whole in this
case as it pertains to channels so you
can see here red not good green is good
so in the industry we're not doing as
good as others in the same industry who
are receiving the same amount of
sessions now we could certainly adjust
and
we can adjust our locale and if we do
that google is going to be able to
adjust how many web properties are
actually contributing to the report and
so when analytics makes that adjustment
we're going to be able to see in this
case just new zealand so we're going to
adjust for new zealand and
we're going to go with the 4999
and so we could see there are about you
know 300 something web properties
contributing 47 web properties now
contributing to this report so we're
focused on the new zealand region and
this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
anonymous web properties so now if i go
back to the report after i've honed in
i'm looking at channels and i could see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how i compare against the
competition i can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session average session
duration bounce rate but that's just
channels i can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your industry so you're getting a
good idea as to how you compare against
your industry just by making some
adjustments in the benchmarking report
you obviously want to make sure you're
looking at the same industry adjust for
your country or region adjust for the
site size meaning how many sessions you
actually get on a daily basis and then
analytics will do the rest they'll
compare you against those in your
industry and so i find this to be a good
tool because it allows me to stack up
our site against those in the industry
and obviously if we're not driving as
many sessions especially say from
organic then we have our work cut out
for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmark report now if you
want to get some good insight as to what
the competitors are doing and you don't
want to use a tool well look no further
you can always go to google.com okay so
this is how we used to do it back in the
day before all these tools became
available you just typed in a keyword
and we're going to type in rv rentals
and now we're going to be able to see
who's bidding on that keyword so we
could see we have a number of different
uh companies bidding on the keyword
we're interested in okay here i can see
some featured snippets okay and then i
can see some organic search results okay
if i scroll down i'll be able to see
some other companies bidding on that
same keyword meaning they're paying for
rv rentals so if i clicked on somebody's
link here they're actually going to pay
google for the click and so this just
gives me a good sense of you know how
many people are actually
trying to rank for this keyword or
trying to be found for this keyword so
that's all i did i just did a search now
from an organic perspective if you
really want to hone in on your
competition you can always do the syntax
all in title colon and then hit enter so
now
i could see i have 163 000 results and
what does that tell me that tells me
that i have 163 000 websites with rv
rentals in the title tag so if you're
trying to optimize for the keyword rv
rentals as an example then you know that
you have 163 000 different listings
ahead of you that you need to jump over
in order to rank for the keyword rv
rentals so using the all in title syntax
and the keyword right after that
actually just gives you a more accurate
picture of how many sites are actually
ahead of you for a particular keyword so
that's the whole idea so if i get rid of
the syntax and you can see for rv
rentals i have 132 million but that's
not really accurate because not all
these listings have the keyword rv
rentals in the title tag and title tag
if you're working on organic search is
one of the key important factors for
ranking so you need to have that keyword
in the title tag so that's the whole
idea behind using the all in title
syntax it gives us a good idea as to
what our competition is doing and how
many sites we have to jump over to get
to number one on google now if you're
running google ads just as we did with
rv rentals we went up there and we saw
we typed that in as a query and we saw
how many advertisers there were for rv
rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns google ads actually has a good
report that i really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and what auction
insights allows us to see is
what competitors or domains are bidding
on the same keywords we are and so what
google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here i'm looking
at year to date and here we could see us
and i can see our competitors okay so i
could see impression share so for if
we're talking about one keyword every
keyword has a hundred percent impression
share how much of that impression share
are you getting and when we say
impression share meaning eyeballs when
we talk about eyeballs are we getting a
majority of the eyeballs or our
competitors getting majority of the
eyeballs so we can see our average
position i can see how often i overlap
with my competitors okay i could see how
often i'm above a particular competitor
i could see what percentage i'm at the
top of the page versus my competitors
the absolute top of page rate and then i
can see how often i out rank my
competitors and vice versa how often my
competitors outrank me so i could see
all this good insight as to what
competitors are bidding on the same
keywords i am okay so this is if you're
running google ads okay so if you're
running google ads okay you can just
click on the auction insights report you
can find that the top navigation just by
clicking on campaigns and by doing so
you'll be able to gain some insights as
to where you stack up from a paid search
perspective against your competitors so
let's turn our attention to paid
marketing tools so if you're doing some
advertising on google bing linkedin you
probably want to work within those
platforms as the tool of choice so
you know if you're doing paid search
on say google search dot com or display
you could be doing display advertising
on you know a network like adroll or
google or you could be doing social
media paid ads say on facebook so
whatever it is you're doing you probably
want to work within that platform itself
to get the ideal data that you need okay
so here are some of the tools some of
the places you can go of course if you
work in google ads you also have google
ads editor that you can leverage okay
and i'll show you that in a couple
minutes you have google ads keyword
planner of course both of these are paid
if you're running campaigns okay so bing
if you're running campaigns on bing okay
you get all this good data that you can
digest do some reporting okay you also
have some third-party tools out there
that you also have to pay for in word
stream okay so
wordstream's a third-party tool that you
can leverage bing and google
are actual advertising networks so you
would advertise on the platform itself
and get all the data you need right in
the platform and leverage a lot of the
tools that they have available in the
platform as i mentioned you could also
use google ads editor
so bing also has their own editor as
well so and as well as facebook so you
can use an editor type version and i'll
show you that here in a couple minutes
but let's talk about why we want to use
the tools in the platform itself well we
want to be able to monitor how our ads
performing so which ad receives the most
traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords converting
not converting you know they cost us a
lot of money and not netting a high
enough return for us so we want to keep
an eye on that okay so we want to
monitor our cost okay across different
locations and devices not only cost but
we want to also monitor how our ads are
performing across different locations of
devices keywords across different
locations and devices so we want to be
able to
measure by device okay so we also want
to analyze competitors data and as we
showed you in the competitors section
google as an example has auction
insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so
google itself does provide some
information in the case of auction
insights as to how
uh your competitors are performing
against you on google search so
that's on the paid search side then you
have display okay so
display advertisements okay you're
across a different network so there are
different types of networks out there
for example avril okay yo cortillo
celtra is another paid version or paid
tool you can use in wide orbit so these
are some of the paid marketing tools you
can leverage
of course i like to stay if i'm
advertising on google i like to stay on
google ads and measure my display
performance that way but if you're on
adroll for example then you want to
leverage adroll's reporting platform and
some of the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools well just
like search for example where we want to
look at keyword and ad performance same
kind of concept here we want to be able
to monitor whether we have the right
keywords and right customer engagement
so
when it comes to display
we want to be able to
make sure we're choosing the right
audience of course that means looking at
not only audience insights but our
target insights as well are we reaching
the right audience when it comes to
display and google has a good breakdown
that i'm going to be able to show you
here in a couple minutes okay so we want
to improve our campaigns by monitoring
our competitors display ads as well so
there are tools available that will help
you do that and that's on the display
side and if we look at social okay why
what tools can we use on social well you
got facebook ads manager okay you got ad
espresso choir tweepy you got all these
cool paid search tools again i usually
stick with where i'm advertising so if
i'm advertising on linkedin or twitter
i'm going to leverage that platform but
just know that there are
other tools available for you so a
social like display it's all about
targeting our audience so for these some
of the tools like on facebook we can
review and relaunch our ad campaigns
based on target audience we can measure
conversions and gain insights
in this example about facebook users how
are our users
interacting with our ads and then we
want to target people based on their
activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel
preferences etc so social allows us to
do that and then
with facebook as an example we can
monitor any a b test we run for example
if we're running
call to action test we can measure the
results that write in facebook and i'm
going to show you an example of that
here shortly so let's jump right into
google ads and look at some tools
available to us
from the search side of the house so for
running search campaigns right in google
ads we could see campaign data we could
see keyword data we could see ad data so
for example if i want to see what ads
are performing i'm just going to click
on my ads and extensions okay and here
are my ads and now i could see
what ads are performing in terms of
clicks click-through rates etc and so
that way i can go ahead and pause ads
activate ads so that's right here in
the google ads
platform itself now if i want to look at
specific keywords i can do that so i can
see what keywords are driving traffic
and clicks here i can just sort by
clicks and now i can see not only what
keywords are driving clicks i could see
what the click-through rate is i can see
the impressions how many people actually
viewed my ad after click typing in a
keyword query that i'm bidding on i
could see
how much i've paid by keyword and more
importantly i want to be able to see
conversions or conversion rate and then
with google ads you have quality scores
so we want to be able to measure quality
score so this is a google
ads keyword reporting and so the great
thing about
the keyword reporting is that there's
some other features available to me here
so here i can add negative keywords okay
just by clicking on negative keywords i
can also see a search terms report and
so when it comes to search terms i can
actually see what specific keywords
people typed in
and
based on the keyword that somebody typed
in as a query i can see what match type
triggered that particular ad and so if i
see a keyword query that i don't
particularly care to be shown for or i
want my ad shown for then i can go ahead
and just select it and i can add it as a
negative keyword okay so that tool is
available to you right in google ads
okay and then you have the auction
insight so we've reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive analysis and so here if we
look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see
basically you know who else is bidding
on the keywords and what the impression
share is what their average position is
what the overlap rate is position above
right top of page absolute top of page
right now ranking share so once we have
google has data then they'll be able to
share that information with you okay so
that's just keywords but there's a cool
tool that i really like and i leverage
it for seo and pay-per-click and that's
google's keyword planner so if you click
on tools and then you click on keyword
planner we'll be able to
leverage the keyword planner and the
whole idea behind the keyword planner is
do we want to discover new keywords or
for the keywords we have selected we can
get volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if i click get started okay so
google's going to give me
some other keyword ideas and they're
going to give me what the average
monthly searches are for that keyword
they're going to let me know the
competition they're going to give me a
range in terms of how much i can expect
to pay for that keyword so if i happen
to click on that keyword i can add it to
a plan and then once i've added to a
plan then i can go ahead
and
look at that plan and
measure
what kind of volume i'm going to get and
how much i can expect to pay so now once
i've added my keyword to that plan i can
go ahead
and
see how many clicks and impressions and
costs and click the rate and average
cost per click i can expect to spend so
and this is based on
a maximum cpc of two dollars so i can go
ahead and adjust my plan accordingly if
i want to in order to see
basically how much i can expect to spend
so that's the whole idea behind the
keyword planner in terms of choosing new
keywords and once you choose keywords
you're interested in bidding on you can
actually do a forecast to see exactly
how much you can expect to spend how
many clicks how many impressions you can
expect to get and
if you have conversions set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so
there are so many
different tools and features within
google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so
really i'm just going to highlight some
of the more important tools and features
so i mentioned the keyword planner i
mentioned the campaigns keywords and ads
reports another thing i would look at in
google ads again we mentioned this as
one of our key defining why would we use
it bullet point and that's because of
devices so we mentioned devices why
would we use google ads reporting tool
because we want to look at devices and
we want to be able to see
what devices are driving traffic from
what campaign and then the cool thing
about
google ads is write in google ads
platform you can go ahead and do a bid
adjustment so if i increase my bid
adjustment for example on mobile phones
then my particular ad in this particular
campaign is going to show more than on
computer so i can always decrease it for
example do a bid adjustment on computer
and that means i'm going to show my ads
less so
i can go ahead and do bit adjustments
based on device that's the cool thing of
working right in google ads platform is
you can make adjustments right here in
the platform based on devices well you
also have locations too so we mentioned
that as one of the reasons why we want
to use some of these tools and
if i see a particular location i'm not
interested in advertising well i can
always select it and i can always just
pause it or remove it so
or i can change the bid adjustment on a
location as well so i can make a lot of
different changes right in the google
ads platform for those seasoned in
search advertising paid search
advertising especially on google ads you
can always use google ads editor all you
need to do is just do a search for
google ads editor you can download it so
basically
what google ads editor is it's a it's a
tool it's the software that you work
your ca with your campaigns on locally
so you're making changes to your
campaigns on your computer and basically
when you're done making changes you can
always
upload them to google ads to the account
on google ads in the cloud so to speak
so that's the whole idea behind google
ads editor it's a great tool for you to
use if you want to make household
changes really quick for example i'm
looking at an account with a bunch of
campaigns so now if i click on one of
those campaigns i could see the ad
groups here okay so for example i just
wanted to turn off all these ad groups i
can just highlight them all and just
click status enabled to pause and i can
revert back if i want to okay so you can
make household changes so here i could
see the campaign the ad group level if i
choose an ad group then i can see some
keywords and again i can make changes ad
nauseum here i can copy i can paste i
can delete okay so i can make a lot of
changes really quick right in google ads
editor and that's the whole point of
editor is to go ahead and work locally
while somebody else is working locally
on the same account you could both be
working simultaneously and
being more efficient on getting things
done in the campaign now if you are
working with somebody else on the
campaign you want to make sure that you
get recent changes so if i say get
recent changes to all campaigns what
google editor is going to do is contact
google ads in the cloud and download all
those changes so here i can see the
changes being download an editor from
google ads and when it's done it's going
to highlight all the changes that have
been made and so
once i'm done reviewing those changes i
can go ahead and click done and now i
know i have the recent latest changes in
editor so now i can go ahead and
continue to make some changes and when
i'm done making changes i can go ahead
and post them so that's the beauty of
google ads editor bing has a version
facebook has a version it allows you to
again go at the keyword level the ad
group level okay you can look at ads
itself and make changes to the ads okay
you could do a lot of different things
right in editor in fact you could do
pretty much most of what you could do in
google ads you can do in google ads
editor and so that's google ads editor
to me i would recommend it if you're
experienced with google ads again it's
software you have to download it you're
going to use it on your computer as
software but when you make changes all
you need to do is post those changes or
get recent changes that have been made
on google ads and so that's google
editor ads editor in summary now let's
go back into google ads and talk about
display advertising because display is a
different network but the platform's
still the same and some of the same
tools are available from the search
network as well as for the display
network right in google ads so if i want
to take a look at a campaign and ad
group on the display network i could
just click on that ad group and i can
look at the ads that are running for
that particular ad group on the display
network so here the difference being on
the display network is you can use image
ads on the search network you can only
use text ads so here i can look at image
ads and i can see how they're performing
in fact you could even go a step further
and use responsive display ads so google
has responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now i can see clicks
impressions click-through rate etc right
on
on my ads and extensions report in
google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so
we want to be able to see okay of the
audiences we have set up what audience
is performing best okay so here i can
see a breakout by audience again i could
see the same metrics i could see on the
search side i could see clicks
impressions click-through rate more
importantly i want to be able to measure
conversions okay so that's the whole
idea when you're in these platforms and
you're paying for ads is you want to be
able to measure against conversions and
you can also measure against cost per
conversion conversion rate okay so those
are some key metrics to measure up
against whether it's audience keyword ad
whatever the dimension is so here on the
display network we can get a sense of
demographics okay so unlike the search
network the display network allows us to
see demographic data and so now i could
see an age breakout or an age range
breakout that google provides us and i
can see again based on the age range
breakout which age range has the most
clicks impressions etc including
conversions so you also have the
opportunity on the display network to
add keywords you have the opportunity
topics and you have the opportunity to
see placements or run placements so here
if i click on where ads have shown i can
actually see where my ads have shown up
for this display campaign and google ads
allows you the ability to go ahead and
you can exclude it from the ad group or
exclude a specific placement from a
campaign so you could take action on a
specific placement and i could see the
type of placement whether it's a mobile
app whether it's a site i can go ahead
and see exactly where that placement was
so that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising i
just want to remind you we do have you
know a nice tutorial on google ads okay
so take a look at the google ads
tutorial we have set up on youtube okay
if you search for google ads tutorial
2019 this is a good uh tutorial on
everything related to google ads so
check out this video because in today's
webinar we're just mentioning tools
across the board and if you are
advertising on google ads as most people
do
then you can see just how powerful it is
and all the different features that are
available so take a look at the video
it's a nice complementary video to this
one this digital marketing tools and
this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on google ads and if you have any tools
or features on google ads whether it's
the search network or whether that's the
display network
then feel free to comment below this
video happy to hear your comments about
what tools and reports and features you
specifically use in google ads so let's
move into uh facebook ads manager and
show you how the platform looks when
you're running ads on facebook so we can
look at all the different tools and
reports available here so here we can
see
if we're in the facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we can see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if i click on one of these ad
sets i'll be able to see
an actual ad that's running here and so
for the actual ad that's running i can
then see the results of that ad and how
it's performing for example you know how
many clicks it's received what the reach
is what the impressions are so
impressions similar to google ads how
many people are actually looking at the
ad and i can see the cost per click here
at one dollar as an example and so now i
can go in and i can go ahead and look at
the ad performance and go ahead and
change out that ad if it's not
performing to
my expectation so if i click on more
tools and then creatives i can just
simply click on creators and then i can
actually see the create is i actually
have running for that campaign i
selected so now i can see all the
creatives that are running and i can see
the results of those creatives so
facebook ads manager also has uh reap
different reporting so if i click on the
reports pull down menu you can see here
i could see some standard reports by add
ad set age and gender
and then i can see all reports here
listed out by placement by placement and
device time of day country etc so if we
just look at age and gender we'll be
able to get a breakout age and gender
here so
you can see by campaign i'm looking at
all campaigns here and i'm looking at
just age and gender i can certainly
deselect one of these and i can look at
a specific time range so now i can see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here i could see
35 to 44 female i could see the reach
impressions and how often they're
actually seeing my ad now this is key
for facebook because if somebody's seen
your ad
a lot they're probably going to tune out
to it so that's what makes the frequency
metric so important on facebook because
then we can go ahead and
you know turn off that particular age in
gender if we needed to and we could see
how much we spent so this just gives you
some idea of the type of reporting
that's available in facebook ads manager
now the great thing about facebook uh
reporting in ads manager is you know i
can group or ungroup uh my dimensions if
i needed to i could change the view and
arrange columns i can get rid of columns
just as you would in google ads
reporting very similar stature here so i
have a lot of flexibility here on how i
review the reports you know you got
different metrics that you could pick
and choose as well okay and you got lots
of different flexibility when you're
looking at the reports on how your
campaigns are performing now here i can
pick and choose i can choose campaign ad
set ads objective again i can choose
different demographics so i have a lot
of options available to me in terms of
how i want to
you know view the performance of my
campaign view the performance of my ad
set or my ad now remember
if you're in facebook you can always go
in and edit the campaign you can edit
the ad set remember in the ad set that's
where a lot of your decisions are going
to be made including how you want to
drive the traffic okay what your budget
is okay you can basically choose your
audience here so you're going to be able
to choose what type of campaign is going
to be and based on the campaign you're
going to go ahead and choose the kind of
audience you want to focus in on you're
going to be able to choose the location
the age range the gender so all of this
is going to be set up in the ad set or
the campaign or the ad if you go ahead
and edit it out remember you can do a b
testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you writing ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
facebook so if you want some more
information about
all the different features and tools and
facebook ads manager check out the
facebook ads tutorial
2019 uh webinar that we did earlier this
year in addition you can also look at
another one that we did on facebook
called facebook advertising tips and
strategies so that should give you some
sense of everything related to facebook
ads and how to take advantage of the
facebook ads manager platform so if
there's anything on social that we may
have missed or that you use feel free to
add a comment below the video we'd love
to hear your feedback okay let's talk
about some affiliate marketing tools
let's turn our attention affiliate
marketing
a lot of affiliate marketing platforms
out there
the number one probably is commission
junction also known as cj
they're an affiliate platform they have
a freemium model meaning you can have a
free trial but
basically you're going to have to move
on and pay for the platform likewise for
houzz offers you a volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click inc hey
when so a lot of these are
brokers per se and when i say brokers
like for example with cj you as a
merchant or you as a publisher can get
in touch with a merchant you as a
merchant can get in touch with a
publisher meaning cj helps bridge the
gap between
you finding somebody to build your
network with okay so
that's what really affiliate marketing
is and you really need a platform to
kind of put it all together and it's a
lot a lot of affiliate marketing
platforms we're actually going to take a
look at cj and go through some of the
features in the platform here shortly
but let's just take a look at why we
need these affiliate marketing tools
well these affiliate marketing tools
identify
you know affiliates inflowers employees
other advocates you want to partner with
so again you could be on the merchant
side you could be actually selling a
product and you're going to want
somebody to help you sell that product
somebody with a website who's an
influencer who drives a lot of traffic
to their own site who
you know does sell reputable brand etc
so you need somebody to help you
introduce you to these sites okay so cj
and some of these other marketing
platforms affiliate marketing platforms
do that okay so these tools are there to
do the introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other
benefit here is you can contract with
affiliates and track the traffic and
conversions well what do i mean by that
well if you do use cj.com by no means am
i only endorsing that platform there are
plenty others out there but whatever
platform you use you're gonna want to be
able to set up terms and conditions with
that particular affiliate so you could
set up with terms and conditions for say
10 off all sales as an example okay well
you're getting a platform that will help
you broker that contract okay contract
terms or program terms furthermore
you're gonna need a platform to help you
track hey is this affiliate helping me
drive traffic or is this affiliate
driving traffic to my products and is
this affiliate helping me sell so
these platforms help you do just that
okay so you can gain high website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites so social
so you have a lot of benefits to working
with affiliate marketing in itself and
the tools available will help you gain
website rankings as one example we want
to be able to track certain metrics okay
so an affiliate marketing you have
earnings per click epc as an example
most platforms measure epc from a seven
day period to a three month period okay
you can also figure out what the actual
cost per click is just like you do on
say google search you can actually
measure that in affiliate okay you want
to eliminate fraudulent clicks
impressions and conversions so
any affiliate platform worth its weight
is going to help you understand you know
how many impressions and clicks and
conversions you're getting and help you
manage that in terms of fraudulent
clicks or hey if you're getting a lot of
impressions and no clicks that's a
problem too so
these platforms are really built on
helping you manage your relationship
with the affiliate by offering up all
sorts of reports and tools you know the
other big benefit here to affiliate
marketing tool is hey we can influence
our customers throughout their buying
journey so
we could set up different promotions
based on hey did somebody go to the
website did somebody see our product
does somebody click on our product did
somebody go into the shopping cart with
our product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're gonna have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really
there to manage your publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product you obviously want
somebody who's relevant somebody who's
going to be able to sell a product
somebody who has a targeted audience
that's similar to yours okay so we go
into cj.com we're going to log in and
here you can see a publisher's link so
we're going to click on the publishers
link and remember when you sign up
publishers you have to have program
terms and so if we click on publishers
program terms we're going to be able to
see
all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program turns we have set
up for certain publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher
so as a best practice if you have
publishers who are actually performing
well who are selling your products maybe
you want to offer them a little bit more
on the commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products cj is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately cj has templates cj
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so based on the program terms
that's how your publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
there's no limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so
here we can see what publishers are
under what program terms so again if
your publisher is performing well
sweeten the deal offer them a better
program terms and so you can align
publishers with different program terms
and so that's the whole idea behind
program terms is you want to be able to
align publishers with that so when you
sign up a publisher they're going to get
a line with a program term meaning what
are they going to get paid for selling
your product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically seven days or
three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in
cj.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically cj calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here we can't or
these publishers can't make any money if
they don't generate clicks so that's why
you have an epc model or metric so to
speak so you can measure earnings per
click cj does it over seven day period
and over a three month period so you
could sort based on seven day or three
month to see
who's earning the most per click in
terms of publishers now you can select
under publishers groups now you can
group your publishers okay so if you
have say a group of publishers in a
specific region like the united states
or india or if you're just focused on
the united states and say you have
publishers in different states like
texas california missouri arkansas well
you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see canada and so we have our
publishers grouped into
a group called canada why because
they're based in canada makes sense so
you want to be able to organize your
publishers because the whole idea behind
affiliate marketing cj is you want to be
able to get the best publishers
available for your network and so as you
get more publishers for your network
you'll be able to
basically start grouping them where it
makes sense now the example i gave you
is by geography you could do by
geography or
you could do by publisher status meaning
my best performing publishers go into a
group if they're in a group then they
get aligned with a certain program term
so you could group your publishers any
way you want by status meaning they're
selling more these are our best
performing publishers or by region or
you know by promotion i mean how you
group your publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again i'm gonna repeat it is
you want to get publishers and you want
to start building your base of
publishers because the more publishers
you have the more chance you are to sell
your product remember if nobody clicks
on your product then nobody's going to
buy your product so if you have
publishers who are promoting your
product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so now
once you have publishers you can start
grouping these publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense as a business
decision just know the options available
in cj to group publishers let's turn our
attention to social media marketing
tools social media always a great topic
to talk about so we're gonna finish up
all our digital marketing tools with
social media we talked about seo paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up with social media because
social media has so many tools available
so many okay
the first one i can think about here is
hootsuite hootsuite is a great social
media marketing tool to use okay it's a
freemium okay you can set up a free
trial here you you basically a base
account and then uh you can use
hootsuite to do a lot of things anything
from setting up landing pages to
actually publishing content to listening
hootsuite to me is one of the most
powerful social media marketing tools
available you got buffer buffers a paid
version but you can actually set up a
low cost or free account actually on
buffer and then move to a paid account
okay you got tweet decks been around a
long time that is actually free and i
would recommend tweetdeck and we're
gonna take a look at that here in a
couple minutes okay and then you got
sprout social sprout social is another
social marketing platform similar to
hootsuite do a lot of reporting a lot of
publishing you can a lot of listening
and so we're gonna take a look at sprout
chelsea today as well before we do that
let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working likely with just one
platform like facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be instagram pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place so if you could manage
everything one place then these social
media marketing platforms need to be
able to make it easy for you to add and
manage different accounts okay so a lot
of them have the ability for you to add
you know not just one twitter account
but multiple twitter accounts and not
just one social media platform but
multiple social media platforms and a
good social media marketing so worth its
weight will help you monitor the results
so monitor social media posts that help
drive leads and sales in other words
you're going to have a lot of different
metrics associated with each social
media marketing platform okay which one
is actually doing its job okay so you
want to be able to easily manage these
platforms applications and websites very
efficiently okay so instead of having to
log into each platform is log in one
place get a sense of what's been posted
what the engagement is did they purchase
etc and what you want to do is be able
to individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in the social media marketing tools okay
you don't want to send out a blanket
message across different platforms you
want to be able to
go ahead and customize a post depending
on what that post is depending on what
the product is what time of day what
target market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand advocate
who's not a brand advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual post on real time data so
if for example you post something using
one of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like sprout social and hootsuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are
running ads on facebook or you're
posting on facebook as an example or any
platform in general that platform's
going to have
its own metrics if you will so for
example facebook has something called
facebook insight so you'll be able to
actually see you know what's been posted
based on
you know the last seven days in this
example how many page views you're
getting engagements recent posts so just
to let you know
yes you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
facebook ads okay you can go right into
facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into sprout social i can set up
these accounts right into sprout social
so i don't have to log into twitter
individually or facebook individually i
can link them up all within sprout
social and then i can go to reports just
like i can with facebook insights and
then once i'm in facebook excuse me once
i'm in sprout social reporting then i
can go ahead just like i can in facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me i can jump into you know facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so
i don't have to log into facebook
directly i can see you know the
impressions the engagement the clicks
over a period of time i can see my
audience growth i can see my publishing
behavior how often my publishing i can
see the top post individually i can see
impressions by day you know a lot of
this same material same information is
already in facebook insights so if it's
available on facebook insights you know
you're definitely going to have it
available in a tool like sprout social
so you want to be able to just
efficiently log in and jump from one
platform to the other so here you know i
can go to instagram you know and look at
instagram data or i can look at twitter
information so you want to be able to
efficiently jump from one platform to
the other using in this example sprout
social now as i mentioned as part of one
of the benefits of a social media tool
is that you can publish content you want
to be able to publish content because
you want to be able to organize and
schedule accordingly you don't want to
be
submitting and publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is click compose
select a profile
write whatever we need to do you can
schedule it for tomorrow at a specific
time and there you go voila scheduled so
this is on twitter okay so you know we
could choose another platform here it's
just that easy to schedule so you want
to be able to schedule accordingly
because again when you schedule
something then you want to look at the
behavior of it so it's just as simple as
going from publishing to reporting and
then based on when something got
published you could see the reaction of
it and react to it so another thing here
that i like about it's about social
hootsuite a lot of these other platforms
do it really well you got listening
tools so you can listen in on
conversations that are being hacked for
example
uh mail delivery you know if we do mail
delivery and twitter search will be able
to see what's been tweeted about mail
deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can
refine our search and choose a specific
location a radius to hone in if we're
local okay so this is sprout socials
example of listening here let's take a
look at another example i'm in later.com
so later very similar sprout social and
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule
content on a particular platform and one
thing i like about later here you can
actually see it visually you can see a
calendar and what's been scheduled so i
can see today i have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again i
have five profiles set up for this
account
so i can pick and choose the profile
that i want to publish to so it just
makes it that much easier and i can
visually see it and that's important so
here i can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if i click
on this image here okay i can get a
sense of when it was used and i can view
it on a calendar i can add label for it
so
that's another benefit to later is that
they have this media library here they
have conversations so i can actually
connect to a platform and listen in on
conversations that are being had similar
to the listening tool in sprout social
and they have analytics so you can
actually see
write in later.com how your particular
social media platform is performing so i
can see it here over seven days i can
see the number of followers have
increased i could see the growth rate i
can see the number of impressions that
i've received okay so i want to be able
to see how my particular
is performing over a period of time so i
can look at reach the law profile views
website clicks okay so i can get a lot
of good insights here
right in the analytics platform later
you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something i
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments impressions
the reach and then if i wanted to i can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
discovery actions
comments saves etc so later.com goes
into some nice detail about post
performance they even have date on
hashtags so if you use an hashtag you
can actually see how many times the
hashtag's been used or saved how many
impressions it's received okay so they
really go into some nice detail here
about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool i really like i've been using for a
long time and that's tweet deck so what
tweet deck does is connect with your
twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
twitter account
looks in terms of your feed here i can
see this is my feed here okay i can see
some notifications i can see specific
messages then on this column i can see
activity okay so i can add different
columns here if i wanted to and
basically by adding columns you could
see i can look for what's trending as an
example so i'm going to add in a column
that says trending and so now i can go
in and see okay these are all the
different things that are trending on
twitter
so you can actually add a column and pay
attention to something really specific
okay so for example search okay so right
now i have men's health but i could type
in let's just say world cup okay so i
can see the you got the cricut world cup
you got you know the soccer football
world cup going on so you know we could
pick a particular topic to follow if we
wanted to so again here i'm following
men's health so i can now see
you know everything that's been posted
on men's health now if i click on for
example one of these hashtags here
that's trending i can actually see who's
tagging or using that hashtag friday
feeling in their tweets and so the whole
idea behind you know tweetdeck it serves
up a interesting overview so to speak of
not only your account but you know a
specific topic or what's trending or
you know other things that are being
said so if you really want to pay
attention to your brand or something
really specific like you know your
competitors or a specific product then
you can just do a search on that and so
that's the great thing about tweak deck
it allows you to kind of just look and
listen in on everything going on in
twitter now we do have a good video out
here on youtube how to start social
media marketing so if you haven't had a
chance to look at it take a look it goes
over some of these tools that we cover
today like sprout social later.com you
know facebook insights so it does cover
in more detail some of what we covered
on these social media marketing tools so
take a look at how to start social media
marketing so we covered a lot of
different marketing tools digital
marketing tools everything from seo to
email to social to paid to affiliate to
competitor but there's also a few
other digital marketing tools that you
can use in different ways like video seo
for example so vid iq you know we want
to use vid iq to get a good sense of how
a particular video is performing so here
if we go into youtube
you can see vid iq is a browser
extension or browser a plugin if you
will so i can go and take a look at a
specific specific video and see how many
hours it's been watched how many views
minutes watch subscribers etc you know
the great thing here i can look at the
entire entire account so
i can get good insights into my video or
my entire account here just by adding in
the vid iq extension into my chrome
browser so vid iq actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid iq because it's good
for video seo okay there's also tools
related to content optimization so
you know if you're doing seo and you
have a lot of content on your site well
you know what we want to be able to use
a tool
maybe a third-party tool to give some
objective reasoning as to what more we
can be doing so you got tools like seo
site checkup or site analyzer these are
pay tools but you know if you're really
heavily invested in seo
then they may pay dividends for you you
want to be able to make sure your
content is fully optimized to the
fullest according to you know google's
algorithms and so you maybe you know
want to invest in that third-party tool
so these are good tools to use for
content optimization you know there's
also other key reddit but you know
there's keyboard planner uh in google
there's also a word stream there's a lot
of different keyword tools out there so
you may not have a google ads platform
and so if you don't have google ads then
you may not be able to gain access to
google's keyword planner so having a
third party keyword tool will pay
dividends as well because those
dividends pay off in the form of not
only pay-per-click but also seo and if
you're heavily invested in content
heavily invested in social then you may
want to take a look at the keyword tool
keyword it and it's primarily used for
reddit we talk about page load time so
we looked at that in google analytics we
know that it heavily impacts seo so
there are other tools available you got
a third-party tool here that's free
solarwinds pingdom you actually have
page speed insights by google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of in determining how you can
improve your page load time my favorite
topic conversion rate optimization so
you got a couple in here crazy egg and
target okay so i'm going to show you
another tool called hot jar so here if
you log into hotshot.com you can set up
an account it's actually free and with
the free account you can have hotjar
measure the heat map not only the heat
map but the click mapping the scrolling
of a particular page and so here you can
see we're looking at a particular page
here so
hotjar allows me to
you know see on that page where people
are clicking um i can also see where
people are moving i can also see
you know the scrolling of a particular
page okay so
you can see here on the page i could see
people are moving over here to the right
that's where they're clicking
mostly if i switch over to move mode
then i can see on that particular page
where people are actually moving their
mouse and then i have my scroll analysis
so i could see you know how far down
people actually scroll on the page and
so again with a paid account you can
measure up to ten thousand page views
with the free version you can measure up
to two thousand pages and so two
thousand page views allows you to get
some insight as to what people are
clicking on or where they're moving or
how they're scrolling on a particular
page and so i definitely recommend hot
jar they also do funneling they also do
forms polls lots of other tools
available in hotjar so hotjar.com is a
tool i would recommend as well so one
final tool and i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention it and that's google optimize so
google optimize is a google platform
that allows you to a b test and so a b
testing means that you have an original
page and you're changing one element on
that page to see which one performs
better and so with google optimize it's
just very easy to set up to run and the
whole point of google optimize and a b
testing is to improve website
performance so here you can see i have
an account set up and optimize you can
see we're running one test here and
we're just testing one element versus
the original so we move photos to the
top of the page the original didn't have
the photos to the top of the page and so
we can go into reporting here google
optimize does all the heavy lifting and
so here you can see we can look at
bounces or we can look at you know
basically
a measure the test up against the metric
that's important to our business and
again the whole point is to improve
website performance and so definitely
take a look at google optimize
we'll have another webinar in the future
on the topic but you know to me google
optimize is free you can run up to five
tests okay and if you can run up to five
different tests then that means you have
the ability to really improve website
performance okay so google optimize is a
tool that i would recommend today we're
going to talk about why you would want
to rank using seo and seo is search
engine optimization also known as
organic search you also may as hear us
say organic listings we're going to talk
a little bit about why you'd want to
rank your website in organic search okay
what is search engine optimization then
we're going to follow that up with how
does google rank websites so
why does it rank one website over
another and how do we get our website to
rank number one then we're going to talk
about the different types of seo or
search engine optimization techniques so
you can get your website ranked number
one and then we're going to finish that
off with the do's and don'ts of seo so
let's get right to it and talk about why
seo so we're going to use a basic
example and let's just say you have a
blog you're a food blogger you're
passionate about food and your niche is
ice cream and let's just say you have a
lot of ice cream recipes you want to get
traffic to your blog you want people to
read your blog and you're curious why am
i not ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging a longer longer
than you and they have more content and
more blog posts and more pages for
google to rank so that's usually the
number one reason the other reason is
improper usage of keywords and we're
going to talk a little bit or it's
actually a lot more about you know
keyword usage in
your content so what kind of keywords do
you want to rank for that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords into the content another
reason is port link building practices
and really that means our other blog
posts or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say wordpress
for example and your blog post isn't
loading fast enough well if you look at
it this way think about it if you're
google would you really want to rank a
website or blog post in this example
number one on google rankings if that
particular page loaded very slow no you
wouldn't because when somebody clicked
on that link in organic search and went
to your website they're going to have a
bad experience because the page is going
to load slow so google doesn't want
their users to have a bad experience you
don't want your users to have a bad
experience and so that's why web page
load time is a critical factor for
ranking so we need to make sure that our
web pages load fast and then your user
experience is not good enough so
google again based on my example about
the web page load time google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know google doesn't want any spam
content google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a blog with a hundred recipes you want
google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on google organic search so
let's move on to what is seo so sticking
with our ice clean blog theme really seo
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for seo because that's exactly
how seo works it's exactly all those
points i just may mention about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in seo and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our pages
google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called a meta
description and then again the the
content needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed is
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when i say response
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
etc on google search and then link
building remember i mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page seo
how does google rank website and
basically google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your your web pages they need to
you have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to
basically rank the those pages that
they've indexed from number one to
infinity depending on how many pages are
relevant to that search query so really
it's about crawling indexing and ranking
so crawling is simply a process done by
which google has bots and
what these bots do is they go to your
web server and they're going to crawl
every page that they can find and how do
they find these pages well they
basically follow links you might have
heard the term spydering but that's what
they call search engine spidering so
basically what google's doing is they're
building a web so to speak all the links
that they're following and so when they
can follow all these links on your
website they're going to be able to
crawl them and when they crawl them
basically they're going to take that
content and store it on their servers so
it's available in their index so based
on this method google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found they're not going to show up for
relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to google search and if
i type in the keyword simply learn okay
i can see i have 1 million 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learned pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are 1 million 10 000 pages related to
the keyword simply learn now when it
comes to organic search uh we don't want
to get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're going
to see
something that says add next to it okay
so we could see that there are paid ads
here but when it comes to organic search
those are generally below paid ads and
so that's where google counts the 1
million 10 000 results and so that's the
whole idea behind crawling and indexing
google is able to crawl slimply learn's
website and based on all the pages that
they gather they're going to make those
pages available in organic search so if
you type in a keyword and your web page
is not available for indexing then
you're never going to show up for that
keyword so that's why it's important to
make sure your website is available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search google search
the most relevant websites that are in
google's index are going to appear in
the search results so in the example i
gave uh was simply learn well simply
learn is the brand name of the company
simply learn so there's a lot of
relevancy there so that's why you see
simply learn show up here organically
number one like we mentioned about what
is seo and why seo we talked about that
user experience so there's a lot of
factors that go into ranking relevancy
being one of them so in the simply learn
example simply learn is relevant to a
lot of the simply learned pages because
that's who they are simply learn however
simply learn also needs to make sure
that you know for their pages the page
load time is fast meaning these pages
load very fast for the end user and
google also takes into account other
factors like how long someone is staying
on a website or are they bouncing
meaning are they going to one page that
they land on and then leaving the
website okay and so the user experience
is very very important there are other
factors also like language and location
and so for example location if you do a
search say in india the results are
going to be a little bit different than
say the results in the united states why
because google is indexing as many web
pages as they can find so if somebody's
doing a search in india their results
may be a little bit different than the
results show up in the us because google
has different bots and these bots are
crawling different pages at different
times and so google's index is updating
continuously but it's not real time
syncing so if you do a search in india
you may not see exactly the same thing
because both search engines the google
and india and the google in the us are
may not be exactly synced up so an
example would be you know if you're
looking for cafe so if you search a cafe
and say san francisco you're going to
see different results now if you do a
search for cafes in mumbai you're going
to see different results there's going
to be local search here at the top there
may be some paid search but again you
may see different results because one
location but two google search engines
in india and united states google.com
aren't exactly synced up exactly at the
same exact time you do that search so
location is important language is
important and relevancy is important
along with user experience so all those
are important factors in how google
ranks websites okay so we're going to
talk about the types of seo now so if we
want to rank for a particular keyword on
google we're going to have to apply
search engine optimization and so
there's two strategies to search engine
optimization on-page seo and off-page
seo so first we're going to talk about
on-page seo so on-page seo is nothing
more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do
is understand what keywords we want to
rank for in order to understand what
keywords we want to rank for we need to
do keyword research and if you do
anything in seo keyword research is the
most important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for seo and
why do i say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page seo you can
change the title tag the meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example of how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the tool i would
recommend is google keyword planner and
why do i choose google keyword planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if i want to use google's
keyword planner and i want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then i'm going to
type that keyword into google's keyword
planner and what google's going to do is
they're going to give me some trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword i can
see
that there are trends that appear for
both desktop and mobile so mobile is
important because people start their
search process a lot of times on their
mobile device so we want to be able to
get data from mobile as well as desktop
and so we could see a trend here that
for each particular month over the last
12 months we can see how much volume
this particular keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist gets per
month and so on average on average over
the past 12 months i could see how to
become a digital marketing specialist
is averages 30 searches a month and this
is on google.com and so google gives us
the volume what they also give us is the
competition and so here i can see google
says for that particular keyword the
competition is medium and so in the
google's keyword planner what they also
do is give me other relevant keywords
that i might think about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword so how to become a
digital marketing specialist they're
going to also offer up other types of
keywords that are relevant so just
digital marketing specialist social
media marketing specialist so for those
keywords i can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist i
can see the average volume is 1 000 per
month on average over the last 12 months
i can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords i can see
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2 900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what i would recommend as a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keywords in a spreadsheet and when you
put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data i'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from google planner google's
keyword planner and i have competition
from google's keyword planner and so if
i go into a spreadsheet and i put all
that information in here i'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that google's
keyword planner if we go back just gives
us low medium and high and if i want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe i want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what i can do is go into google and i
can type in that keyword so if i type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist i can see there's
76 million results so i could see 76
million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30
per month on average and so what i want
to do is get a more clear picture of the
competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when i do that
i get a different result here i can see
only
136 listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136
with that particular keyword that we
want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see when you type in a
keyword or search query in google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top of every search result and so now i
can see i typed in how to become a
digital marketing specialist with the
all in title syntax and now i can see
every listing every one of these
136 results have that particular keyword
in it so i could see every one of them
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and why is that important
because now that tells me i only need to
climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from google's
keyword planner but you want to get your
competition from google search and again
that's simply typing in the the syntax
hall in title and then your keyword in
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for a number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page seo so
again
you want to
create content for
say a keyword like digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use google search
see first when they type in a query and
get results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page seo it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
google will truncate the title tag so if
i go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword
in the title tag and somebody types in
that keyword then chances are it's going
to be relevant they're going to see it
and they're going to click through to
your website and that's the whole idea
behind ranking we want to get clicks so
that's how the title tag appears so when
you optimize it you're going to update
the title tag and this is how it shows
up it's going to show up at the top of
your listing okay and it's going to be
bigger and bolder than anything else
google displays so the second thing you
want to optimize is the meta description
and the meta description is simply just
a brief description up to
155 i would say about 155 to 60 160
characters but probably no more than
that and so the meta description is
nothing more than a summary of the web
page itself so if i go back to my google
search results i see my title tag and i
see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and underneath that
is where i can see my meta description
so in this particular keyword query how
to become a digital marketing specialist
i see the meta description an ultimate
guide on how to build a career in
digital marketing and the skills
required to become a digital marketing
specialist note that it's a well-written
meta description within 155 characters
and it includes the keyword digital
marketing specialist so we're trying to
rank for how to become a digital
marketing specialist and here you can
see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between
not only the title tag and the keyword
but the meta description in the keyword
so when you're optimizing a keyword you
want to start with the title tag but you
also want to update the meta description
because if you don't update the meta
description and you leave the meta
description blank then you're leaving it
to google to add in copy that they deem
relevant and so for on-page seo we want
to take control of the copy and we want
to optimize it for the keywords we want
to be found for so the meta description
is a powerful tool at our disposal it
gives us more characters to work with it
gives us more to talk about so for that
particular page and so if the title tag
is only 60 characters maximum it's not a
lot of information to try and get
somebody to click so the meta
description helps us in identifying what
that page is about in order to get the
click so the two working in tandem will
hopefully increase your click-through
rates so when you're found organically
we want to get the click and then the
third element that's important is the
url and url stands for uniform resource
locator and why is the url so important
because that's what people see so if i
go back to my search result how to
become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the url also includes how to
article okay so it's very relevant the
url is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's relevant to the keyword query and
that's important for the end user and
google google wants to know hey is this
the page that's relevant to the user's
query and if it is then this user is
likely going to have a good x user
experience after they click on the
listing so the url is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
url structure doesn't help at all
because not only does google not
recognize the url as being relevant but
the end user
may not want to click on that page given
the the way the url looks so you want to
try and avoid a poor url structure so
the rule of thumb is this if you don't
understand what the url is then google
is likely not going to understand what
the url is and so we want to try and
keep our url structures clean and when i
say clean ideally you want to make sure
that whatever keyword you're trying to
optimize that's the keyword that's
included in the url nothing included
that is not understandable so again
going back to our example how to become
a digital marketing specialist it's very
clean the title tag is the keyword the
meta description is cleanly written has
the keyword and then the url is the
other element that the end user can see
and that url includes the keyword in it
so after we've done those three elements
the title tag the meta description and
the url then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organizational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from h1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an h6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building out a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an h1 or an h2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to google that hey
this header with this particular keyword
in it is important so if you use an h6
with the keyword in it it's telling
google hey this is an h6 but it's not as
important so an h1 and an h2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you can
see an h1
is going to be at the top of the
hierarchy so that means it's going to be
bigger and bolder then you have an h2
which is going to be bigger and bolder
than an h3 but not as big and bold as an
h2 so with headers not only are you
organizing the content accordingly but
you're also signaling to google how
important that particular header is and
of course the header needs to include
the keyword we're trying to rank for so
let's take a look again at that example
so if we go to how to become a digital
marketing specialist if i click on that
page i can look at the content and i can
see that there are headers in here so
the headers are there to organize the
content and that's what we want we want
to be able to organize the content and
if you look at the other example i'm
showing here how to become a digital
marketing specialist learning path
explored you can see that's an h1 but
below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an h2 and so we're not stressing to
google that that's more important than
h1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to google
what's important and also to organize
the content because google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on
is internal linking and so internal
linking if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to
other pages on
simply learn's website and so for this
particular content it also links to seo
specialist ppc specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist and so this is a best
practice when you're optimizing a web
page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when i say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation they
can naturally and seamlessly go from one
relevant article or page to another and
so that's the whole idea behind link
building and internal link building it
allows google to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end user
experience
and it's about allowing google to find
the pages on your website so they can
crawl them and index them so you can be
ranked for them and so also in addition
to
internal linking we want to be able to
use natural language and so what do i
mean by natural language or natural
language processing so what google does
is in terms of natural language
processing they're looking for the
content and the keyword it needs to be
relevant so when your website is about
digital marketing you don't necessarily
want to rank or try to rank for the
keyword digital marketing one it's too
broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the keyword
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing examples or what is a
digital marketing strategy or how to
become a digital marketing specialist so
those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify
other keywords and the natural language
process what keywords are more relevant
for the content and then another element
to on-page seo is the sitemap and so
with the sitemap it's basically a list
of all the pages on your website and the
whole idea of listing all the pages on
your website in one document is it helps
both users and search engines understand
the structure of your website so there
are two types of sitemaps one is an html
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that site map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an xml sitemap and xml is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for google or other search
engine crawlers and so xml is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if i go to simplylearn.com and
simply type in say sitemap.xml
just as an example i'm going to get this
particular page and this particular page
displays two xml sitemaps so these site
maps are there for google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind seo you want to be able to
have google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keywords
you want to be found for so it all
starts with the sitemap so let's go from
on-page seo which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag the meta
description the url the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking and also
updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're gonna switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page seo
because without page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off page seo and you could do all the
off page seo you want but you still need
on page so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to
off-page seo and so off-page seo is
simply the process of linking or
promoting your website using link
building and so if you remember i talked
about this earlier on there's two types
of links internal and external linking
and so for on-page seo we used internal
linking for off-page seo we're going to
talk about external linking and external
linking allows us to improve our
website's recognition or relevancy or
credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and authority
because we want google to know that our
web page is trustworthy it is recognized
by other websites and it is relevant for
a particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off page seo methods then
google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off page seo is synonymous
with link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website it also creates high domain
authority and so what i mean by high
domain authority is if we have basically
links to other web pages pointing back
to us then basically our domain
authority is going to improve and when
our domain authority improves other
websites are going to want to link to us
so the higher authoritative we are for
our website then other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain authority so it all starts
with linking to
other high domain authority websites so
linking to a high domain authority
website for example having a link on
wikipedia that points back to our web
page creates high domain authority for
us and it helps drive traffic so some of
the other benefits of off-page seo are
credibility so if we're linking from
wikipedia to our webpage it does create
credibility for us it also helps us
increase our page rank so remember that
external linking helps build domain
authority helps build credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page seo link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high
authority websites wikipedia or say a
social platform it's going to increase
our brand awareness and increasing our
brand awareness increases our
trustworthiness and so if somebody is
looking to say become a digital
marketing specialist then likely instead
of typing in digital marketing
specialist on google they may type in
our brand name in this case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to off
page seo so it's nothing more than
having links on other websites that are
pointing back to ours and again there's
lots of benefits it's drives helps drive
traffic and increases our authority so
those are things that we want to take
advantage of when we want to rank and
the key behind off page seo or link
building is always going to be content
so from an on-page seo perspective
having quality content allows that
content to be optimized for relevant
keyword and ranked but also from an
off-page seo strategy
having high quality content allows us to
have other sites and it doesn't
necessarily have to be a website it
could be a social platform or can be
another blogging platform or blogging
website linked back to ours why because
the content is original it's natural
it's well structured it reads well and
so that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off page seo is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to
spend a lot of time or a bit of time on
others websites so remember the example
i used earlier in this presentation
about having an ice cream blog and ice
cream recipes well it probably wouldn't
be a bad idea to say spend some time on
other blogs related to
desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to
vegetables or other items that people
could link from so the whole idea is
understanding who else is out there who
has relevant content that you could
share so you could share your content
with them they can share their content
with you and generally that's how it
works naturally anyway in the web sphere
if somebody likes your content they're
going to link to it they don't
necessarily have to wait for you to ask
them but it might not be a bad idea to
understand who else is out there that
has content similar to yours so that you
can you know get a link on that
particular website or blog post and so
some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just facebook or twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's medium there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has a say a blog about
cakes having their link on your blog
post so there's nothing wrong with it
because it also adds to the user
experience and if you're going to ask
somebody to put an external link on
theirs you might want to be open-minded
and make sure that you're are able and
willing to put an external link on your
blog post or website pointing to their
content that's how the web works
especially if the contents of quality
relevant and of good nature okay so
let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of seo so we talked a
lot about
why seo what is seo you know how do we
rank for seo what is on page seo what is
off page seo and so
let's just wrap up with some of the
things you again want to do to rank your
page for a particular keyword and some
of the things you don't want to do so
the first thing on the list is optimize
for white hat techniques and what i mean
for
opting in for white hat techniques is
basically everything i just mentioned
today you want to do keyword research
you want to choose a natural language
processing form format so you could
choose keywords that are going to be
relevant natural to the content and you
don't want to opt for black cat
techniques and black hat techniques are
probably not even worth going into
detail but one example is choosing a
keyword arbitrarily like say digital
marketing and just stuffing that keyword
into the content so that's probably not
something you want to do because again
it's not going to be good for the end
user so stay away from black hat and
focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's presentation the
other do we want to do is get backlinks
from relevant sites so that's off-page
seo again it's what i mentioned earlier
it's about linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has quality content we don't want to
have a backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then google
is going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same way
as if you were on a quality website we
do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag
for every web page on your website and
ideally what does that mean that means
using our keyword research to choose one
or two keywords for page and optimizing
your web page for those one to two
keywords so you ideally what you want to
do is have one to two different keywords
for every page on your website we
definitely definitely definitely want to
write engaging content so the content
should be engaging remember user
experience we want users to stay on our
website we want them to enjoy the
content that they're reading and we want
them to go from one page to another
naturally we definitely don't want to
leverage or plagiarize or just copy
content from others websites because
it's not one probably going to be
relevant to what you're writing about
two it's duplicate content and it's
somebody else's so that's a black cat
technique we want to stay away from i
can't emphasize this enough we need to
do keyword research first before you do
anything else you need to find relevant
keywords and not only that you need to
understand the volume and the
competition for each of those keywords
okay you don't want to choose a keyword
that has low volume high competition you
want to choose a keyword that has high
volume low competition but above all you
want to choose keywords that are
relevant to your content we want to
avoid keyword stuffing so don't take a
keyword and just stuff it everywhere on
the page it's not going to be natural
and google's going to be able to pick up
on that so we want to maintain some
level of quality with our content and
quality with the keywords that we choose
so reminder when you have quality
content it's always going to link
internally to another page on your
website with quality content but it's
got to be natural and don't just build
site-wide backlinks meaning don't just
have an internal link to the homepage or
don't have every page on your website
linking to just one page so internal
linking should be natural naturally
linking from one page to another not
only does it help google understand and
crawl all the web pages on your website
but it's good for the end user it's good
user experience and certainly last but
something i didn't talk about it does
take time to rank your content so
remember the process you're going to
write your content you're going to
choose keywords you're going to change
the elements on that page for those
keywords and all the while you're going
to make sure google can crawl that
content and when they crawl they're
going to index it the process takes time
especially if you choose a keyword
that's competitive so just be patient if
you have quality content and you've
optimized for on-page seo and off-page
seo then you will rank for that keyword
and then make sure your website's
user-friendly and mobile friendly so we
talked about responsive content earlier
so remember most users today start the
process of search on mobile so we want
to make sure your websites are mobile
friendly search engine optimization
starts with the keyword because we want
to be found for relevant keywords and so
the first step
and search engine optimization is always
going to be keyword research so it is
the most important step and so what is
keyword research all about well it's a
process of identifying keywords we want
to be found for on the search engines so
millions of people use search engines on
a daily basis we want to be found for
those keywords that people type in that
are relevant to the content we want to
be found so going back to the italian
restaurant example if we're writing a
blog post about italian restaurants if
somebody types in the best italian
restaurants or italian restaurants in a
specific city we want to be found for
that content if it's relevant to what we
wrote about so keyword research should
be done based on two factors really it's
that based on the factor of how much
traffic or volume a particular search
engine query has and it's based on
competition and really
the underlying factor here is that all
keywords in your keyword research should
be relevant so you need to understand
what those keywords are so are they
relevant to the content that you want to
be found for if they are then really the
two factors you want to look for is the
volume how much volume or traffic each
keyword has associated with it and then
the competition how many other websites
are trying to be found for the same
keyword so those are the factors
involved with keyword research you
always want to choose relevant keywords
and then once you find or choose those
relevant keywords you want to be able to
find out exactly how much volume and how
much competitions associated with each
of those keywords and so when you look
at keywords you're always going to
choose relevant keywords but there are
two types of keywords there are short
tail keywords and they are long tail
keywords and we're going to talk about
both of these here so let's start with
short tail keywords so short tail
keywords are generic keywords generally
they're less than three words in a
keyword phrase for example italian
restaurants so
short tail keywords generally
have very high search volume that means
that if somebody types in italian
restaurants then there's going to be a
large amount of volume with that meaning
that
generally a lot of people type in the
keyword italian restaurants however with
high volume always comes high
competition so
if you want to be found for italian
restaurants know that if you are ranked
number one or number two or even on page
one of google you're going to get a lot
of traffic however to get to page one of
google or even position one or two it's
going to take you a while because there
are probably a lot of websites
who are in front of you who want to be
ranked and found for the same keyword so
the whole idea with short tail keywords
is it's a lot of visibility it's a lot
of traffic a lot of volume but also a
lot of competition and generally the
underlying factor here is that if you
are ranked for a very broad or short
tail keyword like italian restaurants
then chances are it's not going to be as
relevant so if you get the traffic to
your website
then chances are the conversion's not
necessarily going to happen because we
don't necessarily know the mindset of
somebody typing in a very short tail
generic keyword like italian restaurants
they could be doing research on italian
restaurants they could be a chef who's
trying to get recipes for italian food
it could be a tourist looking for
italian restaurants in a different city
or it could be a person just looking for
italian restaurants near their location
or where they're living and so there's a
lot of different factors with short tail
keywords so you just don't know because
it's so generic and because it's so
generic if you do get the traffic for
that generic keyword then the chances of
the conversion are going to be lower
than say if it's a more specific
relevant keyword so let's take an
example
of a short tail keyword let's just stick
with italian restaurants so i'm going to
go to
a tool called moz and well moz has a
tool called the keyword explorer and
within moz so if you go to moz.com and
then use the keyword explorer you can
get an idea of how much volume and
competition are associated with a
particular keyword so in this example
we're using italian restaurants it's a
very broad keyword we could see that the
monthly volume is between 70 000 and 118
000 per month okay so that means for a
particular keyword in the united states
on a search engine you're going to get
about 70 000 to 118 000 people who type
in that keyword and so if we were to
look at the difficulty of that keyword
you could see
that it's fairly difficult because out
of one to 100 it's got to score 43 so
it's fairly difficult however if you
notice the click-through rate is very
high so moz estimates that we'll have a
organic click-through rate for that
keyword if we're ranked for it so
if it's relevant to us and we want to
get some visibility to our site then
yeah we want to use that generic short
tail keyword however if we're interested
in conversions then we really want to
turn our attention to
longer tail keywords however if you want
the visibility then you want to use
short tail keywords if you want the
conversion then you want to switch over
to longer tail keywords so longer tail
keywords are more specific they usually
consist of more than three keywords so
tie in restaurants very generic if we
add a few more keywords that keyword
phrase it then becomes longer tail so
compared to short tail keywords longer
tail keywords are generally less
competitive and the search volume is not
as high case in point so if we go back
to moz and then we look at the keyword
explorer and we'd actually type in
italian restaurants and let's just say
orlando florida
moz is going to
generate some monthly volume for us and
they're going to allow us to understand
how difficult that keyword is and so
here you could see very very little
search volume in fact
so little volume there's 11 to 50 okay
so that means on average that this
keyword generates 11 to 50 queries a
month so very low compared to our short
tail keyword italian restaurants the
difficulty here didn't necessarily
lessen but it is less uh competitive so
if you're interested in conversions and
you have an italian restaurant in say
orlando florida then this is the key
word you may want to use so there's a
trade-off between longer tail and
shorter tail but when visitors land from
longer tail keywords they're usually
ready to make a purchase they're usually
more specific intent there's more intent
involved with a longer tail keyword so
best restaurants in italian in florida
branded shoes in florida something very
specific is going to generate probably a
higher conversion rate than something
more generic so that's the trade-off and
so when to use long tail keywords well
we want to use long tail keywords and
for targeting pages with a product or
specific article so if we're interested
in that particular conversion then
longer tail keywords are likely more the
way we want to go versus something more
generic which means if you're using a
generic shorter tail keyword you're more
interested in the visibility and the
traffic not necessarily the conversion
how does a search engine work so let's
talk about that for a minute so we know
that millions of people use search
engines we know that we want to be found
on search engines but how do we actually
get our content in the search engine so
that's the important part that we need
to understand if we have our own website
and we have our content so these search
engines want your content in their
search engine index so how do they get
your content well they send out bots or
files and we'll just call them spiders
so they send out these spiders to crawl
your website and the whole idea behind
using the insect spider is because we're
talking about the world wide web and so
if google for example sends a bot to
your website they're going to crawl your
website in spite of your website they're
creating a web of pages so all they're
doing is following link and every page
and link that they hit they're going to
bring back to their server so these
spiders scan your websites they just
follow links and they take all the pages
and content that they're able to gather
when they hit your website and they're
gonna pull all that information back
into their own index so if you think
about google they're crawling or
spidering millions and billions of
websites all those millions and billions
of websites are sitting on google
servers so when somebody does do a
search query google because they have
all these websites in their index are
able to quickly determine which website
is the most relevant for that search
engine query so that's generally how
search engines work so let's talk about
the types of seo so if we want our
website to be found on these search
engines and google or the search engines
have crawled our website then what we
want to do is we want to
basically look at it from a two-pronged
perspective it's a two-pronged strategy
so the first strategy we're going to
talk about today is on page seo so those
are on page seos defined as what we do
on our website to be relevant for search
engine query on a search engine so again
on-page seo is what we do to our own
website off-page seo is the other the
second part of that seo strategy and
off-page seo determines what we do off
our website to be relevant for search
engine query and so off page seo
generally is synonymous with link
building and we'll talk about that a
little bit more as we go forward but
really when you want to do seo when you
want to be found for
a keyword on a search engine you're
going to have to apply both on-page seo
and off-page seo so let's talk about
on-page seo
and so this is the first part of our seo
effort we want to focus on on-page seo
first and so on page seo is the method
of optimizing elements of web pages
remember these are all the items we want
to do on our website to be relevant for
certain search queries so it's basically
the idea behind this is to make our web
pages more relevant for specific search
queries on search engines and so there
are a number of different elements on
our website on a particular web page
that we want to
manipulate or optimize if you will to be
relevant for search engine query and so
let's start around the idea that you
know you there's a number of things you
can do so let's start with schema first
and so schema is nothing more than
it's a collaborative effort between bing
yahoo baidu google and the idea is
really they want to understand more
about the content of your website and so
the idea behind this is that you want to
be able to provide snippets of
information to these search engines so
they understand a little bit more about
what your web page is trying to portray
or convey so that they can find out
exactly what's relevant to that search
engine query so it's nothing more than
micro data or bits of information that
you can add to your website or web page
in order to provide a little bit more
enhanced information to the search
engines so if you think about it's
collaborating with the search engine so
the more basic information you share
with the search engines the better off
they have to understand what your web
page your website is all about and so
the more information they have the
better of an opportunity you have to be
ranked for that search engine query and
so if you have a website with reviews if
you have a website with images if you
have let's say a website with products
with prices in other words you have an
e-commerce website and you're trying to
sell products well to me you want to
employ schema because again schema is
snippets of information that are
provided to the search engine so they
can better understand so
you can certainly provide snippets of
information in the terms of images or
prices or particular products and how
much is left in stock so all this
information these bits of information
you can provide to the search engine so
that they can better understand what it
is you're trying to sell how much it
cost how much is in inventory what
people think about the product etc so if
you have a website that sell products
you probably want to employ schema and
so when you do employ schema again
snippets of information provided to the
search engines the search engines are
going to better understand and then
they're going to present that
information in the search engine results
so if you have ratings and reviews you
can provide snippets of information to
the search engines the search engines in
turn are going to present that
information in the search engine results
so if you have positive reviews then
somebody typing in in this example shoes
they're going to be able to see that you
have positive reviews for your website
so that's the whole idea behind schema
is to provide snippets of information so
again it's not just related to reviews
also for images so if you have images
you can provide snippets of information
to the search engine so they can see you
know what the shoe actually looks like
when they type in in this example puma
shoes or like i mentioned inventory
snippets of information about your
inventory the search engines are going
to provide that information search
engine results so if somebody's looking
for women's training shoes or women's
puma shoes and they see your product and
they see how this is in stock great let
me go to this website and purchase these
shoes so that's the whole idea behind
schema is making sure you present
information critical to your website so
that the search engines better
understand what your website's all about
it also helps with relevancy because the
more the search engines know about your
website the more relevant your website
becomes and the better chance you have
to rank for a particular keyword there's
also some other information here
involved with schema and those are site
links so site links additional pages on
your website okay that show up in the
search engine result and so again the
more information a search engine has
about you the better chance you have to
be found the better chance you have to
get a click so site links are just
additional links on your site that
appear in search engine results and
that's all a benefactor of having schema
so here you can see in this example we
have additional web pages that show
under a certain search engine result and
so by having more links in the search
engine results you have a better chance
of getting the click so if you want more
information about schema i would
recommend going to schema.org so when
you go to schema.org you can actually
click on a link that allows you to see
all the information you need to get
started with schema.org okay so it's got
a lot of information available to you it
describes what it is you have to do in
order to
get your information and set for the
search engines to better understand
focus on for on-page seo is title tag
and so title tag is what shows up in the
search engine results so if you've ever
done a search engine query meaning
you've gone to google typed in a query
using a keyword like italian restaurants
you're going to see specific search
engine results and the title tag is what
appears in those search engine results
so a title tag is important because it's
the title of a web page that appears in
those results and so the title tag is
something that's important because if we
want to be found for a specific keyword
we want to make sure that keyword is in
the title tag because that keyword is
going to describe what the page is all
about and so if we want to be found for
that keyword let's just say italian
restaurants in florida for example
that's going to be part of our title tag
so when somebody types in that
particular keyword query italian
restaurants in florida then we have a
good chance of showing up because the
title tag which is the title of the page
is going to have that particular query
in it and so you can edit the title tag
and when you edit the title tag you want
to be able to put that particular
keyword in the title tag so if we do a
search on google for example so if i go
to google.com and i type in italian
restaurants in florida
here i can see under the local search
results and here i can see italian
restaurants in florida central florida
italian restaurants in miami so you can
see that these are highlighted so the
title tag is not only stands out but
allows you to
you know showcase exactly what your page
is all about and it helps with the
relevancy of that keyword query so when
you're trying to optimize your website
using the title tag for specific keyword
you want to keep in mind a couple
parameters because title tags show up in
the search engine results but
certain search engines particularly
google has character limits around the
number of characters you can use in the
title tag and so we want to keep that in
mind so
ideally we want to format our title tag
appropriately and so to me the most
optimal way to optimize a title tag
using a particular keyword that you want
to be found for is to use that keyword
in the title tag and then separate that
with your brand name so if you actually
have two keywords then you can use the
primary keyword first then the secondary
keyword and then the brand name so to me
this is the most optimal format but keep
in mind there are character limits but
if you look at this format to me it's
the most easiest format to abide by
because it makes your title tag more
relevant you don't have to worry about
necessarily fitting in excess keywords
in the title tag because again the title
tag is character limits so if we take a
look at our example in google search
results if you go over those limits and
the title tag is generally between 60
and 65 characters long and so if you go
over those limits let's just say your
title tag is more than 65 characters
google in this case is going to cut off
the characters and so here you can see
the ellipses after the title tag now if
you follow the format that you know we
at simply learn recommend you can see if
our keyword is italian restaurants in
florida and then separated by the brand
name this gives you an optimal format
for the title tag it also makes it
relevant for the keyword query so you
want to keep that title tag probably no
more than 60 characters because if you
flirt with putting more than 60
characters then the search engines are
going to cut off that title tag and then
that's not going to look good and it's
going to also become less relevant so we
want to keep the character counts in
mind so if you abide by that format of
the keyword and then maybe the secondary
keyword if you have one separated by the
brand name then you should be good to go
with making sure your title tag is
relevant for that keyword query so let's
then turn our attention to the meta
description so the meta description is
just a short description about the
content on your web page so if the title
tag is the title of the web page the
meta description describes the page okay
so it's a description about what that
page is so the meta description appears
under the title tag and then the url so
if we go back to our google search
results we look here italian restaurants
in florida maggiano's little italy is
the brand or the restaurant we can see
the url which is underneath the title
tag and then here we could see the meta
description and so with the meta
description you have a little bit more
room to work with in terms of character
count but the meta description just like
the title tag is just as important
because one it shows up in the search
engine results two it describes what the
page is all about and three it allows
you to optimize the meta description so
the meta description becomes more
relevant for that search query that
somebody types into that particular
search engine so the optimal length for
a meta description you can go up to 300
characters but i would not even
recommend even flirting with that limit
because just like the title tag search
engines in the case of google will
actually cut off the meta description so
if we look here back at our search
results if you go over those limits
you'll see that the search engines will
cut off the copy
of the meta description with and they'll
just put ellipses so we don't
necessarily want to
go over those limits so my
recommendation is to keep that meta
description probably 165
characters to to no more than 200
because we're trying to
describe not only what the page is all
about but we're also trying to optimize
that meta description so it becomes
relevant for the search engine query and
so you want to keep it short and concise
so if we look at our example here
italian restaurants in florida magianas
does a good job so book an event space
make a reservation at maggiano's in
florida to enjoy delicious view maps
menus and more so
very concise meta description it
includes their keyword query that they
want to be found for italian restaurants
in florida and so to me it's short and
concise describes what the page is all
about and
allows them to fit it all in within the
character limits so here in this example
we want to be found for amazon puma
shoes so the brand here is amazon so
amazon wants to include puma shoes not
only in the title tag but they want to
try and fit that into the meta
description however the whole idea
behind the meta description more than
anything else is describe what the page
is all about okay you want to be
relevant for the search engine query but
you also want to sound natural as well
you want to be able to
really the whole idea between the title
tag and amount of description is to get
people to click on your link because
remember there are nine other listings
on the google search engine results page
for page one so we want our meta
description and our title tag to stand
out so we want it to be relevant but we
want it to stand out so it's important
you write that meta description
according to what the page is all about
but you want it to stand out uniquely
and accordingly so once you've done the
title tag and the meta description you
want to focus your attention on the
header tag and so header tags are used
on a web page to really separate out
content and so you have headers and
subheaders and so ideally you want to be
able to optimize the header tag and the
subheader and so if we think about
headers there's a hierarchy for headers
so there's between a header one and a
header six and so we'll just shorten the
word header and we'll call it an h1 so
h1 is really at the top of the hierarchy
for headers and so if we use an h1 on
our web page then what we're trying to
explain to the search engines is listen
this particular keyword phrase in our
header is is a header and we're emphasis
we're trying to emphasize what it is
we're trying to say and that's how
really the search engines interpret
headers they see an h1 h2 h3 h4 h5 and
h6 they know that if you're using an h1
you're trying to really emphasize
something so if you put that keyword in
the header tag what you're telling the
search engines is hey i'm really
emphasizing this particular keyword and
so the search engine will interpret that
as important and if you use your keyword
in that header then really what you're
saying is hey i really this keyword is
really relevant to that query so
naturally the other benefit of a header
is it really breaks up the page as well
so
the header you can use subheaders and
sub headers are nothing more than say a
lower h tag so if you have a header
that's an h1 you can use an h2 and h3 as
a subheader and so forth and so on
because what you're really trying to do
is not only organize the content on your
web page but you're trying to emphasize
that for google so if something's an h2
or an h6 you're basically telling google
or the other search engines this is not
as important as say in h1 so if we take
a look at our example that we've been
using for italian restaurants in florida
and if we click on magianas we can see
that they're using headers so if we
click on maggiano's we could see that
this is a header here we want to bring
everyone together at maggiano's italian
restaurant in florida so they're using
that header to break up the text here
you can see they're using another header
here excellent italian food and an
excellent experience to match so that's
a header to break up the content okay
they're not using subheaders they're
used using headers but that's fine
they're really trying to emphasize the
content by putting in that header and so
headers help not only organize the
content but they help emphasize the
actual keyword it is you want google to
recognize so if we're not sure if
something is a header we could simply
just mouse over what we think is a
header and we can just right click and
if you right click on something you're
going to see a menu and if we click
inspect element then basically what that
browser in this case firefox is going to
do is show us the html of that
particular thing of that item that we
right clicked so here we could see in
this particular case this is an h2 tag
so it's an h2 so if we scroll down and
we mouse over this we could see this is
also an h2 as well so this particular
page is using h2 tags not h1 but in h2
so what they're explaining or trying to
convey to the search engines is listen
this is an h2 it's still
relevant we're still trying to put
emphasis on it but not as much so we
want to be able to use our h1s and our
h2s accordingly so remember in h1 is
you're providing the search engines with
information by telling them hey this is
the most relevant this is we're putting
emphasis on this keyword and h2 nuts as
much as an h1 and an h3 not as much as
an h2 so use your headers accordingly uh
not only just to break up the text not
only for styling but for emphasis for
the search engines so headers are very
important elements for on-page seo okay
let's turn our attention to the url
structure okay so url stands for uniform
resource locator and so our url
is the specific location of a web page
on the internet so basically if we're
found in the search engine results one
of our web pages are going to go along
with the title tag and the meta
description in the search engine results
page so if i go back to our search
engine results for italian restaurants
in florida we could see that the
particular url in question here is
locations.magianos.com
so that's the url that shows up along
with the title tag in the meta
description so if we click on that link
that's exactly where we're going to go
so url structure is important for
on-page seo so why is it important
because not only does it show people
where they're going but we have an
opportunity to
optimize that url for the search engines
to make our url more relevant for that
search query so just like the title tag
just like the meta description just like
the headers we can also manipulate the
url so if we look at a url it consists
of really the protocol and the protocol
means it's either a secure site or
non-secure site so in this example we
could see it's https and that means it's
a secure site and so ideally search
engines like web pages or websites that
are secure so after the protocol you're
going to see the domain and then after
the domain you're going to see
subdirectories okay so that's generally
the breakout with
url structures you have the protocol the
domain
and subdirectories and then you may have
more subdirectories so if we go back to
the example we've been working with if i
go back to maggiano's you can see here
this is a secure site https you could
see the domain in this case it's
actually a sub domain so
magianos.com is the domain but they
decided to put
locations.magianos.com and that's okay
we call that a subdomain and then here
you can see they have one particular
subdirectory after the domain and that's
florida so a well structured url not
only provides the users with information
about where they're going when they
click on your link in the search engine
results but more importantly it also
provides the search engines and some
information about what the web page is
all about so going back to our simple
example with managianos the search
engines know that hey if somebody clicks
on this link they're going to a page
about florida pretty simple the url
structure is pretty simple to understand
we know it's a secure site we know it's
maggianos.com and we know the subpage is
florida or the subdirectory is florida
you want to be careful like everything
else since and seo there are parameters
just like the title tag has parameters
up to 65 characters the meta description
tag has a limit of up to 165 characters
a well-structured url also has character
counts but the idea here is we don't
want to get into numbers when we talk
about character counts for url structure
really the rule of thumb or the best
practice for url is to keep it short and
understandable okay if we keep it clear
and concise not only does the end user
know where they're going but the search
engines know what the page is all about
so the rule of thumb is always if you
don't understand the url or what it
means then the search engines are likely
not going to understand what the url
means we want to keep the number of
directors and subdirectories to a limit
so ideally here you can see in this
example xyz.com
if we want to optimize that url we could
put the targeted keyword in the url if
we'd like to but we want to keep it
probably to a minimum of one to two
subdirectories the shorter this the
amount of subdirectories the better off
we are because that means that not only
the end user will understand the url but
the search engines will understand the
url as well so we always want to make
sure that url is readable again for the
end user and the search engine and so in
this example you could see amazon.com
men's dash shoes slash sneakers slash
puma very easy understand as an end user
i know that i'm going to a puma page
for men on amazon.com now when you get
into urls with
dynamic parameters in them then ideally
you as an end user is not going to
really know where you're going to go so
in the example here the middle example i
can see that i'm going maybe to a shoes
page but i have no idea what the rest of
that url means and in the other example
where you have a very low url
readability i have no idea as an end
user where i'm going to go so as an end
user i need to be able to have
confidence in knowing where i'm going to
go once i click on a link in the search
engine results so if i don't have that
confidence if i don't understand what
the url is then you then the search
engines aren't going to understand as
well and it's not going to bode well in
terms of relevancy and again the url
structure is important factor for being
relevant and if we're not relevant then
the chances of us are ranking higher is
not going to be as good because our url
is not readable so ideally what we want
to do
is make sure we're using keywords that
the end user and the search engines
understand and if we need to separate
out those keywords in the first example
we could see men's shoes we want to
separate that out with a hyphen and so
ideally if you have a url that's
readable and it's short and concise then
again your chances of ranking higher on
the search engine results page bodes
better than if you have a very long
antiquated unreadable url so let's focus
our attention on
image alt text or alt tags if you will
so alt tags or text tags as they're also
known as allow uh the search engines to
understand a little bit more about
what's on the page in terms of images so
images are
a prominent part of every web page on
the internet unfortunately images are
you know usually files that are not
readable by search engines so we want to
be able to provide some alternate text
so that the search engines understand
what those images are all about so again
it gives us an opportunity to
communicate with the search engines so
that they better understand what the
image is all about to make the page more
relevant so generally if an image fails
to load on a web page as an example well
if you have an alt tag then the alt tag
is going to show in place of the image
not loading more importantly if we have
an alt tag and the search engines have
spidered our website and somebody's
actually searching for images then the
alt tag is used as a descriptor for the
image so it also helps us get found for
the images on search engine results
pages and so like everything else we've
talked about with on-page seo there are
character limits to all tags you know
generally the rule of thumb is 125
characters for an alt tag and the alt
tag is used in the html so we want to
surround our image with an alt tag by
putting in a descriptor and so ideally
if you're trying to be found for a
particular search engine query then you
want to use the search engine query as
part of the alt tag and so let me show
you an example here going back to
magianos if we look at their web page
and we actually inspect one of their
images on this web page if we look at
for example a pinterest or facebook we
can actually see in this example that
the image here has an alt tag it's
pinterest and so you want to be able
again to put in all tags for all your
images so it better communicates with
the search engines what the image is all
about it also allows the search engines
to rank images in the search engine
results based on that all text and what
the keyword query was so all tags play
an important role because again if the
image doesn't load on the web page for
some reason then the alt tag is there as
a replacement it's also there to help
the search engines rank those images and
understand the page a little bit better
so you always want to be able to put in
the keyword query that you're trying to
be found for in the alt tag and so be as
descriptive as possible you have 125
characters to use so be as descriptive
make it easy to read because again this
is what's going to show up in the search
engine results pages for images okay
let's turn our attention to internal
links so when it comes to seo internal
links also play a vital role because
basically an internal link which is a
link from one page of your website to
another page of your website um allows
google to or other search engines really
to follow the pages as they index your
entire website so it serves that purpose
of allowing search engines to index so
it definitely improves the indexing but
internal linking also has many benefits
and one of the other benefits is it
helps spreads what we call link choose
and so link jews is basically a way
another way of saying you know this page
is important because it has links from
other pages on our website so
if we link i have a link from one page
to another and
a couple of other pages on our site
linked to that same page then search
engines tend to take notice and they
tend to note that you know if one
particular page has a number of
different links pointing to it then this
page may be important and so that's what
we mean by link choose it's a signal for
the search engine to determine what
pages on your website are important
because of the links that point to it
and so if we look at this example here
we could see that you know there's
usually a navigation on a website that
point two pages and
every page on a website tends to have a
link but if more than one page has
multiple links then again that signals
to the search engines that hey you know
this particular page seems to be
important because it has a lot of links
pointing to it our attention is site
maps so site maps basically allow us to
list all the web pages on our website so
we could do that in a couple of
different ways but when we do it it
basically is going to help the search
engines find our pages easier just as i
mentioned a minute ago about internal
linking when you have one link pointing
to another page on your website it helps
the search engines find these pages
quicker while sitemaps do the same thing
except maps are an entire list of links
on your website and it allows the site
search engines to find all your pages in
your website fairly easily but it also
helps the end user too so if you have a
big website like amazon has a huge
website with a lot of different products
well if you're looking for a particular
product you can do a search for it or
you can look at the site map and the
sitemap will list all the particular
pages on the site and so it's also good
for the end user as well so when we talk
about the end user and we talk about
search engines they're really two
different types of site maps you got the
html version which is for the end user
that's going to be nothing more than a
link on the website usually in the
footer and so when you click on that
site map link you'll get a list of all
the links on the website okay so that's
an html site map then we have the
sitemap for the search engines you know
the spiders that want to crawl our site
so that's the xml sitemap and xml is
just a different format it's just a way
to format all the links on our website
so the html sitemap is html written in
hypertext markup language designed for
the end user if you click on it it helps
the end user navigate the website
quickly because they can find what
they're looking for and so generally
that is an html now if we turn our
attention to the xml site map that's
basically designed for search engines
and thing about the search uh the xml
site map is we work with google to go
ahead and and and submit the sitemap to
google so google can quickly understand
what pages on our website so for example
if i went to a website let's just say
valleyfig.com
so if i went here and
if i'm a search engine i'm going to want
to know all the urls that are on this
website well as an end user i can also
just type in sitemap.xml
usually that's the xml file where all
the urls are located and here i can see
all of the urls on valleyfit.com and so
the idea behind an xml sitemap is we
want to communicate that xml file to the
search engines and so google in
particular has what they call a search
console in search console if you go to
google.com webmasters so search console
is a way to communicate with google and
one of the ways to communicate with
google is to submit a site map so we
want to submit our xml sitemap so if our
xml site map is located in the root
directory so after our domain
valleyfig.com
sitemap.xml we know that that file is
sitting in the root directory i can go
into search console and i can submit my
sitemap and when i submit my site map
then i'm basically communicating with
google telling google hey
google instead of trying to find all our
web pages on our website when you crawl
the website we're going to go ahead and
submit the sitemap to you so we're going
to tell you all the pages on our website
and so by doing that by submitting our
sitemap.xml file to google it speeds up
the process because google is able to
now understand all the pages on our
website that have been submitted and
then once we submit those pages then
google is going to quickly index a
majority of those pages if not all of
those pages and so that's the benefit of
having an xml site for the search
engines is that we can quickly submit
that file to the search engine so our
pages get submitted and indexed quicker
so continuing on with on-page seo we now
turn our attention to page speed and so
page speed also known as page low time
of a particular page of a particular
website is important for seo why is it
important because
google has millions of users use their
search engine and google wants their
users to have a good experience and so
if google ranks websites based on
relevancy they also want to take into
account page speed because if a website
does not load fast or web page doesn't
load fast then it would be detrimental
for google to rank that page high
because what's going to happen is that
page is going to get a number of clicks
and then the user experience is not
going to be that great and so therefore
it's going to have a negative impact not
only in the end user but google as well
and so page load time then becomes
important for on-page seo so
really when it comes to page load time
we really want to pay attention to how
long it takes
our web pages to load in terms of
seconds because if a page loads slow
then chances are the user experience is
not going to be good even from an
analytics perspective meaning if i go to
google type in a query click on a link
and then it's that link takes me to a
website where the web page loads very
slow chances are i'm not going to spend
a lot of time waiting for that page to
load i'm going to leave that page and if
i leave the page then it's going to
cause up what they call a bounce so i'm
going to bounce from the page and that's
just not good for the entire search
ecosystem and so we want to pay close
attention to page load time because the
faster
a site or page loads google's going to
recognize that and that's going to help
with ranking and so how do we understand
how our pages load well we can look no
further than web analytics tool like
google analytics for example so if we
turn our attention to google analytics
if i go to say
valleyfig.coms analytics account i can
look over the last 30 days and i can see
okay on average our page average page
load time for the entire site was five
seconds around five seconds and ideally
we want our pages load as quick as
possible i would say the rule of thumb
on page load time is probably no more
than three to four seconds okay but
there are factors involved with page
load time so a couple of factors are the
browser that people use so some browsers
load pages differently than other
browsers the other factor involved with
browsers is the device so you could be
on a mobile device and say internet
explorer versus on a desktop using
chrome and you're going to have
variation in terms of average page load
time so definitely browser device plays
a role but also country plays a role the
infrastructure how much bandwidth is
available so you could be in say san
francisco united states and be on a
high-speed network versus another city
or another country where you're not
necessarily on the same high-speed
network you're on a lower bandwidth or
lower network and that's going to affect
the page load time as well so in
analytics you can actually see the
breakdown of time per country and then
of course the page itself so when we
talk about average page load time for a
website we're talking about the average
for the entire site but we can actually
look at in google analytics the average
low time for every page on the site so
ideally if you have a particular page
you want to rank organically in the
search engines and the average page load
time is not suitable or it's very high
then you want to address what the issues
are and so the great thing about google
analytics is you actually have speed
suggestions so if i go to speed
suggestions in google analytics i'm
going to be able to see the average load
time for certain pages on the site and
then what google's going to do is
actually give me
some feedback so for example i can see
that
the home page loads about
5.59 seconds and so if i click on page
speed suggestions then google is going
to give me suggestions on how to speed
up the page load time not only on
desktop but on mobile as well so when
you click on page speed suggestions
you're actually going to go to a tool a
google tool called page speed insights
and then page speed insight is going to
allow you to see how quick your page
loads and then it's going to be able to
give you feedback on what to do in order
to speed up the page load time not only
for the page but for the site and the
great thing again is you can see it for
desktop and you can see it for mobile so
page speed is important we want to be
able to keep our page load time low
no more than probably again three to
four seconds because if it's any more
than that google's going to take notice
the other search engines are going to
take notice and they're not going to
want to rank that particular page high
on google so some ways to increase your
page speed you always want to optimize
your images you never want to have
images that take a long time to load you
want to use a simple website design now
i know flash as an example has long been
disbanded but you don't want to use
other technology that's really going to
slow the page load time of course where
your website is hosted does matter so
the server it's hosted on could be
shared with other websites and so that
may eat into how quick the server
responds to people trying to load your
web page and so you want to keep that in
mind so server response time does play a
factor in loading and then of course
optimizing your code you want to never
have unnecessary code on your website
and when i say unnecessary code some
examples could be tracking code if
you're doing any search advertising
let's just say on facebook or bing you
try to want to minimize the amount of
extra code you put on a site because
that code has to execute and that eats
into the page load time so you want to
be cognizant of how much code you put on
your website because that will eat into
the page load time so let's talk about
featured snippets so featured snippets
is the search result that generally
shows uh up at the top of the search
engine organic results so it's
informational content and you'll see it
above organic results but you'll also
see it below search advertising and so
some of the common featured snippets you
may see are in the form of a paragraph a
table or a list and so
paragraph snippets tend to be the most
popular and let me show an example of a
featured snippet so if i go to
say google.com and type in machine
learning here you can see some paid
search ads okay and why do i know
they're paid search ads because i can
see ad next to them but if i look below
the paid search ads but above the
organic search results i see a paragraph
feature snippet and this is nothing more
than again just some an informational
content about machine learning and
really
the whole idea behind uh featured
snippets is really they're just
informational and really it's
informational and and what google likes
to do is pull content in there that
really answers a question so if your
content doesn't necessarily answer
question then you can't expect your
content to show up as a featured snippet
so the whole idea is with the search
engines is really google searches
through a number of different sites to
find content that will best answer a
user's question like for example what is
machine learning okay so if we ask the
question what is machine learning we can
expect to find a feature snippet and so
really what users do a lot when they
type in a query they use prefixes like
how does or how do or how to or what is
and so those types of questions are
normally asked as part of the search
query so if you could answer
those questions then
generally google is going to recognize
that and if it's relevant it's going to
show up as a featured snippet so the
whole idea is to really create truly
high quality content so
about feature snippets is if you have
true high quality content that answers a
question then chances are your content
may show up as a featured snippet so the
whole idea is you know work to create
high quality content that provides a
really good answer to really basic
question it could be anything what is
machine learning what is a fig you know
how to ride a bicycle how do i surf all
these are related questions that content
can answer and google wants to make sure
as part of a featured snippet that they
provide content that answers that
question and not just content the best
content that does the the best job with
the most relevant information answer
that person search query so here we can
see our three examples you have a table
format so if we want to type in aviation
jobs we can see
snippets of information about the latest
job listings for aviation you can see in
the middle screenshot what is machine
learning so that's our paragraph
featured snippet and then if you type in
something like building a fence it's
going to give you a list of you know
ways to go about building a fence so
these are all answers to questions the
query may not necessarily be in question
form but the snippet is there just in
case you want to know more information
about that particular query so generally
that's how featured snippets work and
the great thing about featured snippets
it's open to everybody the key is to
have quality content if you have quality
content that provides answers to
questions then chances are your content
can show up above organic search results
which will give you more visibility
drive a lot more traffic to your site
and quality traffic because likely it's
answering somebody's question so let's
do a a recap of everything we talked
about with on-page seo
so before we move on off page remember
on-page seo is what we do to our website
to enhance our website to be found in
the search engines for relevant keywords
so it's all about relevancy and remember
before you do anything to your website
you need to start with the basics of
keyword research you need to find
keywords that are highly relevant that
have volume and low competition and so
when you can focus on your keywords and
you find out and finalize what keywords
you want to be found for then you're
going to
conduct on-page seo on-page seo consist
of number of different factors some of
which we talked about today starting
with schema remember we want to have
structured data to better communicate
with the search engines what our web
pages are about then we talked about
title tags so title tags appear in
search results remember 65 characters we
want to make sure our keyword is in the
title tag followed by our brand name and
then we talked about meta descriptions
meta descriptions allow us to you know
talk specifically about what that page
is all about meta descriptions fall
under the title tag in the search
results we talked about headers h1
through h6 h1 being the biggest in the
hierarchy of headers and having an h1
tag with your keyword provides the
search engines with an identity of how
strong or how important something is on
a page it also organizes the page with
headers and sub headers and it breaks up
the content so it's easily
understandable by the end user we also
talked about alt tags so remember images
on its own are not recognized by search
engines so we want to surround those
images with all tags with words that
help the search engines identify what
that image is they also serve a purpose
in the browser if an image doesn't load
then we can actually see what the image
is all about with the alt tag we talked
about feature snippets there are lists
okay they are paragraphs okay they're
they're different types of snippets and
really the whole idea again behind
snippets is answering a question with
quality content we talked about page
speed identifying how quick our pages
load in google analytics so if your
pages don't load very quickly then
google actually provides suggestions to
speed up the page load time of a
particular page and some of the culprits
that you want to look at are making sure
you have images that are good quality
but also not a lot in size you want to
make sure they're optimized you want to
look at your server response time you
want to make sure you optimize code so
there's a lot of different factors of
page load time you just want to keep an
eye on what pages are not loading quick
enough and remember we want to keep it
as low as possible but no more than
three to four seconds we talked about
internal linking internal linking to a
particular page from one page to another
provides link juice and link juice is
nothing more than an indicator for the
search engines to identify what pages
tend to be more important than another
based on the number of links pointing to
that page and then we also talked about
site maps so we talked about the two
types of site maps html and xml html is
for the end user xml is primarily for
the search engines xml generally is
going to be a file called sitemap.xml
and we could take that xml file and
submit it to google search console and
so that expedites the process of
indexing your site and helps your site
not only get indexed faster but will
help google understand how many pages
are on your site and then get those
pages indexed so that they can be found
so that you can generate traffic so all
these are factors with on-page seo that
you want to address before you move on
to off-page seo okay let's um turn our
attention to off-page seo now that we
covered all the essentials for on page
we still need to focus our attention on
off page remember earlier i mentioned
that seo is a two-pronged approach we
have to focus on on-page seo first and
then to complement our efforts and to
continue our efforts and to continue the
effort of being relevant for certain
keywords we need to do what we call
off-page seo and those are our actions
we take that don't involve our website
directly meaning we've already updated
the title tag the meta description the
alt tags the headers etc we want to do
things off our website that's going to
allow google and other search engines to
recognize that hey we are relevant these
pages are relevant for certain keywords
on our website and so really when we
talk about off-page seo it's really the
technique of promoting your website
using link building when we say
technique of promoting our website using
link building that means establishing
links on other websites that's what we
mean by link building and so
establishing links on other websites
really
enhances our seo efforts because
it improves first and foremost it
improves the credibility of our website
so
if we're on a
you know a very popular website that is
known to be reputable
then having a link pointing from that
website to ours just improves the
credibility of our own website
not necessarily in the minds of the
search engine but in the minds of the
end user uh the other benefit here is it
increases our domain authority and let's
take a minute to talk about domain
authority so domain authority is simply
just a score between 1 and 100 and so in
digital marketing even including seo as
a marketing channel everything's
measurable and we want to be able to
measure everything we do digitally and
so off-page seo is measurable one of the
metrics involved with off page seo is
domain authority in other words it's a
score between 1 and 100 for our domain
so how does google how does baidu how do
these other search engines see our
domain how authoritative is our domain
how reputable is our domain and so
having links on other websites pointing
to our domain increases our
reputability increases our authority and
so i'm going to show you an example so
if you remember back on on page seo i
when we're talking about keyword
research we use a tool called moz
moz.com and i would recommend using
moz.com to measure domain authority so
if we go to moz.com
and moz.com has a tool called link
explorer so if you put in your domain
using their tool link explorer you're
going to be able to see your domain
authority and domain authority is a
score between one and 100 and basically
it's simply just scoring your website in
terms of authority how does the search
engine see your site out on the world
wide web the higher the score the better
and so
recommend using moz.com link explorer to
measure your domain authority so the
more
links we have on external sites pointing
to our own site in theory the higher the
domain authority so we're going to come
back to
moz.com quite frequently as we talk
about off-page seo because we need a
tool to help manage our efforts so we're
going to come back to moz.com but let's
let's talk about some of these other
benefits to off-page seo so we know it
helps with the credibility it increases
our domain authority but what are some
of the other intangible efforts that are
also measurable well it increases our
referral traffic and by increasing our
referral traffic meaning if we're on a
reputable site that gets a lot of
traffic and there's a link pointing our
site then naturally we're probably going
to see traffic coming from that site and
we can measure that in tools like google
analytics we can measure referral
traffic and so that's an inherent
benefit to doing off-page seo because
we're trying to create the relevancy of
our own website we're trying to be found
for relevant keywords but yet at the
same time we can increase traffic to our
website and then certainly not lost in
all this is improving our page rank so
the idea here is you need on-page and
off-page seo to work together to improve
our rankings and improving our rankings
in the search engine results will
inherently
increase our rankings and drive traffic
to the site from search engines and
that's ideally what we're trying to do
we're trying to accomplish traffic from
search engines by improving our rankings
but at the same time we improve our
credibility and we accrue improve our
standing in the search engine world and
we also increase traffic to our site
from all these other websites and so
there are a lot of benefits to off-page
seo um it's just let's talk a little bit
more about some of these other benefits
because according to a backlinko a web
page with more backlinks is going to
rank higher than a page with fewer
backlinks but let me just say this with
back linking especially from sites it's
all about credibility it's all about
quality over quantity so we want to pay
attention to quality over quantity so
let's harken back to moz.com
and here we can see
we have a domain authority of 35 but we
have a lot of links inbound links from
other websites pointing to our website
we have 575
domains out there on the internet
pointing to our domain valleyfig.com
and so if we want to take a specific
look at these domains we can just simply
click on linking domains and here we can
see all the different domains pointing
to our website now again it's about
quality not quantity so if we look at
the domain authority and that's a score
that measures the credibility of a
website we could see the domain
authority on some of these
domains like npr.org has a domain
authority of 93. and so to me
that helps boost the domain authority
for our own website our own domain it
also has the chance of driving that
traffic it also increases the
credibility but in the end having
quality links from other quality domains
is going to increase our own rank on
search engines and that's the whole idea
behind it so we could actually see
that we have quality
websites of quality domains linking to
our domain now you can also use another
tool i mentioned this earlier with
on-page seo when i was talking about
sitemaps so if you go to search console
so that's a google tool we can also look
at a link report and see what other
websites are linking to us so this is
google's way of communicating to us what
websites are out there linking to us and
so here i can see the top linking sites
to our website
valleyfig.com is the crumby kitchen has
1443 links pointing back to our site
cookscountry.com whole foods magazine
mayan perfect kitchen these are all
sites with links pointing back to our
site so search console is a good tool
it's a good alternative tool especially
the links report is a good alternative
tool to get an idea of the types of
sites that are linking to your site now
what you're missing here in search
console is the domain authority but you
can use the link explorer tool in
moz.com to measure the domain authority
for any domain it's just a matter of
going to the tool itself going by going
to moz.com by going to the link explorer
report and just typing in the domain and
from there you'll be able to see the
domain authority so it's all about
quality over quantity i can't stress
that enough so when it comes to off page
really it's anonymous with link building
so it's the most effective method for
off-page seo and it's simply just
getting links from other websites to
your own so it's not as easy as it
sounds especially when we're talking
about quality over quantity but building
these links to our website will help our
rankings and that's the whole idea
behind off page seo we want to be able
to link from other websites to ours so
that we can help our rankings in
addition to some of the other benefits i
just mentioned so
google recognizes backlinks as one of
their top ranking factors so in addition
to some of the on-page seo tactics that
i mentioned earlier including title tag
and meta description and url structure
and headers all those are important but
at the same time it's a balance so
google wants to know hey yes we
understand you've optimized your title
tag for keyword but how does the rest of
the internet see your website or is your
website worthy enough to add a link from
a particular quality website to your
website so if there are a number of
quality links then your site must be of
quality as well and so that's the whole
idea behind link building being an
important factor because again it's
about from google's perspective it's
about the user experience they want to
make sure that sites ranked on page one
of google are quality sites quality
sites that load well that have good
content that have fresh content not just
sites that have a gazillion links
pointing to them with
you know keywords stuffed into the title
tag so it's an ecosystem google's and
other search engines want to protect
that ecosystem with quality so that's
why link building is an important factor
and so there are different types of
links so when you have a link pointing
from one website to your own okay the
link could be a follow link or no follow
link and the whole idea behind
follow or no follow is simply hey we
know that google and other search
engines are spidering the entire web the
whole idea is for them to collect as
many pages as they these search engines
can bring them back to their servers so
they can serve them up in their search
engines well as google and these other
search engines spider these sites
they're following what they're doing is
they're following links that's as simple
as it gets they're following links from
one link to another so remember we
talked about internal links earlier on
on page seo internal links are just
links on your web pages pointing to
other pages on your own website well
when it comes to external links so links
pointing from one website to your
website
that website that's linking to your
website has an opportunity to say hey
google you can follow this link or don't
follow the link and so if they choose to
not follow the link meaning they put a
nofollow tag into the anchor text then
google's going to follow the link but
not recognize the link itself and what i
mean by that is hey if you have uh let's
just use valley fig has a link from
wikipedia if wikipedia has a link
pointing to valleyfig.com but the link
itself is no follow then what google is
going to do is not recognize the link
itself they're not going to recognize
the link so therefore you're not going
to get credit or link juice as we say
you're not going to get any juice from
wikipedia to validate but if it is a
follow link then what google's going to
do is recognize the link and give you
credit for the backlink and by giving
you credit for the backlink that's going
to inherently increase your domain
authority it's also going to likely
increase your rankings so you want to
pay attention to the types of link
building that's out there no follow and
so anytime you try to establish a link
on an external website just make sure
it's a follow make sure it's not a no
follow because if it's a no follow link
then you're not going to get the credit
from the search engines and so the whole
idea behind link building in terms of
seo is to get some credit from a quality
website to your website and so if we
look here a follow link in this example
is one where the ahref or the link
itself doesn't have a nofollow in it but
if a hyperlink does have a nofollow in
it then that means you're not going to
get the credit for the backlink so
remember no follows they don't allow
search engine crawlers to follow the
link so
if that's the case it's not going to
pass any link juice when you don't pass
quote unquote link juice you're not
going to get credit for the backlink and
so if you don't get credit for the
backlink then if we go back to our tools
that we have available for measuring
off-page seo so if i go back to
let's just say moz or even let's just
say search console you know i'll be able
to see
all these links here these links that
are showing up are follow links why
because google's recognizing the link if
they were nofollow then we wouldn't see
the link in here so that's something to
keep in mind as well and so just keep in
mind if it is a no file you'll see in
the hypertext itself the nofollow tag
and you can always check that the html
of any particular link and so when we
talk about link building we talk about
off page seo really we're talking about
how to get links on quality websites and
how do we do that well i've listed here
a few ways to do that so you could do
guest blogging or blogging in general is
a good off page seo slash link building
strategy and i'll talk about more of
that in a minute but we can list our
websites in reputable and trustworthy
directories i mentioned wikipedia as an
example even though wikipedia may not be
classified as a directory but there are
other directories out there you could
ask for testimonials so if you're
working with clients or other websites
you could ask for testimonial or they
can provide a link pointing back from
their site to your site it's about
relationships really is what it comes
down to it's relationship building and
that's what a link is relationship
building or you could do content on
social media so these are just examples
of ways to generate links but let's go
back to the blogging part because
blogging to me is an essential part to
off-page seo and why is that because
anytime you are part of a blog you're
generating content and not only you
generating content you're generating
fresh content that's likely to be
interesting to the end user and with
that content yes you can optimize that
content but the beauty about blogging is
really anybody can do it but if we want
to connect blogging with relationships
if we're a food blogger then we can
write on other food blogs as a guest
writer and we can have that blog post
linked back to our own blog as an
example or we can have other bloggers in
the same industry write a guest blog for
us on their own blog and point their
link back to our site blogging creates a
lot of
opportunities for link building because
again it's a fresh canvas with
interesting content and when you have
interesting content then the opportunity
for back linking is going to be there
because if you're writing about
something that's interesting then
naturally you're going to want to link
to something else related to that that's
interesting and so that's the
opportunity that blogging creates
so again it's vital to get links from
authoritative web pages then multiple
links from low quality web pages so
going back to the link explorer report
we want to be able to pay attention to
those domain authorities or those
websites with low domain authority and
really you should pay attention to
really quality sites okay you want to
pay attention to quality sites and so
when we talk about links there's inbound
links there's outbound links we're
interested in those inbound links we're
interested in getting links from
high quality websites pointing to our
own website and again that could be in
the form of a blog it could be social
media it could be a partner site okay
these are all inbound links they just
need to be followed make sure they're
not a no follow so it's simple just
getting a external link that's a follow
to your to your own website and so the
one thing i want to mention here though
on inbound links from external websites
and that's making sure that not
necessarily every inbound link points to
the home page we want to be able to have
links point to internal pages so let's
harken back to
search console as an example so search
console our links report shows us
links pointing from external websites to
our own website but what are those
linked pages so if we look at some of
those linked pages here we can see the
top link pages we could see on
valleyfig.com slash recipes is the top
link page then the home page then the
about us then slash international so we
want to make sure that if we're trying
to generate backlinks from external
websites to our own website we want to
make sure that they're pointing to
interior pages not necessarily the home
page and why do i say that because one
of the benefits to link building and
off-page seo is ranking so the whole
idea about ranking
is to get some of our other pages ranked
not necessarily the home page the home
page is just a doorway into your website
if we have interesting content out there
on the web and it's a food blogger as an
example and they're talking about a
particular food item well they're going
to want a link to a page that's related
to what they're blogging about that
particular food item they don't want to
link to the home page the homepage is
just a doorway and so that's the whole
idea behind link building we want to
link to multiple pages on the site why
is that because if i take this
particular page valleyfig.com recipes
and i just put that into moz and i look
at the link explorer report for this
particular page the domain authority is
still going to be the same 35 that's
what valleyfig.com is 35 however there's
also another metric called page
authority so page authority is likewise
with the domain authority to score
between 100 and 100 and so the more
external links pointing to an internal
page with high domain authority that's
likely going to increase the page
authority of that page so in other words
if we have good links from other
websites pointing to that page then it's
going to increase the page authority for
that page and ultimately the domain
authority for that page and so just like
the domain authority in this case
valleyfig every page under that domain
has a page authority score so the higher
the score the likelihood that that page
is going to rank in the search engine
results okay so that's the whole idea
behind link building is we want to
improve the authority of the pages not
just the domain but also more
importantly we also want to keep the end
user in mind so if it's from a blog or
social media the link pointing from that
blog or social media platform should
naturally point to something related to
what you're talking about not just the
home page because again the home page
more or less is the gateway into the
website so we want to get people to
where they want to go we want to
naturally create a link from good
content to some other good content so
that's the whole idea behind backlinking
so outbound links will direct a user
from our own website to another website
so the idea here is it's okay to have
outbound links on your own website the
natural ecosystem of the world wide web
okay what i would recommend here is not
to have so many in a century located
place for example don't have one page
with nothing but external links on it
you know sprinkle these external links
these outbound links throughout your
website but also if it's not a
reciprocal link meaning if a guest
blogger is not linking to your website
but you're just linking to theirs and
they didn't ask you to then maybe
consider a nofollow tag maybe you know
ideally you want to make sure that these
links are just natural in nature so
don't just have a habit of putting
outbound links because the whole idea
behind outbound links is you want to
keep people on your website but if it's
a natural link going from one content to
another and you think the end user is
going to benefit then no problem but
just don't get in the habit of putting
external links on your website because
that means that hey that user that's on
your website may click on that link and
leave your website and not come back so
keep that in mind as well because you
don't necessarily
benefit from an seo perspective by
having outbound links on your own
website you want to do it as a courtesy
if somebody else is linking to you you
want to do it for the end user if you
feel the benefit from additional content
under the website but from an seo
perspective it doesn't necessarily
directly enhance your own website in
terms of ranking turn our attention to
duplicate content
so
a lot of us have websites with a lot of
content sometimes
we go ahead and take our website and
revise it create a new one or register a
new domain and put content on that new
domain and so
we may find ourselves in a situation at
one point or the other where we have two
websites with the same content or it
could be the same website
with a lot of content but some of that
may be duplicate as well so we want to
try and stay away from duplicate content
but for some of us we may stumble across
it accidentally we may find ourselves
having content that's duplicated and so
we want to try and prevent that because
that's a no-no in the world of seo so
if we have duplicate content appearing
in more than one url there are ways to
rectify
not having the search engines recognize
the content twice so some examples of
duplicate content are for example a
spammer takes an article and posts the
same content on his website or like i
mentioned before you create another
website or register another domain and
have
that particular
content on the old website still or
you're writing a blog post and you tag
it or categorize it and the content
shows up under the tags under the
categories and just shows up in general
so there are a lot of scenarios where
you can find yourselves with duplicate
content and so we want to rectify that
we don't want duplicate content we want
the search engines to recognize the
original source of the content and so
basically if you have two versions of a
web page you may result in duplicate
content issues another example that
would be for example if you have
products you may find that that same
product may be under two different
categories so how do we rectify that
well there are a number of different
ways and so the simple way is what they
call a 301 redirect to the original url
so if you find yourself in a situation
where you have a new website with the
same content you could simply set up a
redirect and we call it a 301 redirect
because 301 refers to
permanent so it's signifying to the
search engines that you're permanently
moving from this page to this page the
other way is through a canonical
attribute and so
the word canonical may not register with
some of you so
let's just uh take a minute to talk
about what a canonical is basically
canonical tag it's a page level meta tag
so remember that meta tag description we
talked about in on-page seo we'll think
about this as another type of meta tag
and it's placed in that html header of
your web page so basically all it does
is by placing this meta tag it tells the
search engines which url is the original
version to be displayed in index so it's
the purpose of a canonical is to keep
the duplicate content out of the search
engine index so we want to consolidate
our page rank our page authority our
domain authority all to original content
that's the whole idea of having a
canonical and it's a quick solution so
all you need to do is add a canonical
tag to the header so let me show you an
example if you have a site let's just
use cnn as an example cnn.com has a lot
of content sometimes given the breadth
of content that they have they may run
into duplicate content so they simply
just put a canonical tag into
their their header and so by doing that
they're able to
tell the search engines hey
this page this domain is the original if
you find yourself with multiple sites
well you can also use google search
console so remember we use google search
console in earlier examples when we
talked about
links to your site or we talked about
that site map on on-page seo well if we
go on a search console we could
basically say look google because search
console is a google tool we want to
confirm that this is our domain so this
is the domain you should be focusing on
so you can leverage search console to
communicate with google regarding which
site is important which is the one that
should get indexed you can use the
canonical you can put that on any page
either website or you could set up a 301
redirect so those are the ways to fix
duplicate content issues 301s are the
easiest canonicals tend to be temporary
because they're just the page level and
then search console is a a good method
because it communicates with google
directly and it allows google to crawl
various web pages differently than if
you didn't tell them okay so if you
didn't tell them they're just going to
grab anything they can so by
communicating via the google search
console tool it allows you to tell
google this is the domain i want to
focus in on so let's talk then now about
how the google algorithms work so we'll
shift gears here and we'll talk about
how these algorithms work on google so
google uses advanced concepts retrieve
data so what they do is they're
spidering they're spidering they're
collecting web pages and they're taking
all those web pages back to their server
and anytime somebody does a query
they're delivering those web pages
within milliseconds they're delivering
results based on your query so that's in
general how it works so it uses a
combination of different algorithms to
deliver the best results they want the
best results and so some of the most
popular algorithms below are
google panda google penguin and google
rankbrain so these are all
things that google has done
to make sure that they're constantly
tweaking their search engines to deliver
the best results so let's talk about
some of these these popular algorithms
and before we talk about these popular
algorithms let's just make one thing
clear that google's always tweaking
their algorithms on their search engine
and so if you want to get an idea how
often they do it well they do it every
day they're constantly tweaking it but
they what they do is they release major
changes to their algorithm a few times a
year so if you want to get a sense of
what those changes look like well you
could go to
moz.com and you can go to google dash
algorithm dash change and you can see
here that hey google changes his search
algorithm around 500 to 600 times while
most of these are minor google again
rolls out major changes like panda like
penguin that affects search results in
significant ways so you can go here and
you can go all the way back to 2000 and
see some of the algorithm changes that
have occurred over
the last few years and you can see here
the last major one was done in august of
2018 that was the metacore update so
they're constantly making changes to
their search engine to deliver a more
concise more better ecosystem for the
end user so if it's a better search
engine for the end user end users are
going to come back so the whole idea is
continuing to tweak the system the
algorithms to better show more accurate
results and so let's take a look at some
of the the major algorithm changes that
they've done in the past so the first is
we'll talk about google panda and panda
was an algorithm released back in 2011.
so here we are in 2019's a few years ago
but still significant in that really
this algorithm emphasized high quality
content because before panda there was a
there's just a lot of content out there
on the internet and
there was a lot of spam content there's
a lot of duplicate content and so really
the idea behind panda is for google to
really deliver in their search engine
results pages high quality content so
what it did was it removed web pages
that had low quality or duplicate
content so that was the whole idea
behind you know the algorithm nicknamed
panda it removed low quality and
duplicate content and that kind of
cleaned things up a bit where if you did
a search query now you'd actually see
better better results and one thing
about panda is because there's so much
quality because google is indexing so
much there on the internet that it's
constantly being updated it's updated
regularly so the next one we're going to
talk about is google penguin so
penguin was released after panda and
what that focused in on was low quality
links so remember we talked about link
building we talked about quality links
over quantity so
naturally you're going to have links
naturally from all websites whether that
be high quality or low quality the whole
idea behind this algorithm is to
sever the links that are low quality and
so the idea behind that was they focused
on two areas so they focused in on link
schemes and keyword stuffing so that's
what penguin focused on was link schemes
were basically
link almost link farming where you
produced mass amounts of backlinks and
not all of them were good quality they
weren't natural links links should be
natural from one high quality site or
blog to another high quality cider blog
and by creating link schemes you've
created an ecosystem where links just
went to irrelevant low quality spam
related pages and so google's penguins
algorithm update focused in on that
effort to remove or combat pages that
had poor links from being indexed in
their search engine results and then
they also combated keyword stuffing
keyword stuffing is nothing more than
taking your targeted keyword and
stuffing it into the content of your
page your title tag your meta
description so any sites that were
caught up doing that basically suffer
the consequences because what penguin
did was take care of sites that
basically were accused of keyword
stuffing or had characteristics of
keyword stuffing and they removed sites
that had a lot of links pointing to it
from poor quality sites and vice versa
sites that really had a lot of external
links pointing to other poor quality
sites so that's what penguin did they
took a look at those two areas i mean so
we talk about link schemes again
penguins aim was to decrease the ranking
of webpages that created artificially by
using black hat techniques and basically
what i mean by black cat techniques that
artificially creating links that just
didn't make sense just for the sake of
getting the backlink just for the sake
of passing link juice and so that's what
a link scheme is or was and so google
basically tweaked their algorithm to
combat those poor link schemes and so
keyword stuffing as i mentioned a minute
ago it's just repetitive usage of the
same keyword and that just basically
suffers the content is the thing that
suffers here and when the content
suffers the end users suffer so google
is all about quality content and when
you have quality content and that
quality content is indexed and users
find what they're looking for chances
are they're going to go back to the
search engine to continue to find what
they're looking for with the end result
being presented with quality content so
keyword stuffing really dilutes the
quality of the content and then let's
talk about the third algorithm which is
rankbrain so rankbrain is a processing
algorithm that uses machine learning and
what that does that machine learning
interprets search queries that users
search on google so
for example
if rankbrain sees a word or phrase it
isn't familiar with basically the
machine can make a guess as to what
words or phrases might have a similar
meaning and filter the result
accordingly so basically take these
search engine queries and present them
in a way that's logical so that the end
result can be something that's relevant
to what you're looking for and so for
example
if you're searching for online marketing
you will get results related for digital
marketing on search engine remote pages
why because rankbrain will interpret
that particular keyword and they're
trying to basically match based on all
the data they collected what words or
phrases might have a similar meaning so
online marketing digital marketing have
similar meanings now that we've talked
about some of the
different algorithm changes that google
has made over the years and continues to
make let's uh
segue into the types of seo and so when
we talk about the types of seo we're
really talking about
doing what's right what's expected
versus doing something that you know is
trying to cheat the system and so you
may hear the terminology black cat seo
white hat seo or gray hat seo and so the
whole idea behind these terminologies is
that hey what are we supposed to be
doing here in terms of following best
practices in order to get our pages
ranked on the search engines for the
keyword queries we covet and so let's
talk about what not to do first and
that's always black cat techniques so i
just mentioned a minute ago with panda
and penguin algorithm updates you know
penguin took into account you know lynx
schemes poor linking techniques keyword
stuffing so
those are considered black cat
techniques so black cat is a technique
used to improve page rank by violating
search engine rules and policies so it's
clearly google's made a clear line in
the sand they don't like link schemes
they don't like keyword stuffing so if
you take into account those practices
then you're practicing black hat
techniques to treat this cheat the
system to try and rank faster and so
some other ways of black cat or you know
redirecting or phishing
having duplicate content all these are
are things that are frowned upon by
search engines so the result of not only
algorithm changes is you could get your
website blacklisted from the search
engines if you are caught in violation
of their policies it's pretty clear-cut
so that's why the algorithms are in
place uh the algorithms try and create a
system an environment where you know
good quality content is shown so if
you're keyword stuffing you're creating
lots of duplicate content that's not in
adherence with you know google's
policies for creating good quality
content and as a result you could get
blacklisted so with black hat techniques
you run the risk of being penalized and
you don't want to be penalized by the
search engines so white hat contrarily
used to improve search engine rankings
by following those rules and policies so
in effect it's everything we talked
about today from on-page seo to off-page
seo doing the right thing with your
content in terms of organizing the
structure with headers creating very
clear and concise meta descriptions
submitting a site map all of those are
white hat techniques addressing page
load time using really relevant keywords
naturally in your content and creating
high quality content that's fresh and
interesting for the end user that's a
white hat technique that's going to get
you ranked higher and farther and with
better benefits so grey hat is just
simply a combination of black and white
it's the practice of improving by
following the policies but they
considered you know ethically dubious
and so what i mean by that is listen you
you don't want to purchase links you
want links to come across naturally you
don't want to do excessive internal
linking you don't want to have a lot of
links pointing to one page it's not
natural so you want to be able to do
things that
are
natural you don't want to just take
content from another side and claim it
as your own so you want to do things
that
are natural that's going to create a
good experience for the user because if
it's for the end user which it is then
generally it's going to be good for the
search engines and so let's talk about
website architecture now so
basically when i say website
architecture what i mean is we want to
give the search engines an idea of how
our website's built so website
architecture and the structure of
websites important and so every website
has a hierarchy it starts with the home
page the home page is the top page it's
the the domain it's where most people go
to find other pages of your website and
so generally you're going to have a
scenario where you're going to have a
home page with you know if you sell
products multiple categories and in
those categories you're going to have
multiple products so the generally
that's how a web architecture flows it
flows from top down and the reason for
having a good website architecture is
internal links are spread equally so you
want to make sure again not to apply a
black cat method or greyhound method of
pointing all links to one page you want
links naturally to spread throughout
your website because not just from an
seo benefit but from an end user
perspective you want users to flow
through your website naturally so if
you're planning on developing websites
from an seo perspective you know take
these things in consideration so we want
to take into account the site
architecture navigation we want to take
into account the url remember we talked
about url structure and on-page seo the
rule of thumb is if you can read it the
search engines will read it so we want
to keep it clear and concise and
relevant to the content of that page
when we talk about responsive design
we're talking about multiple devices so
you don't build a website just for
desktop especially when
mobile is being used by a majority of
the users around the world so you want
to build a website that's both desktop
friendly and mobile friendly we also
want to take into account a robot's text
file and a robot's text file is simply
just a text file that allows the search
engines to index
certain pages it tells them what not to
index and so you can always find the
robot's text file normally if you go to
a website and let's just say we go to
valleyfig.com
and then we type in robot or robots.txt
file here we can see if i type in
robots.txt file here this basically is a
file a text file that's in the root
directory and it simply just gives the
search engines an idea of what they're
allowed to index and what they're not
allowed to index anything with a
disallow means hey search engines please
don't index these pages so that's what a
robot's text file does and every site
should have it because there are some
pages on your website then you
inherently don't want the search engines
to index and you want to optimize for
the crawlers so that means that making
sure that your pages are available and
that means also submitting a sitemap
remember we submit our sitemap via the
google search console so good site
architecture not only makes content easy
to find but also helps to gain traffic
because hey if your site is easy it's
well organized it's built multiple
devices the urls are easy then all
that's going to be apparent to the
search engines and when it's apparent to
the search engines it's going to get
indexed they want to get indexed then
you're going to get found and you're
going to get the traffic so it's just a
natural progression it's best practice
so some important features of good
architecture are again that url
structure code your site navigation in
css or html make it easy for the search
engines to follow build a comprehensive
structure for an internal linking
meaning they should be natural internal
links if a page is relevant to another
page then create an internal link if you
have a very big website with a lot of
content or a lot of products then create
a breadcrumb navigation okay so we're
maybe familiar with that on amazon as an
example
amazon.com has a lot of products and
if you're navigating from one product to
another in one directory or one category
to another category then amazon creates
what they call breadcrumbs to help you
navigate back to where you were quickly
so
these are all good best practices for
good site architecture good site
architecture equals search engine
results so responsive design helps to
make your website mobile friendly it
will increase the amount of time the
user spends on your website which may
improve site ranking so let's talk a
second about mobile friendliness so if i
go back to google search console there
happens to be
in search console a mobile usability
report and so if i click on that report
basically what it's going to show me is
pages that
are do not follow google's best
practices so some of google's best
practices are making sure that the text
is easy to read that clickable elements
aren't necessarily close to one another
and the viewport is set to the
appropriate device meaning the screen is
set to the appropriate device okay and
so
basically
if we are found in violation then the
pages affected are going to get flagged
by google and if the page is affected or
flagged by google then those pages won't
get indexed and so we want to keep an
eye on the mobile usability report in
google search console so remember it's
better to have a good site architecture
that bots can easily index so bots will
give preference to web pages with
relevant content and in the end it will
help your website rank better and as a
side note always use a site map to make
it easy for the bots to crawl your
website so we covered that and on page
as a reminder if i go back to search
console and if i click on site maps i
can go ahead and submit my sitemap so if
i created an xml version of my sitemap
called
sitemap.xml and i submit that basically
what i'm doing is i'm saying hey google
here's my sitemap file and in that
sitemap file are all the pages on my
website that want to get indexed and
when you submit your sitemap to google
basically they're going to
discover those urls and index those urls
and their search index and that
expedites the process of getting indexed
it expedites the process of getting
found on search and it expedites the
process of getting clicks on your search
results pages and and having that
traffic go to your website where they
can enjoy the user experience and
convert and remember the robots text
file is there to allow google and other
search engines to know what pages to
crawl so good website architecture like
for example amazon they use breadcrumbs
they have a hierarchy in terms of of
categories okay so you can see how it's
evenly dispersed on the left side on the
right side a poor website architecture
is very slanted in one direction a lot
of internal links no breadcrumbs the
navigation isn't very clear so we want
to make sure things are simple and easy
so let's turn our attention to local seo
so local seo is for those businesses who
focus on a specific market it could be
a whole state like the state of florida
in the united states it could be a
specific city in a particular state like
orlando florida or miami it really
depends on the business and who you are
trying to attract and what geo location
you are trying to attract so if you're
trying to attract a segment of audience
in a specific location then local seo
should be
in your sites uh for optimization and so
when we talk about local seo we're
really talking about optimizing your
website to get traffic from a specific
location so that's what local seo is and
the idea behind local seo is to put your
particular service or product or
whatever it is you're offering to
that particular geo market that
particular locale or that city or that
state so you want to put yourself in
front of the right audience that's the
whole idea behind local seo and so if we
focus it on google you know local
results are based on three factors and
this is according to google so it's
based on a relevancy so if somebody's
looking for a plumber and you happen to
be a plumber in that particular locale
or city or zip code then chances of you
getting found are going to be great
because of relevancy and then distance
so where that person's located based on
your address or where you're located has
a role in how you display on local seo
and then prominence so prominence is
also very important because you know how
prominent are you as a business are you
getting a lot of reviews do you have a
lot of different locations do you have
all your photos and all your information
posted so prominence does play a bit of
factor along with distance along with
relevancy on google local seo so these
factors combined to help find the best
match for your search just somebody
typing in that plumber or say that
italian restaurant or
any particular product or service is
going to find local results and you want
to be there to to meet that person when
they're looking for your product or
service so that's the whole idea behind
local seo and so one of the factors with
local seo is having consistent nap or
not and so what is nip it's really name
address and phone number so it sounds
very simple and it is simple you just
have to be consistent so if you have a
local seo presence on say bing search
engine you want to make sure that the
name address and phone number are can
also the same name and address and phone
number on google so it's just about
consistency so that's what we want to do
we want to make sure that we're
consistent across the board because it's
important for companies that want to
rank well have some consistency and it's
important too when we talk about
consistency to actually have that
information you need obviously the name
of your company you obviously need a
phone number and you need to put your
address in there but really of all three
the phone number's just as important
because we talk about local seo we
mentioned mobile earlier we know that a
lot of people initiate their search on
mobile and so if they're looking for a
local restaurant or local cafe or that
plumber and you appear in local seo then
your phone number's going to appear with
the results and that gives an
opportunity for somebody to go ahead and
just click on that number to call it
just makes it that much easier for
somebody to get in touch with you so
consistency and having all your
information are important factors for
local seo so having an inconsistent nap
if you will is not going to bode well
for you on the local seo results okay
it's important because it offers up
legitimate legitimacy it offers up
better rankings and at the end of the
day it's going to help you get those
calls it's going to help you get traffic
to your website so for example
if a particular company that sells puma
running shoes has a yellowpages.com
listing we want to be consistent if it's
on yellowpages.com and this is their
address on their website then you need
to be consistent with that if it's
inconsistent and we're talking about
very minor details but these minor
details are important simply just
putting rd as road and then spelling out
row is going to cause some inconsistency
so consistency is very important why
because local seo is also tied to
mapping you know google maps and so
google wants to see consistency so that
they can offer up the address and the
mapping services so that's one good
reason why it needs to be consistent
another reason is again you know so many
may want to
drive to your location or call your
location or see if that location is
close to them so that's why consistency
is such a key component to local seo so
in order to get started on google for
local seo what you want to do is you
want to just do a search for google my
business so google my business is the
platform in which you're going to set up
your local business and once you set up
your google my business account whatever
that account is you want to make sure
you have all the credible information in
there i can't stress that enough you
need to have that phone number you need
to have that address it needs to be
consistent but with google my business
there's a lot of things you can do here
so you can manage reviews so if you do
have a location you can go ahead and
manage those reviews uh that somebody
puts in for your business and so if it's
a negative review you definitely want to
respond to that negative review if it's
a positive view you definitely want to
respond to that positive review so you
can manage reviews you can upload photos
so photos is a big component as we
talked about with all tags and images
you know having these images help appear
in the local seo results you can manage
a lot of other things your information
you can manage posts you can offer up
promotions there's a lot of things you
could do you could set your business
hours so the more information you put in
to google my business the more
information is gonna can be conveyed to
the end user looking for your products
and services and google my business even
goes as far as offering up the
opportunity to have a website so if
you're a business that doesn't even have
your own website you can create a
website right in google my business and
so the end result is this if somebody's
looking for let's just say
lice removal
and orlando let's just say your child
comes home from school with some lice
you need services that offer up lice
removal well you're going to be able to
see businesses listed in the atlanta
region that offer up the service you're
looking for and if you're on a mobile
phone you can go ahead and quickly you
know call that person you can go to the
website you look at the reviews so local
seo is very important to local
businesses very important and so you
want to make sure you have consistent
presence not just on google but on bing
and some of these other local platforms
like yellowpages.com for example so
being prominent across multiple
platforms is going to put yourself in
front of the right audience who's
looking for your products and services
let's talk about how to measure your seo
performance so all that hard work you've
done with on-page seo
and coupled with all the work you've
done with off-page seo are eventually
gonna net results and positive results
and we want to be able to measure that
as you're actually doing the work as
you're putting forth the effort on on
page and off page and so we want to be
able to measure that and so
you want to be able to understand
what to measure and where to measure it
and so when we talk about seo we really
want to hone in on three high-level core
metrics and that's ranking traffic and
conversion so when we talk about ranking
traffic and conversion we can break that
down into this list here what kind of
traffic are we getting from organic
search what kind of traffic are we
getting from mobile devices remember
mobile is very important because as we
talked about with on-page seo as we
talked about with local seo a lot of
searches start with mobile devices we
want to look at keyword ranking remember
keyword research is the first step in
the seo process even before we do any
work with on-page and off-page you know
we want to look at the local visibility
if we have local seo results we want to
look at engagement metrics so all that
traffic we're driving from organic
search we want to be able to measure how
they're performing and behaving on our
website we also want to measure some
form of progress on off-page seo and
that's in the form of backlinks so all
of these are different metrics we can
measure using different tools so let's
talk about how to go about looking at
these metrics and where to go look at
them and measure them and so
really
monitoring all this behavior will help
us understand how we're performing how
seo is performing and so really what we
want to do is start with organic traffic
and so we can look at that on a
month-to-month basis we can look at it
from a geographic perspective we can
look at it in terms of how many new
visitors were driving versus returning
and then again more importantly
conversion rate and so to me the best
place to start to look at that traffic
from organic search is google analytics
and google analytics is a free tool it's
simply there to measure website
performance so if you go into google
analytics we can actually go in and we
can look at all sorts of data based on
website behavior and so if i'm in google
analytics and i go under acquisition and
then i go under all traffic channels
over a given period of time let's just
say the last seven days for a particular
website i can see what traffic is coming
from organic search and then i could see
the amount of new users that are coming
from organic search i can also see
engagement metrics bounce rate for
example so
i want to be able to see if somebody's
typing in a query clicking on our link
in the organic search results and then
coming to our website are they actually
engaging with our website or are they
leaving the website after only visiting
the page they landed on so that's all in
these are all important metrics to
measure and i can measure all that right
here in google analytics if i wanted to
i can even take it a step further and
break that down by country so if i type
in country as a secondary dimension now
i can see what country is driving
traffic from organic search so a lot of
your organic traffic information is
going to be centrally located in google
analytics so we also talked about mobile
traffic a majority of searches take
place on mobile phones versus desktop so
google basically is reporting that
nearly 60 percent of searches now appear
from mobile devices and so if we go back
to google analytics we can also look at
a mobile report so if i go in google
analytics under audience under mobile
overview i can see a breakdown of the
amount of traffic coming from desktop
versus tablet versus mobile and so
you'll find as time goes on that your
mobile device is likely going to drive a
majority of the traffic from organic
search and so you can compare device
information with channel so if i just
type in channel and google analytics as
a secondary dimension and look at the
default channel groupings versus device
category i could see that you know
mobile from organic search has driven
traffic over the last seven days this is
something you want to keep an eye on
because a lot of people tend to begin
their searches on mobile devices so
mobile ranking is different than desktop
ranking because with mobile ranking it's
based on a responsive website and with
that responsive website basically
responsive being that the website's
going to adapt to the mobile device so
it's going to respond to the device that
somebody's on and so therefore the
metrics or the engagement metrics are
going to be different but if i look back
to google analytics i can see again
bounce rate i can see pages per session
average session duration so if i look at
line three i could see all the different
engagement metrics compared to those
metrics from other devices
and other channels okay so you want to
be able to do a comparison because if
behavior is not up to par engagement is
not the par on mobile then you want to
do something about that so you want to
hone in on mobile traffic specifically
from organic search because the behavior
is going to be different you know people
start their searches on mobile the
site's going to be different and so
therefore it's a different experience
altogether so make sure you track the
behavior and more importantly make sure
you track that page speed so earlier we
talked about on page seo when we honed
in on page speed so just as a reminder
if i'm back in analytics and i go back
under behavior then if i go to site
speed then if i go to overview i'll be
able to see the average page load time
on my website i can also look at
specific page timings and i should be
able to see that by device so if i type
in device category i'm going to be able
to see how each page loads per device
and so this allows me to understand
which pages are loading fast which pages
are not loading as fast and address
those pages accordingly to improve
engagement metrics so we want to keep an
eye on page speed as well as overall
user behavior from mobile devices you
can also use other tools that are out
there like agency analytics there are
plenty of tools out there i tend to use
google analytics because primarily it's
free and google analytics is a google
product so it works with other google
platforms like google search console we
want to keep an eye on ranking so
remember when we do our keyword research
we're choosing keywords that have high
relevancy high volume and low
competition so we want to be able to
track keywords that we choose that have
high relevancy high volume and low
competition and so the tool we use or at
least i recommend using is moz so i
mentioned moz earlier with on page and
off page seo so if we go into
moz and we know what keywords we're
trying to rank for we can go ahead and
add them to mods and what moz does is
they actually track where these keywords
rank and so if i go into moz and i click
on rankings i'll be able to see on a
weekly basis or a monthly basis how our
keywords are ranking and for what pages
they're ranking so for whatever keyword
i choose to to optimize for i want to
make sure i put those keywords in moz
because when i put them in moz moz is
going to on a weekly basis tell me where
these keywords rank and for what url
they're ranked for so that way i can
keep an eye on ranking over time because
in theory the higher you rank the more
traffic you're going to get and so we
want to be able to see the trend in
which keywords rank okay so if i click
on a particular keyword in moz it's
going to give me over a period of time
where that keyword is ranked be able to
see improvement in ranking for
particular keyword the whole idea behind
seo is to choose keywords that are
relevant optimize for those keywords so
that you can be ranked for those
keywords in order to get the traffic and
conversions so moz is a good platform
that helps us monitor rankings for
particular keywords now if you don't
want to use moz as an alternative you
can turn your attention to google search
console and so remember we talked about
google search console earlier when we
talked about sitemaps we also talked
about mobile usability with search
console we also talked about links to
your site with google search console so
google search console is a good tool to
help you understand how you're
performing with organic search and so
there's one tool in particular which is
performance that helps us understand
what keyword queries people are actually
typing into google search and so here i
can see the actual query and so with
this particular website valleyfig.com i
can see that dried fig recipes over the
course of the last three months had
5414 impressions that means that one of
my pages either one or multiple pages
appeared in google search engine results
5414 times and over the course of those
impressions i received 1100 clicks so
google search console is going to be
able to tell me not only you know how
many impressions i receive for a
particular keyword but they also are
going to tell me how many clicks and if
i wanted to add more metrics to that i
can add them like the average ranking
position for keyword the click-through
rate so i can add multiple metrics to
this report to give me an understanding
of hey are any of my targeted keywords
being used or queried and if they are
where am i ranking and i am i showing up
and am i getting clicks so search
console serves is a good alternative if
not primary tool or platform for you to
measure how your organic search results
are showing so for local visibility this
metric is important for
you know maintaining local seo so
remember on the local seo we talked
about
google my business so if i go back to
google my business i can go into my
account and so google my business is
going to be able to show me some metrics
so if i go into google my business and
click on insights i'm going to be able
to see
a number of different metrics over the
course of a month i can see exactly you
know what queries were used by how many
users and when i appeared so i'll be
able to see how many views i receive not
only on search results but on maps then
i can also see what actions people took
when they saw my results in maps or in
search did they visit my website did
they request directions did they call so
i can actually see engagement metrics
right in google my business i could see
a breakout by zip code i could see phone
calls by day of the week i could see how
many people even viewed my photos so
there's a lot of insights into
local seo on google my business so that
gives you an idea of how you're
performing organically on local search
and remember you want to be able to use
google my business to hone in on your
specific audience so all these metrics
help you align with whether you're
getting in front of the right audience
and whether that audience is actually
behaving the way you want them to
meaning you know are they actually
contacting you are they going to your
website are they calling you so local
visibility and understanding the metrics
involved with local seo is very
important so google my business is where
you want to turn your attention so
overall engagement metrics are important
they play an important role in
determining rankings for example we
talked about bounce rates a bounce rate
is the rate at which people go from
organic search to your website and then
leave after uh seeing one page and not
going any further so if they land on a
page and then leave the website after
landing on that page it's considered a
bounce and so bounce or bounce rate is a
good indication of how people are
receiving our website or the content
that they're reading on our website
there are other metrics involved like
average session duration or pages per
visit all of these are engagement
metrics and let's not forget about page
speed so page speed is also a good
engagement metric all of these metrics
affect or determine rankings so we want
to be able to make sure that if we're in
google analytics and we're looking at
engagement metrics that our metrics are
good because if somebody comes to our
website from organic search and there's
a high bounce rate then what does that
tell us that there's a disconnect
between what that person's querying and
then the content that they're reading
and so we want to be able to address
those engagement metrics so that we can
continue to not only drive quality
traffic but keep the traffic engaged and
then in turn drive up conversions last
metric we want to look at is backlinks
so content having more backlinks from
good domains will effectively improve
your seo performance we talked about
backlinks with off-page seo and remember
quality over quantity and so we can
measure backlinks going back into moz we
can use moz's link explorer tool so
remember if i type in a domain valley
fig i can get
some metrics related off page seo
including my domain authority but more
importantly i can see
what links are pointing to my site in
this case valleyfig.com so i can see
there are 575 link domains i can see
there are 7 900 inbound links and so
just by clicking on that i can get an
idea of the types of websites that are
linking to my site and their domain
authority and their spam score google
search console so if you go back into
search console you can also just click
on links and we should be able to get an
idea of you know what websites are
linking to our site and more importantly
we want to be able to see not only what
sites but what pages they're linked to
remember we want our backlinks pointing
to interior pages not necessarily the
home page so here i can see the top link
page for valleyfig.com is slash recipes
so we want links pointing to our
interior pages not necessarily the home
page that's what's going to help your
performance your rankings for all your
pages not just your home page so having
quality back links pointing to interior
pages help boost the domain authority
and the page authority for that
particular page so again using moz
link explorer tool or using the links
report and search console are good
sources for you to identify backlinks so
when we look at these these reports we
want to look at the domain authority of
these sites that are linking ours the
number of outbound links to the site or
specific pages on our site we want to be
able to look at the ratio of length
distribution
you know we want to be able to look at
how many follows and nofollow so most of
this if not all of these metrics are in
moz so if i go back to moz i can
actually see you know which one's
pointing which ones are followed the
total quality of the link that's
pointing to our site again bam so moz
link explorer report tends to give us
all the information we need in order to
measure and get a sense of our backlinks
that help us with off-page seo so there
are other tools out there there's hrefs
again search console there's other seo
platforms out there that'll help you
measure backlinks okay now that we
covered everything with on-page seo and
off-page seo and really everything seo
in general let's take a little quiz and
if you could go ahead and just put your
answers in the comment section below so
just a little quiz here and we'll start
out with question one which the
following type of site map is
specifically designed for search spiders
so the answer is either a html sitemap
or b xml sitemap so go ahead and put
your answers in the comment section
below i'll give you just another second
to think about that okay another
question for you from a search engine
perspective which of the following link
types could cause a negative effect on
your rankings it's either a purchase
link or b no follow link so again if you
could if you know the answer or just
take an educated guess go ahead and put
the answers in the comment section below
okay next question a website's robot's
text file serves what function is it a
tell the bots what pages should be
crawled and not crawled or b tells the
bots what links should be follow and no
follow so if you know the answer you
feel good about your answer go ahead and
put it in the comment section below
today we're going to talk about seo tips
and tricks so let's get started
and throughout this series we're gonna
have a few tips to share with you and
we'll start out with tip number one opt
for smarter ways to do keyword research
and so
if you listen to any of our seo
tutorials in the past you know that
keyword research is the first step but
the most crucial step in starting seo so
when we do keyword research we want to
be able to
basically find keywords that we feel are
relevant to our business that we want to
be found on search for and so here are a
few tips that can help you do that
research in a more efficient manner the
first thing we want to do is identify a
list of keywords that are relevant so we
only want to focus on relevant keywords
for a business that's a given so what i
would suggest is as a best practice
maybe you know put down some of those
keywords in a spreadsheet so think of
them as a theme of keywords because when
you do research you're going to want to
include a theme of keywords related to
one another so you can pick the best
ones out of that theme and so as an
example
if we have a company that sells dried
figs in a spreadsheet as an example if i
show you a spreadsheet maybe we want to
focus in on just dried fig and maybe we
want to focus in on dried fig recipes so
go ahead and put those in a column you
know some of these keywords that you
know you want to be found for so that's
really the first step they need to be
relevant so put them in a spreadsheet so
that you can build keywords around that
list then we want to choose keywords and
when we choose keywords we want to have
some criteria around choosing them and
so we always want to choose keywords
with a lot of volume and what i mean by
volume i mean how many people on average
type in that keyword or a related
keyword per month the second criteria is
the key word of product fit meaning you
know is the keyword relevant you always
want to stay true to relevancy the third
is commercial intent what is the intent
of the keyword is it trying to get us a
sale is it answering a question so what
is the intent of that keyword and then
last it's difficulty so we want to
definitely take a look at how difficult
a keyword is to rank for on organic
search so that's some of the criteria
you may have some additional criteria
that you want to use but this is the
criteria basically for choosing keywords
so again we want to prefer keywords with
high volume you want to be careful of
seasonality so remember seasonality in
this example christmas tree you're only
going to have a spike you know during
the winter or excuse me the october
november december months so be careful
of seasonality when choosing high volume
keywords and again keywords that are
relevant to your product even though it
doesn't have much search volume
relevancy always trumps uh volume or any
other metric commercial intent so we
want to look at keywords that for
example have buy in them they may have
low search volume but if somebody's
typing in that keyword then we can
insinuate that the consumer who typed in
that keyword is ready to make the
purchase so we want to look at what the
intent is of that keyword and then again
the difficulty always opt for keywords
that have low difficulty or competition
and so in order to get these metrics we
can use third-party tools i'm going to
show you a couple of examples of
third-party tools you can use that will
give you some of this information so the
first tool i'm going to show you is
google ads keyword planner so
if i'm having a google ads account i
could simply go to tools and then choose
the keyword planner and from there i
want to find new keywords so if i choose
the keyword dried figs because that's
the keyword i put in my spreadsheet that
i'm interested in optimizing for and
then maybe drive fake recipes that was
the other keyword theme
so if i enter those two keywords in just
to begin with basically what google is
going to give me is the average search
monthly volume so here i can see dried
figs i have an average monthly search
volume 8 100. that means on average over
the last 12 months that's how many
people have typed in that keyword here i
can see a little bit of a trend i just
hover my mouse over that graph i can see
again for seasonality impact if there is
any seasonality what the volume is on
average per month then i can see the
competition is high and because this is
google ads because it's paid search
they're going to give me a sense or an
idea of what i should be bidding on that
keyword now that's another topic for
another day but it's good information to
have because if you're not ranking for a
keyword you could decide to bid on it
for paid search so don't discard the
bidding information go ahead and put it
in a spreadsheet for later use but for
now we're focused in on keywords that
are relevant how much volume how much
competition okay so once i get this
information here i can simply go back to
my spreadsheet and put that information
in there what's the volume for dried fig
what is the competition now for
competition notice that google ads gives
us a high or low now if we're trying to
measure
ratio between volume and competition we
want to get an actual sense of what that
competition is so what i always do as a
best practice is go into google search
if i go to google search and i type in
dried figs
i'm going to see the actual volume is 34
million 500 thousand so i could see
that's the actual search volume for this
particular keyword however if i add a
syntax called all in title before that
keyword with the colon space and then
hit enter then i could see the actual
volume reduces to 31 000 and basically
what this tells me is that 31 000
listings or results have the keyword
dried figs in the title tag so if a web
page has dried fig our targeted keyword
in the title tag then ideally we can
insinuate that that page is trying to
rank for that keyword so therefore in
order for us to rank number one on
google we have to jump over 31 000
results so we want to be able to include
this information into our keyword
analysis so if i go into our keyword
analysis here and i
go ahead and enter in that information
so what's my keyword my keyword is dried
figs okay my volume was eighty one
hundred my competition was thirty one
thousand and so that gives me a ratio of
eighty one divided by thirty one
thousand if i make that into a
percentage basically 26
so that's my keyword effectiveness index
or kei or ratio between volume and
competition and so that's an a way that
you can
gather information is by using google
ads enter the information into a
spreadsheet and then sort all your data
by kei you can sort it by volume you can
sort it by competition all these metrics
matter alternatively as another tool you
can use moz so moz has a keyword
explorer tool okay so if i type in the
keyword dried figs focusing on the
united states i could see that moz says
hey look there's anywhere between 4
hundred and sixty five hundred in terms
of volume out of a hundred the
difficulty is forty one and so i can
expect a click-through rate of you know
forty-one percent and so basically the
great thing about moz's keyword explorer
tool is i can also look at the search
analysis search engine results pages
what serp stands for and i can analyze
the serp for a particular keyword in moz
so i want to be able to understand what
my competition is doing so here i could
see if i really want to try and optimize
for that keyword i could see what the
other pages are ranked for that keyword
in the on page one i can also
see what local results show up for that
keyword so here i can see that we have a
number of different sites listed here so
if we want to be number one these are
the sites that are basically above us
that we need to
climb over to be number one on google so
i find that the keyword explore tool in
moz is very helpful for understanding
your competition as well as getting a
alternative check on volume and
competition or difficulty if you will
and so remember we want to identify a
list of keywords that are relevant i
can't stress that enough we want to
choose keywords based on difficulty we
want to choose keywords based on volume
on commercial intent and more important
relevancy we can also identify trends
from a site search query like amazon and
know what your competitors are ranking
for so we can also go back into moz and
we can see just by typing in some of the
keywords we're focusing on we can see if
our competitors are ranking for the same
keywords just by using that keyword
explorer tool and then another thing we
want to look at is lsi or latent
semantic indexing so that's a fancy word
which basically means we want to find
keywords related to the topic of the
page you're trying to optimize so if
there are other keywords on that page
then you could sway in that direction
and so when it comes to choosing
keywords you want to choose always a
primary and secondary keyword and so if
we go back to our spreadsheet it doesn't
necessarily always have to be just one
keyword it doesn't necessarily have to
be dried figs we could choose another
keyword that has a good volume to
competition ratio so we want to choose
keywords that are always relevant and if
we're analyzing nothing but relevant
keywords then we want to be able to
choose keywords that have a good ratio
between volume and competition so you
always want to choose at least two
keywords per page we could also stay up
to date on industry news as it will help
you learn new jargon so it doesn't hurt
to
subscribe to sites like search engine
watch or search engine land they have
lots of good tips so here i'll show you
what that one of those sites look like
if i simply just go to search engine
watch dot com i find this is a good
resource to stay up on the latest news
when it comes to search engines here we
can see
why seo and front-end developers are the
perfect search marketing team another
article about optimizing your channel
youtube channel five easy steps so
there's a lot of information here on
search engine watch that pertain to seo
and keyword research we could also look
at other third-party sites like
wikipedia reddit and core for example so
if i go to quora i can do a search for
dried figs and i can see
what's being written about that topic so
that should give me some ideas to build
a keyword a list around so for example
the health benefits of dried figs okay
are dry figs safe for diabetes best ways
to eat dry figs so those are all good
keyword themes that we could build a
keyword list around and i did that
simply just by typing in drive figs on
core so that's a a good tip for you to
leverage when you're trying to build out
a keyword list okay let's uh talk about
tip number two which is publish high
quality content to get more traffic to
your website
so
it's all about content so we've already
done the keyword research we still need
to
kind of merge the two when we talk about
merging the two it's not just building
content around those keywords it's much
more than that when it comes to seo and
so that's why we always talk about high
quality content so let's talk about some
of the tips that can help you create
high quality content so
first tip is we want to be able to
publish longer and engaging content
longer and engaging content tends to
rank higher in google why because you
have more content to work with and when
you have more content to work with you
can optimize it you can structure it you
can insert different assets like videos
and images and by keeping it long you're
gonna likely keep it engaging and so
google tends to lean in favor of content
that is well organized structured and
long because it is more likely to be
engaging for the end user we definitely
want to include those target keywords so
you want to be able to
you know insert those keywords into
those meta tag descriptions into his
title tags into those alt tags but you
want to work them in naturally you don't
want to force anything content should be
naturally written because if it's
naturally written it's going to be
engaging so we want to use lsi keywords
in the content so lsi or basically
latent semantic indexing basically just
means different terms and concepts
related to your target keywords so feel
free to use terms that are similar to
what you're currently using these
keywords can definitely be used for seo
because they create more visibility and
potentially higher rankings because it
gives you an opportunity to use keywords
that are natural and work for different
variations and
let's look at examples so if you're
optimizing an e-commerce category page
and your keyword is one mix used for men
so we want to use keywords closely
related to one mix used for men for
example running shoes for men or sport
running shoes for men outdoor sport
shoes or air cushion shoes let's take a
look an example of amazon so if i go to
amazon i could see the one mix used for
men page and if i look at this page i
can see a lot of product and each
product has basically some content
associated with it i.e the title of the
particular product and so you want to be
able to
use different descriptors for this
particular product for example men's
running shoes or breathable lightweight
gym sports shoes or lightweight casual
sneakers or walking casual sneaker all
of these are lsi related keywords
they're similar to what we're trying to
optimize for so you don't necessarily
always have to be brand heavy or stick
with one keyword you could definitely
show variation especially on the
e-commerce side if you're dealing with
different product so we want to make the
content readable with the help of
visuals subtitles and bullet points so
if you're e-commerce you want to make
sure that page is laid out properly easy
to read you hear i could see the
descriptor along with the title all kind
of merge together and so there's no
break out of okay this is the product
name this description it's kind of one
all-in-one which i like it just makes it
more natural sounding okay and you can
see these are all broken out uh pretty
well laid out page and amazon is more or
less you know consistent in terms of how
their pages are laid out so make it
readable add visuals add subtitles add
bullet points it helps break out a lot
of the content especially if you have a
long amount of content or large amount
of content so the use of subtitles
bullet points and visuals will help
break it out structure it and make it
more engaging for the end user you
definitely want to write an effective
and organized content in order to reduce
the bounce rate so there is correlation
between engagement and bounce rate the
more you structure the more you add
visuals the more you add subtitles the
more engaged somebody's gonna be the
less likely they are to bounce from the
page we also want to share customer
reviews and ratings so
if you have a webpage you sell product
even if you don't sell products it's
always good to have testimonials or some
type of customer review so if we go back
to our example
on amazon and we clicked on a product uh
one of the running shoe products we look
here we can see the image we could see
kind of the description well i may not
be so interested in buying this product
i want to know a little bit more about
it well that's where the breaking point
comes in that's where the decision
factor comes in where if i read other
reviews then i can possibly have my mind
made up to buy this product so here i
could see that not only there are
reviews but there's testimonials so i
could see that here you can see that
there's a lot of stars and you can see
the kind of the review title these
running shoes are very comfortable and
lightweight so you have a lot of
different feedback and so reading custom
reviews is always helpful because even
though you're making the decision it
kind of will help sway you in one
direction or another at least it does
for me so that's the the beauty of a
customer review and a rating we want to
be able to use those to our advantage
and then you want to be able to update
your content on a regular basis so and
that goes for testimonials and reviews
you want to make sure you're always
getting reviews if you're always getting
reviews then that's just adding to the
particular product and so if you're
always updating your content on a
regular basis as well then google's
going to be able to see that and google
likes fresh content okay we also want to
include the benefits of the product so
if you're selling a product any product
you always want to include the benefits
you want to do as much as you can to
make your product engage into the end
user enticing so that they can buy it so
in addition to customer reviews or
adding content about the product you
want to include benefits so if we go
back to
amazon here we can see amazon lists a
lot of the benefits or one mix in this
case list a lot of the benefits so here
you can see all the descriptors about
the particular product it's got rubber
sole it's got a breathable textile
lighting you get free high quality socks
with every shoe so these are some of the
features and if we continue to scroll
down
we could see some of the details about
the fabric type specifics about the
fabric and a lot of information on this
product page even a sizing chart so a
lot of different features that will help
the end user make the decision so don't
hold back add as much information as you
possibly can as much information as you
have available it doesn't hurt because
in the end what you're trying to do from
a product perspective is sell the
product and you can't really sell it
unless you have information that's going
to convince the user that this product
is what they want to buy so include the
warranty size recommendation return
policy and some offers so it should all
be listed on the page easy for the end
user to see so can't stress it enough
provide as much product information as
possible go back here here it has a
sizing chart what colors are available
again some of the descriptors if i
scroll down here i can see
some more of the benefits you know
waffle rubber outsole soft deodorant
insole again fabric type it's got all
sorts of information it's got images
about the fabric itself the shoe itself
how it's structured so a lot of
information about this and it even does
a comparison and so there's a lot of
information about this particular
product so don't hold back add as much
as you can to convince the end user so
in the case of the one mix on amazon you
know they had a sizing chart you know
they had an faq being additional
information what other products that
customers view from one mix and then
testimonials so these are some of the
basic bits of information you want to
add on your page if you don't have
customer reviews it's okay add faq in
its place again the end result is to
convince the customer to purchase the
product and then build a comprehensive
internal linking structure of web pages
so every product page should link to
similar products so if i go back here
here i can see other products from one
mix so you should always have a linking
structure so that if the end user
doesn't want to particularly buy that
particular product then you have links
available so they can go to another page
and then add different varieties and
related short videos of the product so
if we go back to our product page you
know they have different varieties that
they're showcasing here they have the
size chart they even have a size
convertible chart so if you're dealing
with metrics you can go over to us
metrics feet vice versa you can add a
video you know show a video of if you're
selling running shoes throw a video
somebody working out you know it doesn't
have to be a full blown commercial per
se but it could be a short 30 second
video of what the shoe looks like on
somebody else's feet so that they could
see somebody walking with those shoes on
so video doesn't have to be a big
production you can do it right from your
phone so review your content before you
publish this goes without saying you
want to do that just you make sure you
include everything possible because when
the content does get published remember
google is going to index that content
when they index it it's going to show up
in the search results so we want to make
sure we have all the information readily
available not only for the end user but
for google as well we want to be able to
analyze our meta tags in url to improve
click-through rates so this is important
because the meta tags i.e the title tag
and the meta description and the urls
what shows up in google search results
so we have title tags the first that's
the first important element that's what
shows up in the search results so what
we want to do is we want to optimize the
title tag and when we optimize it we
want to use modifiers and when i say
modifiers i mean you know feel free to
use the word best or cash back or free
shipping or discount so for example if
you're selling running shoes 25 best
sneakers or up to 70 off or free
shipping or buy shoes on discount very
action oriented but you know it includes
these modifiers that are going to help
somebody click on that link so
some tips for optimizing the title tag
in addition to modifiers we want to
watch the title length and we want to
include those target keywords in the
title tag so remember you're likely
going to have two keywords to work with
you want to have at least one of those
keywords in your title tag so with the
modifier you know up to 60 to 65
characters in length with that targeted
keyword should get you a good title tag
that's going to get somebody to click on
it so let's look at an example so if i
type in the keyword best recipes for
dried figs you know here i could scroll
down here's my title tag stands out my
url is right underneath that and
underneath the url are is the meta
description and so here i can see some
modifiers 188 best autumn dried fake
recipes or 25 fantastic fig recipes or
10 best cooking dried fig recipes so
these are all modifiers they're going to
help somebody get the click get them to
click on your link and go to your
website so when you don't hit the 65
character limit if you go over that
google's going to cut off the title text
so we want to avoid that at all possible
so the whole idea is you know like 10
best cooking dried fake recipes by
yummly that's a good enticing title tag
okay takes into account a modifier
includes the targeted keyword and is
under the 65 character count some
additional tips for writing meta
description we always want to provide a
unique description for each web page of
the website so no duplicate meta tag
descriptions every page use needs to be
unique then we also want to be specific
about what we're offering so if you have
say you're selling headphones and you
have a particular set of headphones from
a different specific brand include that
in the meta description if you have that
particular product from that brand on
sale include that in the meta
description so you want to be as
specific as possible the whole idea
behind a meta description is to describe
the page but also to get the end user to
click on your link so here's an example
of using modifiers and describing a page
if we look at amazon again we can see
this example here and if we look at it
on google search results so if i type in
amazon bluetooth headsets ten dollars or
on sale here we can see a lot of amazon
listings in google search here you can
see the use of modifiers in the title
tag and also in the meta description
here we could see that you know this
particular headset bluetooth headset is
on sale 50 off so if something's on sale
feel free to include it be descriptive
about the page let people know where
they're going and use those modifiers
don't be afraid to use numbers in the
meta description even if it's the price
itself even if it's not on sale but it
is the price included it's not going to
hurt the more information you can
include in a meta description the better
chance you have of somebody clicking on
that link use numbers symbols you know
percentages off always help use catchy
words like discount or cashback you're
competing with other listings on the
page so if you have something on sale if
it's on clearance list that it's on
clearance here i can see they even
included the coupon code so feel free to
list as much specific information about
that page as possible the whole idea is
you're competing with your own web pages
but in other cases with competitors so
the meta description along with the
title tag and the url helps separate out
you from the rest of the listings on
search engine results and we don't want
to keyword stuff we want to keep it
within 160 something characters or 160
65 characters because google will break
off the meta description just like they
do with the title tag and so we want
clean natural written meta descriptions
that separate you from the competition
so that means including the keywords but
making sure those keywords are naturally
included in the meta description so if i
go back again to valleyfig.com and i
could see the meta description hey
welcome to the best resource online for
dried fake recipes savory sweet snacks
are healthy dried food recipes we've got
it all okay start cooking with figs and
so it's natural sounding it does include
the keyword it's not keyword stuffing
it's natural sounding that's hopefully
going to get that person to click on
this particular website let's turn our
attention to
the url so we want to make sure that the
url is basically taken into account best
practices so if we take a look at this
particular url here it doesn't
necessarily look as attractive as we
would like so
first of all i don't understand some of
it so that makes it unpleasant boring
and messy to say the least so you want
urls that you know basically are clean
and understandable so in other words we
want to make them seo friendly because
if they're seo friendly somebody
understands the url then they're likely
going to click on it so the old rule of
thumb is if you can read the url then
the search engines can read the url so
here are some tips for creating friendly
urls for seo make it readable you want
to include the target keyword in the url
so if it's dried figs the url should
include dried figs if it's dried fig
recipes make sure it's dried fig recipes
now avoid using too many subdirectories
in the urls so we want to keep it as
close as possible to the root directory
and match the urls to titles most of the
time so let's go back to our example
here here we can see this is
valleyfig.com recipes not necessarily
dried fig recipes but recipes
nonetheless it's in the root directory
okay so at all cost now this is in some
cases unavoidable given that you may be
dealing with an ecommerce website that's
calling you know content from a database
so if that is the case you're going to
have some dynamic parameters in the url
which is fine just make sure you avoid
having too many of those dynamic
parameters it's understandable about
parameters but the role of dumb
generally is no more than two different
parameters in the url so prefer to
create short urls that's really the way
to go the shorter the better is the rule
of thumb and you know if you're going to
break up the url then use hyphens
instead of underscores it's just cleaner
it's a more understandable search
engines tend to read it a little bit
easier if it's hyphen so here's what a
friendly url looks like for
search you got your domain you got a
subcategory broken up with a hyphen and
then the product so that's like just a
clean url for a particular ecommerce
site that has categories and
subcategories so again we got amazon.com
your category can be electronics your
subcategory could be earphones and your
product could be both earphones it's
that simple let's start with talking
about rich snippets this is tip number
four so we want to add rich snippets to
improve your website's visibility on
serps so tip number four is all about
rich snippets so let's start out by
asking ourselves what is a rich snippet
so rich snippet is simply just a term
used to describe structured data markup
that you as a website owner can add to
your html so hypertext markup language
or html is what is basically constructs
a page if we can add more information to
that that will in turn allow search
engines like google to better understand
the information that's on that web page
so the more google understands about
that web page the more they can put into
the search engine results page so rich
snippets is basically some structured
data markup that we can add to our
existing html and so if we want to add
rich snippets to search engines then how
would you prefer your products to be
displayed well if we have products then
we want to make sure that maybe we have
reviews or maybe we have so um other
information in there like
links to our site okay so there's a lot
of different types of rich snippets that
you know we can add that google can
recognize and add to the search engine
results so if you have a product then
there's a lot of things we can add like
specifically product reviews so we want
to be able to add more information to
the search engine results by working in
some rich snippets so basically the
whole idea is to set up the rich snippet
to drive targeted traffic okay so
because the more information in the serp
the more likelihood you're gonna get the
click and the more likelihood that click
is specific traffic so some of the
benefits of structuring the data for
rich snippets are as i mentioned
increasing click-through rates you know
also increasing conversion rates so when
you get the traffic from organic search
to your website if somebody's looking
for specific product and you have a
number of different good reviews showing
up let's just say 5 stars out of 5 stars
and you have 100 reviews showing 5 stars
then you know somebody's probably gonna
send take some trust in your brand and
your conversion rate probability is
going to go higher it also helps improve
your search engine visibility because
you're adding more information so in
other words the more google knows about
your page the likelihood it's going to
rank that page and it's more likely that
that information that's contained in
that rich snippet is going to get
featured in either the knowledge graph
which is that graph on the right side or
in a featured snippet which usually
shows up at the top of search engine
results so in other words the more
information you give google the more
they can use that information on their
search results page and there's no
disagreeing that the more information
that you have in your search engine
result the likelihood of getting more
traffic increases so for rich snippets
you could always start with
images so some of the common properties
that you can add to your product page if
you have a product pages the page itself
is an image you can always start there
you can always add a description you can
always add in ratings and you can always
add in reviews so these are some of the
most common attributes you can add as a
rich snippet so if you add that google
picks it up it's going to include that
information in the search results okay
some others are offers
prices
site links links to your site and
product availability so all that
information can be conveyed to google
google understands what you're trying to
pass along it's going to include that in
the search results so did you know that
according to ahrefs over
99.58 of featured pages that have
structured data already rank in the top
10 list of the google search results
page so in other words if you have rich
snippets in your page your chances of
ranking in the top 10 of a google result
is going to be very very very good okay
let's talk about tip number five
optimize your site structure for a great
user experience so let's go over some of
the tips that you would do for planning
a good website for seo and so tip number
one
is you want a url structure that follows
your site's navigation hierarchy so
obviously home page interior pages so
depending on what type of site you have
obviously the navigation needs to follow
that site's navigation that site
hierarchy and it all starts with a home
page you want to optimize your home page
to drive traffic to your product pages
so the home page is nothing more than a
doorway into your website and so the
site's navigation
should link to all those different
products so if you have an e-commerce
site with sub-categories or categories
sub-categories then you want to be able
to
make sure your navigation reflects that
you want to build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking as well
because when you're from the home page
obviously you want to be able to easily
navigate to other pages however when
you're on other pages you want to be
able to have a link pointing back to
relevant pages and not necessarily on
the home page so this serves two
purposes one for the end user obviously
you want the end user to navigate
through your website seamlessly right
second for the search engines their
following links they want to be able to
understand how your website flows and
links together so you don't want a
scenario where it's a one-way street
from the home page to interior pages you
want basically a home page to interior
interior to other relevant interior
pages and that could be a lateral or
that could be a situation where it's a
hierarchy for example home page category
subcategories sub sub category etc you
want to be able to make sure your site
is constructed in a manner in which the
search engine can read it so css or
cascading style sheets or hypertext
markup language html are your two most
common languages that's basically what
browsers load that's what search engines
like to index it just makes it easy for
them to understand what your page is all
about remember we talked about rich
snippets in the previous tip rich
snippets are nothing more than
supplemental html to describe what the
page is all about so that the search
engines can understand that page and
include reviews or include site links in
the search engine results so this is all
based on html so the more you provide
the search engines in a more structured
manner via html the more the search
engines are going to stay in the page
adding breadcrumbs to your product pages
is also a good practice if you have an
e-commerce site and you have a category
then a sub category then a sub sub
category then a product page well it's
probably not a bad idea to make sure you
have a breadcrumb so that was that way
somebody can easily go right back from
the product page to say the category
page or to the subcategory page directly
without having to hit the back button or
having to go through the navigation some
good examples i think amazon is a good
example of using breadcrumbs giving the
amount of products they have on their
site so go check out amazon if you want
a good example for breadcrumbs and then
canonical tags we want to make good use
of canonical tags and that's in order to
avoid duplicate content so a canonical
tag is nothing more than a link element
basically or an html element that
basically prevents duplicate content
issues so in other words if we have a
canonical tag as a meta tag basically
we're telling the search engines this is
the preferred or canonical version of a
web page okay so use this webpage so it
signals to the search engines which page
they should basically index and pay
attention to and avoid at all the other
pages that have similar content so
that's the idea behind a canonical tag
so that's a good best practice and then
optimize your site for desktop and
mobile i can't stress the mobile part
enough most users
begin their journey on mobile so if
you're not sure about what the search
engines like or don't like you can
always refer to
google search console for an example so
if you go to google search console they
have a report called mobile usability so
if you click on mobile usability you can
see what pages they like what pages they
don't like from a mobile perspective and
if you have errors they're going to tell
you what those errors are so if your
website has text that's too small to
read they're going to tell you that
these are the pages with this error and
so that allows you to go and address
those errors because from a google
perspective if you have if a page has a
mobile usability error then google will
not index that page so leverage google
search console to get a sense of what
type of errors your site has from a
mobile perspective you also want to
prefer to keep your checkout page simple
so again from an e-commerce perspective
you want to keep the checkout page as
simple as possible for obvious reasons
you want the end user to have a good
experience and you obviously want the
conversion so when i say keep a checkout
page simple really now with today's
technology you can create a one-page
checkout process you want to optimize
your sitemap so when we talk about
sitemaps we want to make sure that it's
a file and xml file that basically
includes all of our urls and we can then
turn around and give that site map to
the search engines so if you have a site
map in xml make sure you go to google
search console so if i go to google
search console and i click on site maps
i can just simply just tell google where
my site map is located and when they
recognize that sitemap they're going to
be able to
basically index the urls from that
sitemap so we can see here how many urls
they discover and how many they index so
make sure you create the sitemap in an
xml format submit the sitemap via google
search console and then you can go back
and see how many pages they've indexed
versus how many you've submitted and you
want to make sure that sitemap is
dynamic meaning anytime you publish a
url that url is added to the sitemap
fixing broken links so broken links is
not something you want but it's
something every website has it's
unavoidable you know people publish
pages all the time there's test pages
there's all sorts of reasons why
a site has broken links you want to be
able to address those and again going
back to google search console we can
basically see just by looking at some
reports what pages have broken links and
which ones don't so we could certainly
look at search console to get
information about basically what pages
are broken which ones aren't and then we
want to prefer predictive searches and
integrate product typographic errors on
your search bar so basically have a
search bar that's a best practice but
anticipate knowing what people are
typing in so that means maybe going into
google analytics and looking at the
search terms report so we can go into
analytics and look at search terms to
get a sense of what people are searching
for but you know when we talk about
integrating product typographic errors
we're talking also about fonts so we
want to make sure we're using the latest
fonts so that we don't run in any issues
on our website uh people not being able
to read based on a specific font that
you're using and then as a best practice
what i found and this is not necessarily
for everyone but using a live chat
widget sometimes helps in fact i would
even go beyond sometimes most the time
again depending on your business but i
see most businesses now have live chat
enabled and so basically
having live chat enables somebody who
has a question to immediately reach out
to somebody versus picking up the phone
versus sending an email it's just
instantaneous gratification in some ways
so inserting live chat on a website is
more common practice than not nowadays
given it it lends to a better user
experience tip number six improve your
page speed and reduce the bounce rate so
let's talk about page speed and how page
speed correlates with higher bounce rate
if it's a high page load and so
according to crazy page speed is an
important overlooked seo tactic because
for every second delay and page load can
result in
fewer page views 60 decrease in customer
satisfaction
decline in conversion rate so
you know you can see here regardless of
how specific the numbers are when you
have a page that loads slow you're going
to have lower user engagement and a poor
user experience so you have to pay
attention to page speed and so since
2010 google has been using page speed as
a factor for page ranking in the search
engine results so here are some tips to
focus on making sure your pages are
optimal in terms of speed so
enable browser caching okay you can
reduce plugins if you're using wordpress
as an example you know disable plugins
you're not using using a simple website
design going back to tip number five
stick with css and html don't do
anything fancy in terms of technology
because it's only going to complicate
matters optimize your code minify files
meaning hey if you're not using any code
just get rid of it because code has to
execute and that slows down page load
time so if your website has numerous css
and javascript files basically minify
and combine them and that's what we're
talking about there you know you don't
necessarily need a lot of
you know javascript on your page you can
leverage google tag manager or you know
other features that help minimize the
number of javascript files you have and
so you can also get some of these ideas
by going into google analytics so in
analytics under behavior under site
speed under page timings you can
basically see how quick each page loads
and then if you click on speed
suggestions right below page timings
what happens is google is going to
actually give you some suggested ways to
increase speed so
if we let this report load we'll be able
to see some speed suggestions per page
and so here you can see for example the
home page has an average page load time
of 4.89 seconds you can see right next
to that we have page speed suggestions
seven total so if we click on that
basically what it's going to do it's
going to launch another google product
called page speed insights and what
pagespeed insights is going to do is
it's going to analyze the page in
question whether that be the home page
or an interior page and what they're
actually going to do is not only analyze
the desktop version of your website but
also the mobile version and so now we
can see opportunities to improve our
page speed by making sure the images are
properly sized making sure server
response time is changed again defer
unused css not using css that's or
getting rid of css or minifying it so
there's lots of things you can do and
again this is desktop and mobile so on
the mobile side we could see some of the
other issues too that are causing high
page load and so analytics site speed
reports page speed insights are good
ways to get an idea really excellent
ways to really address page load time
issues so again these are just some of
the common issues with page load time
there could be other factors leaning on
those page speed insights reports will
definitely help reduce page load time so
basically according to google a website
should have you know time to first bite
lesser than 200 milliseconds
milliseconds is very very fast so in
case your website is slower than 200
milliseconds such as 500 milliseconds or
more you need to improve it so you don't
even have to measure it by milliseconds
you can even go by seconds which is what
most of us count time and again you can
see that simply going into the speed
suggestions report in google analytics
so ideally in terms of seconds you want
something that's about you know four
seconds or less three seconds or less
obviously as fast as possible so case
study walmart walmart reported the
following results so walmart experienced
a two percent increase in conversions
for every one second of page speed
improvement so think about that there's
definitely correlation between
page load time and speed so in
conversions and user engagement so the
quicker your page loads the higher the
engagement so with that improvement they
also experienced an increment in revenue
so meaning the pages load people had a
better user experience they were able to
check out easier and that led to more
revenue so they were able to measure
revenue against milliseconds and that's
something you can certainly do in
analytics you can correlate revenue with
bounce rate you can correlate revenue
with page speed tip number seven build
quality links and increase the domain
authority of your website so google's
top three search ranking factors
includes link building so you need to
have quality links from quality sites
pointing to your site and so that's a
factor in terms of ranking so that's
falls under off page seo you need to
build references and links on quality
sites and so building quality links to
your content can give your product or
category pages or even content or blog
post a boost in the serps so it's all
about quality over quantity so it's
always building quality links not
quantity so let's talk about what kind
of strategies you should implement so if
you implement these strategies then
you're going to likely see a lift in the
serps so earn backlinks from relevant
and authoritative web pages so what's
authoritative well authoritative is
subjective to some degree but it's also
measurement in others so you could use
moz as a good tool to measure page
authority or domain authority so if i go
into moz moz has a page and domain
authority score between 1 and 100 and so
you can actually see
what sites have good domain or page
authority just by entering in the domain
so relevant you obviously want to rank
to something that's relevant so if
you're in the food industry something
food related you want to promote your
content regularly on social media so
social media i always consider it all
low-hanging fruit when it comes to
backlinking you know there's so many
different social media platforms
available
facebook linkedin
twitter there's so many varieties from
images to pinterest and instagram to
video being youtube so there's lots of
ways to get your content out on social
media that will allow you to not only
promote your ban build a community but
also establish a reference back to that
page you can opt for guest blogging okay
so you can reach out to another blogger
and blog on that platform and it could
be reciprocal as well a blogger can
certainly you know blog on your platform
and have a link back and it works both
ways influencer marketing so influencer
marketing is working with somebody who
has a large amount of followers who can
influence those followers to you know
mention you in a hashtag link to your
particular product or brand or even
drive traffic to your site so you want
to take advantage of social media
platforms and start your own page as
well so
facebook's a good example it could be
having a youtube channel if you're into
video you can certainly set up a youtube
channel build a following around youtube
as well so always start your own page if
that's the platform of choice the last
thing you should do is set up a page on
social media and not keep it updated you
could certainly participate in forums
you can participate in other websites
like cora or reddit that's very you know
content based content driven user driven
i always recommend starting your own
blog blog is a good way to
not only generate content but it's a
good way to incorporate different types
of content so you could set up different
types of content and categories it's a
good way to incorporate different assets
like images and video it's a good way to
get users engaged by having comments or
having social share buttons it's a good
way to leverage that content onto other
social media platforms so there's lots
of benefits to blogging very few cons
the only con would be a time constraint
but it's better to have one blog post in
one month consistently than not blogging
at all so getting listed on high quality
link directories like yahoo directory is
still a way to add a link from a high
quality site and then make use of broken
link building so again on the last tip
we mentioned search console search
console certainly has reports available
for you that allow you to see what pages
on your site are no longer there and
allow you to see what pages they're
linking from okay you can also do
testimonials there's lots of ways to
generate quality links in a way you
almost have to get creative but creative
in a way that's going to generate
quality not quantity quality is the key
so even if it's one source whether that
be somebody else's blog so be it as long
as it's quality that's what counts so
let's talk about some of the key
takeaways from today's tips so remember
tip number one we want to opt for
smarter ways to do keyword research so
remember we want to look at volume we
want to look at competition we want to
create themes put them in a spreadsheet
so we want to be smarter and which in
the way in which we choose our keyword
tip number two remember publish high
quality content to get more traffic when
we say high quality content remember
break up the content use different
assets organize it structure it you know
make sure it's answering some of these
questions then we talked about in tip
number three analyzing your meta tags
and urls so we want to make sure that
title tag meta descriptions are creative
these modifiers like numbers or
promotions you know we don't want to go
over character counts we want to make
them unique and distinct so that
somebody clicks on them then we talked
about rich snippets and tip number four
remember rich snippets are just
additional html that communicates the
search engines so the search engines can
understand exactly what's on your page
so if you have recipes if you have
reviews if you have videos if you have
images if you have ratings all these
things can be added to the serps just by
communicating
with the search engines vs rich snippets
tip 5 optimize your site structure we
want to make sure that you know you have
good inbound links you want to make sure
you incorporate breadcrumbs you want to
make sure users can navigate your site
more easily and then in tip number six
if your pages load fast then it's going
to enhance the user experience it's
going to increase user engagement and
increase conversions and then tip number
seven we want to build quality link
quality to increase the domain authority
so remember we can use mods to measure
domain authority it's all about quality
whether that be via influencer marketing
guest blogging directories social media
setting up a social media page there's
always something you could be doing to
generate a quality link to your website
today we're going to talk about keyword
research so
what are we going to talk about when we
talk about keyword research we're going
to talk about why we would do keyword
research for seo we're going to talk
about the types of keywords that we need
to research we're going to talk about
some methodologies best practices on how
to do keyword research some alternate
suggestions we're going to talk about
keyword clustering and then we're going
to talk about some tools that you can
use to do your keyword research so let's
start with the why we would do keyword
research so jesse is planning to publish
a blog of pizza recipes so
she was doing pizza recipes step by step
piece of recipes with sausage homemade
pizza toppings pizza dough recipes thin
crust pizzas she's doing a lot of
different topics on pizza recipes well
what jessie needs to do is understand
what's going to drive traffic to these
blog posts if she's writing about you
know different topics around pizza
recipes so
she's unsure how
these blogs are going to drive traffic
so she really needs to
understand that hey you need to choose
the right keywords to drive traffic so
the question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keywords to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take
care and choosing the key words to align
with your content so that's really the
idea why we would do keyword research
because some of the issues with keywords
that are poorly chosen are they could
have slow search volume for example you
may choose a keyboard that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it can be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyboard that
isn't aligned with your content or you
can choose keywords but use them
incorrectly with your content so these
are some of the issues that you can
encounter if you just go about choosing
keywords randomly without due diligence
without the proper research so low
search volume will lead to less traffic
high competition you may not even rank
at all okay if somebody finds you for a
keyword that's not relevant to the topic
they're just going to leave the page and
if you're not using the right keywords
and or if you are using the right
keywords and not using them correctly in
the content then your pages may not even
be found in organic search so you really
have to take care in choosing the
keywords to me that's the most important
step with seo is keyword research so
we're going to talk about the types of
keyword research then so we have short
tail keywords and we have long tail
keywords so if you write a blog post
about pizza recipes well what are you
going to choose a short tail or long
tail so let's talk about short tail
keywords first so short tail keywords
are keywords that are usually three
keywords and a phrase or shorter in some
cases it may be two keywords in a phrase
or shorter so short term keywords
usually have high search volume which
means likely means higher competition
but what it also means it could be lower
conversions because short-tail keywords
like for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short-tail keyword but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite italian restaurant so
short-term keywords may not be as
relevant so if we compare it with
long-tail keywords chances are you're
going to have lower competition that's
one of the benefits but you're also
going to have lower search volume but
with longer tail keywords the keyword is
probably going to be more relevant with
the content you're writing about so
therefore the conversion rate's likely
going to be higher so that's really the
difference between short term keywords
and long tail keywords if you want to
look at simplistically short tail
keywords are broad in nature it's going
to capture a lot of eyeballs but those
eyeballs may look at your content is not
relevant versus long tail keywords that
may be very relevant but not as many
eyeballs on them so short tail keywords
the characteristics they're not as
specific usually they're less than three
words they have high search volume and
high competition so if you just choose
pizza recipes it could take you a while
to rank for that keyword but when you
rank you're gonna get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the
keyword is broad in nature so pizza
recipes is a short tail keyword that may
not be exactly what you're writing about
in your blog post so it may draw a lot
of traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long-term word is
probably going to be greater because not
many other websites are trying to rank
for that same keyword and so the benefit
of that is if you have let's just say
homemade pizza recipes with mushrooms
that's a long tinky word but if
somebody's looking for that type of
pizza recipe then you know you're going
to track the right traffic and chances
are that traffic is going to engage or
convert based on the type of conversion
you have in place so example would be
homemade pizza dough recipes that'd be
another example more than three key
words in the phrase very specific we're
talking about homemade pizza dough
recipes so we're not talking about just
pizza recipes so it's a little bit more
specific in nature longer tail so these
keywords are used for targeted pages
including blog posts if you're writing a
blog post specifically about pizza
recipes with homemade dough then this is
the keyword you likely would want to use
versus just pizza recipes so let's look
at an example between a short tail
keyword and a long tail keyword and to
accentuate the differences we're going
to use google's keyword planner tool so
google's keyword planner tool is located
in google ads the google ads platform
and when you're in the google ads
platform you can simply click on tools
and then keyword planner and so what
keyword planner allows us to do is get a
sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what google's
keyword planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a
keyword over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
going to click get results and what
google's gonna do is it's going to show
us the volume of those keywords so for
pizza recipe we could see the average
monthly search volume is 33 100 for
pizza recipe so note that pizza recipe
and pizza recipes are closely related
keywords and so what google does is they
consider that a close variance so
meaning if somebody types in pizza
recipe then they're also in google's
eyes looking for pizza recipes so it's a
close variance and so for the keyword
pizza recipe which is short tail we
could see on average over the past 12
months this keyword received 33 100
queries and so if we hover over the
graph we could see basically the volume
the average volume per month so here i
could see for this particular keyword
here the volume per month is 33 1000 and
then i can see
the actual volume over the past 12
months and then for the long tail
keyword i can see homemade pizza dough
recipe again close variance homemade
pizza dough recipes i can see over the
past 12 months what the search volume is
for this on average it's 2400 but i
could see here in december the volume
went up to 3600. but for example in may
it was 1900. so it's gonna fluctuate a
bit over the past few months but on
average it's about 2400 so shorter tail
a lot more volume longer tail not as
much volume but nonetheless there is
volume here and so these are the
differences between a short tail and a
longer tail and so what google's keyword
planner also does is allow us to get a
sense of what the competition is and so
here i can see the competition is low
for both of these keywords fair enough
so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2 400 search queries for that keyword
now whether you get all 2 400 clicks for
that keyword remains to be seen chances
are you're not going to get all 2 400
you're going to get a lion's share of
those clicks but you're going to at
least get some volume on it so even the
longer take keywords have a lot of
promise because there is some search
volume here for this keyword how to do a
proper keyword research so we looked at
google's keyword planner tool in google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose keywords based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search volume search volume is
a good indicator of the potential
traffic we can obtain so again for the
keyword homemade pizza dough recipe we
know that it averages 2 400 a month in
search volume again we may not get all
2400 but are we gonna get a line share
that we also need to look at competition
and so google's keyword planner gives us
a high medium or low in terms of the
competition but if you're somebody who
wants to get a better sense of what the
competition is and you should because
competition is a key component in
choosing keywords and so what i want to
do is get a sense of how many people are
actually optimizing for that keyword so
google's keyword planner tool is going
to give me a low medium high really what
i want to do is get a better sense of
that numerically so what i can do is go
into google search and i could type in
pizza recipes and i could see there's
about 1 billion results that's a lot of
results however that means that every
potential web page out there on the
internet that mentions pizza recipes is
going to be included in this number here
and so i want to get a better sense of
who's optimizing for pizza recipes so
i'm going to put in the all entitle
syntax and so what that is going to ask
google to do is tell me all the websites
that have pizza recipes the keyword
pizza recipes in the title tag so if i
do all in title call in space then pizza
recipes my result drops down to 336 000.
so what that tells me is that there are
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if i want
to focus in on my other keyword if i
choose uh my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if i type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variance and i just click
enter or type the keyword in and hit my
enter key i'm going to get 35 million
results but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition i
have no because every listing that
matches homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so i'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then i'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and i get
160 different results so here i can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites and web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now i have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about seo
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for seo and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes
and so that's our theme so we chose the
keyword pizza recipes so the close
variance here is pizza recipe what was
the volume well we know the volume was
33 100 for pizza recipe so what are we
going to do we're going to put that
number in in our volume column what was
the competition well if we go back and
type in pizza recipes it was 683
thousand so i'm gonna type in
683 000. what was our next keyword well
it was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes
so if i go back for this particular
keyword is 2 400. so i'm gonna put 2 400
in under my volume column and then what
was my competition well my competition
was i typed that keyword back in
2160. so i'm going to put
2160. so now i have an idea of what kind
of volume and what kind of competition i
have now you want to do this for a
number of different keywords and when
you do it for number keywords what you
do want to do is obviously choose a
relevant keyword that has high volume
and low competition so another way of
saying it is the volume or ratio of
volume to competition and so basically
what we could do is take volume divided
by competition if i make that a
percentage i can see it's 0.35 percent
is the ratio between volume and
competition if i do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
i can see that 111
so this just kind of proves the point
that yeah i'm still going to get some
volume but i have a better chance of
ranking for this longer teal keyword
homemade pizza dough recipes so you want
to be able to do that for a number of
keywords and examine the volume the
competition and the ratio between volume
and competition for your themed keywords
in this case pizza recipes so relevancy
you want to choose keywords that are
very relevant to the content that you're
writing and then again commercial intent
what keywords are going to drive more
conversions and revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say you know download pizza
dough recipes so somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
google's keyword planner tool in the
google ads platform we want to target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the google's keyword planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over and we can
get a sense of any particular trend
going on or seasonality so for example
if i saw large growth in the winter
months and not much volume growth in the
summer months then that might indicate
to me that this keyword is more popular
during the winter time so pay attention
to the graphs that you know the keyword
planner tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny halloween costumes well we know
that for halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
september all the way through october
and then it's going to drop after
october 31st which is halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a keyword that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
google's keyword planner tool to find
the volume we use the all in title
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a keyword
that is going to be relevant to your
content don't choose a keyword that's
not relevant if you choose a keyword
that's not relevant it's not going to
bode well for user engagement so the
difficulty of a keyword ranges from 0 to
100 in google's keyword tool so it's
going to be easy it's going to be medium
it's going to be hard but my
recommendation is also to get the
numerical factor and that's the all in
title syntax and again relevancy is what
drives the traffic to your website and
keep the traffic there on your website
and also not only will keep the traffic
on your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about relevancy you always want
to choose keywords that are relevant to
your content even if it's sacrificing
volume relevancy again trumps volume and
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's going to find
your content because somebody out there
might be looking for it and if they do
you're gonna get found and then the
engagement's gonna be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then focus on those keywords that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial intent so these keywords are
more specific and result in conversion
rate for example buying is a good
commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe its download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples like commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you don't be afraid to
use some of these keywords as part of
your longer tail keyword phrase again
the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for seo so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant to
content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword you want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if our primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to cool google's keyword
planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if i go in to
google's keyword planner and type those
keywords in i'm going to choose get
results and now here i could see healthy
diet plan key word i'm focusing on is my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900
and then some of my secondary keywords
healthy diet foods diet plan weight loss
low carb diet you know google will give
me a number of different keywords to
work with so i'm going to look at the
search volume of those as well and so
ideally what i want to do is be able to
then look at the volume and then look at
the competition
so healthy diet plan i go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan
9900 what's my competition so my
competition is seventy four thousand
seven hundred and that's going to give
me a ratio of volume to competition of
13 so that's what my content is about
that's a considered a short tail keyword
because it has a lot of competition and
so my ratio is 13
and what i want to do is i want to be
able to put these other secondary
keywords in here as well maybe even go a
little longer tail because i want to be
able to
find two key at least two keywords i
want to be able to find my primary
keyword that's relevant to my content
and then i want to be able to find my
secondary keyword which is again related
to the primary keyword which is also
related to the content and so i want to
be able to choose two keywords basically
and i want to choose two keywords that
are relevant that have good ratio
between volume and competition so that's
the whole idea again on how to do
keyword research you want to be able to
find your keywords use the tools
available to you and get a sense of what
the volume is what the competition is
look at the ratio between the volume and
competition and then based on the
content choose that primary keyword and
then again based on the keyword you
chose choose some secondary keywords as
well because you want to be found for
not just one keyword but multiple
keywords okay let's look at some
alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account lsi
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like quora or reddit we can use
google suggestions in the keyword search
bar
we can use popular platforms like
wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like reddit so
there are lots of suggestions that we
can obtain from various sources so let's
start with lsi keywords and lsi stands
for latent semantic insect indexing and
so basically what it is it's just
keywords that are linked to your primary
keyword and so when you're choosing
keywords you always want to choose that
primary keyword and then secondary
keywords that are similar to the primary
keyword and usually those are lsi or
latent semantic indexing type keywords
so they're used to drive relevant
traffic to your page so if you're
focusing on one keyword we want to have
other keywords that are similar to
increase our visibility on the search
engine result pages so we could find
latent semantic indexing right in search
so if we use the term healthy diet if we
go to google search for example if i
type in healthy diet and google search
all i need to do is scroll to the bottom
of the page and i can see searches
related to healthy diet so healthy diet
menu healthy diet essay what does a
healthy diet look like notice at the top
google's also giving me some other
suggestions here so they're saying
low-fat diet veganism gluten-free diet
so there's lots of different suggestions
right in google search bar so all of
these are lsi related keywords if you're
optimizing a page for a healthy diet
then you could choose low-fat diet as a
secondary keyword you can use
gluten-free diet as a secondary keyword
it really depends on what the content is
but you always want to support your
content with as much lsi keywords as
possible so you can be found for as many
different keywords as possible in google
search so it's important because if you
have a blog that you know talks about
python so how do the search engines know
if the website python is about the
programming language or the sync so
google for example uses lsi keywords to
understand what the page is specifically
focusing on so if you're just focusing
on python and your content you want to
support that with lsi keywords and so
that will allow your web page to better
communicate with google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
be found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if i
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if i'm talking about
recipes that's a keyword i may want to
use and if i use that then google has an
opportunity to see what my contents
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of the
questions are being asked what males are
good for weight loss what is a good
healthy diet plan all of these can be
keyword phrases that you can use so the
answers are right here in google so core
is a great platform because core is a
platform that people go and ask
questions and a community responds with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about core is it's a good i it's a good
place for you to go to get some ideas
about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find keywords with high search volume
right in core so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant
keywords to healthy dieting so if you
just type in that particular keyword in
quora you're going to probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if i
just type in healthy dieting what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna get some responses
to the the topic healthy dieting so
what's the best diet for healthy living
what are the top five tips for a healthy
diet habit so all of these could be
keyword phrases that you could take away
with for your own content and so the
benefit here is you're getting kind of
an idea of what's trending what people
are talking about and if you use tips
for a healthy diet habit for example and
you optimize for that well again that
could turn around and bode well for you
because you could be featured in google
as a featured snippet at the top here
you can also turn around and use lsi
related keywords for healthy diet habits
and you can simply just look for those
lsi keywords right in google remember at
the bottom or at the top if i scroll
down i could see some related lsi
keywords at the bottom so right in
google as well you can see in the google
search bar that google provides some lsi
related keywords to your query so if i
go back here and type in healthy diet
recipes i can see here google's
suggesting some other related keywords
healthy diet menu healthy diet for men
healthy diet foods healthy diet for
women so these are all lsi related
keywords that you can use to support
your primary keyword and the content
you're writing about so we've talked
about lsi keywords where to find them so
they're found right here they can be
found at the top of google and they can
be found at the bottom you can also then
go to core as well and get some ideas
for the types of questions that are
being asked so if you ask a question and
use that as your keyword phrase then
again you have an opportunity of showing
up for a featured snippet in google just
by doing some additional research within
google itself or on quora so according
to google the autocomplete predictions
are automatically generated by google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for a term so google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if i go back to
google again if i start to type in
recipes i could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in google itself i could see for healthy
diet recipes billions of pages related
to healthy diet recipes i can also get
the search volume by going into google's
keyword planner so if i type in healthy
diet i'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword
and in addition i can see the
seasonality of that particular keyword
and in addition to that google is going
to provide some other related keywords
to my search query so if i'm looking for
healthy diet google's gonna suggest hey
maybe you should choose healthy food or
healthy eating or how to lose weight so
those are lsi related keywords that
google provides in the keyword plan
which is built into the google ads
platform another option for you is
wikipedia so wikipedia is a vast
platform of content so we could turn
wikipedia into our own asset and use it
to our own advantage by finding relevant
keywords in an easy fashion so with
wikipedia we can identify a list of
keywords in the meta description itself
we could choose keywords from the first
paragraph of wikipedia it has many
relevant keywords or we could take a
look at keywords from the wikipedia
content section so we can also see
additional pages like the see also
section that gives relevant keywords
that you're looking for we can also look
at the references section as they
contain relevant keywords so go to
wikipedia as an example and i type in
healthy diet
into wikipedia here i can get just in
the first paragraph alone i can see
some additional keywords that i might
choose to use like micronutrients i
never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe i can use
that as a keyword an lsi related keyword
to my content so if i scroll down i get
to see also section so it might give me
some information food information
consumers for example dietary guidelines
i can look at categories like dietetics
and diets i can also look at the
references section so i can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
i can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here on the platform they're
just all over the page so wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
wikipedia you can look no further than
the first paragraph you go no further
than the see also section the references
section category section there's lots of
information right on the page itself to
help you get ideas for keywords so if
you google your keyword with wikipedia
term in the search query and get
relevant keywords from the title tags on
the serp so you can also do that as well
so if i type in healthy diet wikipedia
in search i can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to
my keyword healthy diet so again another
bit of information for you to choose or
look to choose some additional keywords
for so reddit it's a popular community
where
people post content discuss a variety of
topics so that's what reddit is so with
the help of subreddits an individual can
find relevant keywords with with high
search volume so in reddit there's an
easy way to find out keywords they have
a keyword tool called keyword it so
keywording is the average monthly
searches for a particular keyword so if
we type a word in key reddit and choose
keywords from the auto-generated list
this tool will extract the keywords and
give us those relevant terms with search
volumes so if we go to the keyword it
and show an example of that for example
healthy food if i get keywords i can see
what keywords are relevant and the
search volume of that keyword so if i
just type in healthy food keyword tool
is going to tell me some relevant
keywords and what the volume is so if
you don't have the keyword planner tool
and google ads available to you this is
a good alternative solution to finding
keywords so it's free you just need to
go to keyword dot com type in your
keyword click get keywords and what it's
going to do is give you some relevant
keywords related to your primary keyword
with the search volume let's talk about
keyword clustering now so the whole idea
about keyword clustering is to
really take advantage of the keywords
that we're optimizing for to gain higher
ranking so if we can cluster keywords
together in a theme and
that theme of keywords is relevant to a
specific page of a website then we have
a better opportunity to rank so in other
words why do we have to target just one
keyword when we can target many so keep
in mind you know lsi keywords we want to
group a bunch of keywords together that
are similar for content so for example
after some keyword research you can
thematically group keywords into a core
topic so for example we can cluster
these group of keywords together like
for example what is seo how does seo
work intro to seo what are the basics of
seo all of those are related to the core
theme what is seo another cluster of
keywords for example could be seo
techniques seo best practices tips and
tricks website optimization on-page seo
techniques etc so those are clusters of
keywords okay that we can group together
in themes and if we group keywords
together in themes we can apply that to
a particular content on our website so
the whole idea behind clustering
keywords it's going to provide more
diversity more of an opportunity for us
to be found so that's the whole idea
behind clustering so some additional
steps remember stay up to date on
industry news to brainstorm your ideas
first and identify a list of keywords
i.e a theme of keywords that you can
cluster together and then you could
determine the keywords that your
competitors are already ranking for so
for example if we want to rank for the
keyword seo best practices for example
we can use a tool called keyword moz if
i go to keyword the keyword explorer
tool in moz and just type in seo best
practices
what it's going to do is it's going to
give me some volume related to that
particular keyword but more importantly
what it's also going to do is it's going
to show me what pages are already ranked
for that particular keyword so therefore
i can get a sense of who is already
ranking for that keyword so here i can
see
mozmozmedium.com alexa.com so i can get
a sense of what web pages are ranked for
a particular keyword or group of
keywords i want to rank for myself so if
we look at tools for keyword research
look no further than moz that's the mods
of the tool i would just use but you
could also use google's keyword planner
which we used in the example so for
example if i go back to the google ads
keyword planner if you're in google ads
you click on tools you click on cleave
planner and what keyword planner does is
it provides you for a particular keyword
the average monthly search volume over
the past 12 months it provides you
information on seasonality so if i hover
my mouse over a graph i'm going to be
able to see the volume per month over
the last 12 months what the keyword
planner also does is it provides me some
additional ideas for my particular
keyword and in addition to that it's
going to provide me some sense of how
competitive that keyword is by telling
me whether it's low medium or high in
terms of competition so there's sem rush
there's also other additional keywords
tools out there like word stream or href
or the reddit tool keyword it and then
moz is is another tool i particularly
use so if i go to moz again here i can
just type in a keyword that i'm
interested in it's going to give me the
search volume of that keyword it's going
to give me the level of difficulty so 50
out of 100 so it's halfway between
difficulty and easy and then it's going
to give me some additional metrics like
for example what my expected organic
click-through rate would be if i were to
rank for this keyword but more
importantly what i like about this is we
could see exactly what other sites are
linked to this particular keyword we're
interested in so here i can look at the
top 10 list so this is moz's key word
explore tool so that's what this tool is
and it's part of moz.com so there's a
lot of tools at your disposal i
particularly use moz i particularly use
google's keyword planner and those are
the tools i use but there are lots of
tools out there let's go with the
scenario that you have a friend named
sam and he has a website where he sells
shoes but sam doesn't understand
why his website's not ranking number one
on google and so typically
ranked number one on google there are
some factors involved and
those are factors that are going to help
sam get his website ranked number one on
google so he can sell his shoes get
traffic and convert that traffic to
conversions so there are factors
involved and so what are those factors
well it always starts with keyword
research so in order to rank for a
website where you sell shoes or
you sell products other products like
clothing or food or
you're an automobile website you know
you're a mechanic it doesn't matter
whether you're selling to customers or
selling to other businesses you have to
start with the keyword research and so
we're going to go into really explicit
detail on how to conduct a proper
keyword research and then the second
factor involved is high quality content
so in order to rank high on google
search you need to have high quality
content so we're going to go over
what's involved with creating high
quality content then we're going to
take that content we're going to
optimize it using on-page elements and
website level factors so we're going to
take into account what's involved with
your website and what's involved with
specific pages on your website in order
to rank number one on google then we're
going to get into the off-site
engagement so when it comes to ranking
on google you need to optimize your
website and you need to do
some elements off your website you need
to be engaging off your website meaning
on other websites
and so we're going to talk about what's
involved with offsite engagement so seo
being a major channel for most companies
and websites where the opportunity to
drive a lot of traffic is there but you
have to earn that reward the reward is a
lot of traffic but you have to earn the
reward there's a lot of work involved
and so ideally what we want to do is
follow what we call the 80 20 rule when
it comes to search engine optimization
and ranking on google and what do we
mean by the 80 20 rule well 80 20 means
we're investing 20 percent of our effort
and 80 percent of the results are
obtained so we want to invest 20 and get
back 80. that's basically
about 80 20. so for example if 20 of our
targeted keywords bring in 80 of the
traffic then that's following the 80 20
rule or 20 of our landing pages drive 80
percent of the overall traffic that's
following the 80 20 rule or 20 percent
of our backlinks past 80 percent of our
link juice that's the 80 20 rule meaning
these targeted keywords these targeted
landing pages these trying to target
backlinks using off-site engagement we
want to put in 20 percent of our effort
on those keywords landing pages and
backlinks in return for 80 percent of
the results so without further ado let's
get started with the keyword research
let's talk about that keyword research
for a website with shoes and it doesn't
really matter
what particular product you have if you
need to rank number one on google it all
starts with the keywords as i mentioned
before and so
in this example if you have a website
where you sell shoes for kids you're
going to want to be found for certain
keywords so the obvious key word here
would be shoes for kids well every
keyword that you target has search
volume associated with it so that means
when we talk about search volume we're
talking about how many people on average
type in that keyword or related keyword
on google.com or google search and
there's always an average number of
searches associated with every keyword
and we call that search volume how much
search volume so obviously if we're
going to target a keyword we want to
have as much volume as possible however
there's always going to be
competition for those keywords meaning
there's always going to be other
websites who want to rank number one on
google for the same keywords and we call
that competition or difficulty so for
every keyword you're going to have
volume and you're going to have
competition or difficulty and the
difficulty ranges as well depending on
the tool you use and we'll get into that
in a minute but search volume is how
much on average people are typing in
that keyword or close variance of that
keyword and the difficulty is measured
in terms of how many other websites are
trying to rank for the same keyword and
so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business so if
we're selling shoes for kids and shoes
for kids is highly relevant has high
volume and low competition then that's a
keyword we want to target so we always
want to focus in on those three areas so
there's always a trade-off with keywords
so shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
google for that keyword and so the whole
idea beyond keyword research is
analyzing and choosing the best keywords
so we want to identify a list of
keywords that are always relevant we
want to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for and we want
to use third-party tools to choose
keywords to identify which keywords have
low competition and what keywords have
high search volume so one thing to take
into consideration when you're doing
keyword research is that the longer the
keyword phrase or in other words long
tail keywords or keywords with three
keywords in the phrase or more you're
gonna always have less competition but
there's always a trade-off with long
tail keywords meaning the longer the
keyword phrase there's going to be less
volume but the trade-off is less
competition and so what we want to do is
we want to brainstorm some ideas and
find those relevant keywords so let's
look at an example here so if we go to
google ads so google ads has a tool
called keyword planner and let's just
say i have a
a website where i'm selling dried figs
and if i'm selling dried figs i want
people to buy these dried figs however
in order to attract them i want to be
able to show them that hey we have a
bunch of recipes and if i show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs maybe you'll buy these dried figs
to use in these recipes and so we're
going to look for
keywords related to bread recipes
because if we can optimize for our
recipes page for bread then that will
attract an audience who wants to make
bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example i'm
going to give here and so if i look at
the keyword planner in google ads if i
just type in bread recipes what google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so i
can see the average monthly search
volume here is 60 500. and so in order
to do keyword research what i would
recommend is keep a spreadsheet and so
the idea behind the spreadsheet is to
document the volume and the competition
you're getting for certain keywords so
if i go into a spreadsheet here my theme
of keywords is bread recipes my keyword
is bread recipes and my volume therefore
is going to be 60 500. however if i go
back into google's keyword planner
google is telling me the competition is
low so that's great i want high volume i
want low competition but how low is low
so we want to be careful so if we're
going to put in numbers into a
spreadsheet we want to figure out what
that competition really is for the
keyword bread recipes so if i go to
google and just type in bread recipes
i'm going to be able to see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now is 771 billion are
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want to do is put in a syntax and we
want to put in the syntax all in title
and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
identify the true competitive number or
the true number of websites who are
trying to rank for bread recipes and if
we put in the syntax all entitled colon
and then our keyword bread recipes we'll
be able to see that there are
998 000 results that's a lot lower than
771 billion so that means that 998
sites or listings have the keyword bread
recipes in the title tag and the title
tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if i look down and
scroll down here i can see bread recipes
on every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that there are 998 000
results with bread recipes in the title
tag then this tells us that those are
the websites who are trying to rank
number one on google for that keyword
and therefore those are the websites we
need to jump over in order for our
website to rank number one on google and
so therefore i'm going to put in 998 000
in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now i could see for the
keyword bread recipes i have 60 500 and
if my competition is 998 000 then my kei
or keyboard effectiveness index or in
other words the ratio of volume to
competition is six percent so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is six percent so remember we want more
volume than we want competition so
anytime you do a keyword research you're
going to find a number of different
relevant keywords so if i go back into
google's keyword planner if i typed in
bread recipes you could see that google
is going to give me a number of
different keywords related to bread
recipes let's just say i have another
keyword that i want to think about
optimizing for being ranked on google
for and that's banana bread recipe very
similar keyword as bread recipes except
it's a little longer tail now if i type
in banana bread recipe in google's
keyword planner now i can see the
average monthly search volume has
actually gone up it's 368
000. i can also see the competition is
low so those are good signs so now i can
see 368 000 i'm gonna go ahead and put
that in my spreadsheet now i'm gonna go
into google i'm gonna put in my syntax
all in title i'm going to put in banana
bread recipe i'm going to hit enter and
now i can see i have 233 000 results
with the keyword banana bread recipe in
the title tag so if i look at the title
tags i can see banana bread recipe
banana bread recipe banana bread recipe
on all the listings in the google search
results so that tells me i have 233 000
results that i have to jump over
in order to rank number one on google so
i'm going to put 233 000 in my
spreadsheet now i can see my kei or my
volume to competition ratio is
and so to me that's a lot better number
to work with or in other words that's a
lot better keyword because it's just as
relevant and it has a higher ratio of
volume to competition so therefore
banana bread recipe is going to be a
better keyword to optimize for in order
to rank number one on google so that's
the whole idea behind keyword research
you want to brainstorm ideas there are
plenty of tools out there so the tool i
recommend is google ads keyword planner
google is going to give you
how much search volume they're going to
tell you the competition but then you're
going to go into google search you're
going to use the syntax on title to get
a more accurate read on the actual
competitive number and so to find out
how keywords that your competitors are
ranking for you can use those keyword
tools that i mentioned another tool that
i use is miles so moz if you go to
moz.com
they have a tool called keyword explorer
so if we just type in the keyword for
example bread recipes it's going to be
able to tell us how much volume and the
difficulty so you can use other tools at
your disposal figure out the volume and
the difficulty there are plenty of tools
out there but the one thing i would just
make sure is you use everything at your
disposal so you can use social media to
find the most shared article for a
particular topic or keyword like bread
recipes you could check other platforms
that have a lot of shared content like
reading and quora where you can ask
people about certain topics using
keywords to figure out how much
competition or volume there might be you
can stay up to date on industry news to
get an idea of what types of keywords
are trending but when it comes to
keywords and keyword research remember
for every web page we want to be able to
pick two keywords we want a primary and
secondary keyword so when we do keyword
research and we enter all our keywords
into our spreadsheet we want to be able
to have a number of different keywords
in this case we're focusing on the theme
bread recipes we want to have different
keywords because we want to be able to
choose a primary keyword and a secondary
keyword because we want to be able to
focus on multiple keywords for each page
because we don't want to put necessarily
all our eggs in one basket maybe we
won't want to put all our emphasis just
on one keyword to rank for we want
multiple keywords to try and rank for so
the primary key work and to find the
nature of our business the secondary
keyword could be just highly relevant to
our keyword at the end of the day we
want to choose multiple keywords to try
and rank on google for that page so for
example we have a blog and we're using
ice cream recipes and we're blogging
about ice cream recipes we can have a
primary keyword that is about ice cream
recipes or homemade ice cream recipes
we're going to always want to find out
what the volume and the competition is
our secondary keyword could be built
around other similar keywords like
low-fat ice cream recipes or fat-free
ice cream recipes or low-fat homemade
ice cream recipes those are
complementary keywords just like our
bread recipes and banana bread recipe so
one thing we want to do when we do
keyword research is we want to be able
to target one keyword per content when
you can target many we want to be able
to target multiple keywords not
necessarily target one keyword and so we
want to be able to cluster keywords so
we don't want to target just one we want
to target multiple keywords per page and
when we talk about clustering if we go
back to
our keyword research what we're doing is
we're clustering a bunch of keywords
under the theme bread recipes and so by
looking at the volume looking at the
competition looking at the kei we can
choose different keywords for our page
and that's what we mean by clustering we
want to cluster keywords into a content
theme so why target only one keyword per
content when we can target many because
we don't want to put all our eggs in one
basket we don't want to target just one
keyword we want to target many and so
that means clustering your keywords into
a theme and choosing multiple keywords
for that particular page and when we do
that we have a better opportunity to
rank high on google search and the whole
idea behind ranking high on google
search is we can get the volume so if we
know we're ranked number one on google
search for bread recipes or banana bread
recipe we know we stand a chance of
getting a majority of the volume
associated with that keyword and if we
can get the volume and get the traffic
then we can get the conversions so let's
move on to high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on
you know page four of google and it's
that blog with ice cream recipes and if
it's just content for the sake of
content is not really informative then
it's not necessarily going to get good
engagement in the eyes of google you
know they want to rank content that's
very informative it's very fresh it's
exciting to read it's interesting it's
going to have good engagement so if it's
a recipe or an article about any topic
if it's the content is just not
informative then you're not going to get
good engagement and when you don't get
good engagement if people don't stay on
the site to engage in the content and
they just leave the website after
landing on the page causing a bounce
then the content is just going to
continue to fall down the rankings and
we want to prevent that we want to move
up the rankings we want to be number one
on google we don't necessarily want to
fall in the rankings for our content so
content is a key driver
in being able to rank number one on
google so if the content is on page 9
what can we do well we want to be able
to you know take that content and do
something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe
especially in the summertime and you're
engaging with your community on that
platform then the likelihood of that
community on that platform is going to
increase engagement increased engagement
will send social signals to the search
engine that says hey this content is
good quality likewise for any other
platform most social media platforms
have engagement metrics and those
engagement metrics pass signals is it
good is it not good do we like this
content are we giving it a thumbs up are
we going to want to follow it are we
going to want to share it and so
if you share content that you feel is
engaging on social platforms then it's
going to be engaging and it's likely
going to cause an increase in engagement
for example a decrease in bounces and
once you share that quality content then
the likelihood of it moving up the
rankings even as far as number one on
google is going to be greater so you
always want to start out writing good
quality content so let's talk about good
quality content because google does take
content seriously they do take into
account what other people think of that
content so high quality content is an
important factor so how to create good
content that's always the question so
let's talk about some best practices
here remember in the last segment we
talked about keyword research so we want
to perform good keyword research why
because we want to choose keywords
remember we're choosing multiple
keywords per page one keyword could be
related to our brand one key word could
be related to the content but another
keyword could be related to a user's
intent like recipes if you recall the
example we use with bread recipes maybe
somebody's looking to type in a keyword
that says how do i make you know a bread
or how do i make a specific type of
bread or how do i make banana bread or
what's the best recipe for banana bread
they're question related and we want to
be able to answer those questions so
that's where choosing those right
keywords that's going to respond to a
user's intent so starts with choosing
the right keywords so remember we talked
about a number of different tools when
we talked about keyword research so
there's a research tool that you can use
called
phrase.io and that will help you do
quick research on you know keywords and
trends and whatnot so if you know about
a research tool that you use for keyword
research then drop us a comment below
i'd be interested in getting your
comments about keyword research and what
research tools are out there so if you
know something better than phrase.io
drop a comment below and we'd be
interested in getting your perspective
so keyword research is key but creating
content that fulfills users requirements
so answering those questions if it's a
recipe we want to answer that question
if it's directions we want to answer
that question if they don't know how to
do something we want to answer that
question that's the whole idea behind
content content is not just to fill a
page it's to really fulfill users
requirements that's when you get good
engagement so if somebody's typing in
something on google and they're looking
for an answer your content should answer
that question but we also want to make
the content readable so in other words
you know write for your audience don't
impress anybody with
very high vocabulary type words that
somebody doesn't necessarily know the
meaning of don't use jargon
don't use a street language for example
use everyday common language that's just
easily digestible when your audience is
reading and then we want to keep that
content organized and so when we mean
organize we want to use headers and
subheaders you know break your content
into paragraphs keep the flow organized
if we can keep the flow organized then
it's going to be easier for somebody to
read and then it's okay to add resources
especially resources from credible sites
so if you can incorporate those
resources in there then it's just going
to add the credibility to your content
let the audience know that hey i've done
my research on this topic and this is
what this person has to say about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content so these are all tips to
remember when creating content and then
the one important tip here is we want to
use white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
white hack techniques that's what we
mean write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so they're different
types of content so there's content
where you just write words to install
text based you could also use an
infographic an infographic is simply
just a graphic that visualizes exactly
what you're trying to explain for
example if we want to
write an article about
how to write good engaging content we
don't necessarily have to write all that
out as a text we can create an
infographic so for example here's an
infographic on 20 effective ways to
basically not bore your readers but
write engaging content so you could see
this is an infographic it's all
graphically laid out so
infographics tend to be easier to
understand because they're visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because there's generally no
jargon it's usually images that are
portraying the point of what you're
trying to get across and so it tends to
break it up the monotony of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and organized so you can see
this infographic
has 20 different steps or rules and they
lay those out all here in this
infographic and the great thing i like
about infographics is you could you
could share them on social media you can
re-engage them as a post you can save
them on really any social platform so
infographics tend to tell a better story
and versus say just writing text you can
use video and images so you don't
necessarily have to lay it all out in an
infographic you can certainly insert a
video or an image into
your content especially if it's a blog
post if it's a blog post then sometimes
video and images on its own
tell the story you don't necessarily
need
text to
go ahead and tell your story a video or
an image as they say tells a thousand
words and so
images and videos are great to use in a
blog post so
using different forms of content you
know you always want to review your
content when a user dwells on your web
page for a longer time google will tend
to think okay this person's engaged so
we're going to rank that favorably so if
you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
hubspot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again as best practices we just went
over but the key is you know if you have
longer more engaging content then it's
going to bode better for you on search
engines so a couple of steps to create
high quality content so you want to
begin with a comprehensive introduction
so always introduce your content
remember the content should be relevant
to the keywords so if you're choosing
keywords and your keyword research think
about answering that question if
somebody's typing in bread recipes maybe
they're looking for banana bread recipes
how to make the best banana bread or how
to make banana bread using dried figs we
want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally you want to
create a title that's worthy that's
click worthy so remember if you're in
google search and you're doing search
for something simple like bread recipes
we wanted some make something that's
gonna be you know engaging for somebody
to click on like easy perfect yeast
bread or easy crusty french bread or
something that's gonna be engaging you
know the best bread recipes or how to
make the best homemade bread you know
something that's going to draw
somebody's attention to the title of
that blog post so we want to include lsi
keywords so what i mean by lsi keywords
in your content we mean you know long
tail keywords make it natural headings
and subheadings should consist of
keywords and variants so
if you're writing headers and subheaders
include the keyword in there and that
way
the content always stays relevant to the
audience okay shorten your sentences and
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easy for the
end user to read and we want to
always put internal links on our blog
post why because if we have internal
links then if we have a link from one
blog post to another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website we want to make sure that it's
relevant content that way somebody's
reading something and you have an
internal link let's just say from a
bread recipes page to
a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page so it's keeping somebody engaged on
your website so putting in internal
linking will help keep the end user
engaged because you're offering up links
that's relevant to the content you
always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use alt tags
meaning we want to
pen the image with text so that way the
image doesn't load then at least the alt
text will load so we can incorporate
call out boxes and more importantly we
want to update our content regularly so
we always want to
get the best recipe out there if it's
banana bread or different ways to create
banana bread or always just coming up
with ways to update the content so we
want to keep our content our blog post
fresh and then we want to include a cta
call to action if we include a call to
action then that's going to keep
somebody engaged and have them act on
your content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three-month-old post on
buzzfeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012 again a lot of
engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we could see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includes sources from
high authority websites some do's and
don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices i mentioned
about creating high quality content
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content i.e in the form of infographics
or videos or text or images you can add
images from public domain sites you can
be relatable and use examples to clarify
points just like the buzzfeed article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen to find an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com
creditxyz.com for the image and even put
a link back but ideally you don't want
to take images from other websites just
as much as you don't want to take copy
you don't want to take images use your
own imagery and content but if you don't
have imagery then you can always go to
stock photography there are plenty of
websites out there where you can sign up
for a subscription like adobe stock
images as an example you could sign up
for an account and in some cases you can
sign up for a free account and use stock
imagery okay don't give less information
to your audience give them to your
audience what they deserve which is the
information they're looking for they're
looking for the best banana bread
recipes give them the best banana bread
recipes incorporate your own images
break it up with titles give them a good
quality piece of content that they're
going to be able to engage with and so
if you put long paragraphs in your
content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
about high quality content
in order to get your pages ranked high
on google search let's turn our
attention to
optimizing on page elements and discuss
some website level factors that are both
going to help you rank high on google
search so
let's just do an overview of what we're
talking about when we talk about on-page
elements and website level factors so
optimizing on-page elements include a
number of different things but primarily
we're going to focus in on meta tags
also known as meta description tags
header tags also known as title tags and
urls so those are just some of the
on-page elements we want to be able to
optimize using relevant keywords in
order to rank high in google search we
also want to
take a look at some website factors that
will affect our ranking on google search
they include website architecture having
a secure website having a site map and
taking a look at page speed so all of
those are some of the website factors we
need to take into account in order to
rank high on google search so title tag
and meta description
together are considered meta tags so
both play an important role in ranking
high on google so we want to be able to
write unique title and descriptions for
each page on our website when i say
unique that means the title and the meta
description need to be different for
every page on the website and so if
you're not quite sure
what a title tag and a meta description
tag is if you go to search and just type
in any particular search query the title
tag is what's going to show up here in
bold and then the description is going
to show up below it below the url and
that's going to describe the page so
both of these meta tags are important
because it describes what your page is
all about and that's what google uses in
the search results pages so we want to
be able to pay attention to the length
of our meta tags so if we go back to our
search results pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters meta
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's gonna happen is
the meta description tag or the title
tag will get truncated and so if we look
here for example we can see all of the
title tags here fit the 65 character
limit but if you run over the character
count on meta description then google is
going to truncate the copy so you want
to stay within your parameters in order
to avoid getting your content truncated
and so the other thing when we're
writing title meta description tags we
want to minimize keyword repetition so
if we're optimizing for keyword we don't
want to necessarily just plug that
keyword into the title tag and meta
description multiple times we want to
make sure our title tags and meta
descriptions are naturally written so if
somebody's typing for banana bread
recipe with dried figs you know we want
to have a nice title tag and into this
description that is going to get
somebody to respond uh based on their
need and so we definitely want to avoid
keyword repetition but we want to be
able to use that keyword in the title
tag because if you remember from the
earlier segment when we did the all in
title syntax to find out exactly how
many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the
title tag and the meta description to
describe the page sound natural but also
be engaging because the point is we want
people to click on our link and go to
our website from search engines so title
tags with numbers tend to result in
higher click-through rates this is
according to mods so for example
if you just put in a title tag that says
learn digital marketing well that may
work but if you put a number in there
like five easy ways to learn digital
marketing that might get somebody to
click on your link and go to your
website so having questions in your meta
tags can also increase your
click-through rate for example if you
just put learn the importance of first
page rankings not too bad but again
generic but if you put it into the
formal question how to rank number one
on google it's more action oriented it's
gonna get somebody to resonate with the
question that they have and that may be
their query how to rank number one on
google and so these techniques will
help you get higher click-through rates
and so according to backlinko
title tag with a keyword can improve
site ranking so remember we want to
include that keyword in the title tag
even though we only have 65 characters
we want to include that keyword but we
want to avoid stuffing the keyword in
there we want to again make the title
tag action oriented maybe with a number
maybe as a question with the keyword in
there once naturally not easy to do
but that's the beauty of seo if you can
follow these best practices and write a
good title tag then the chances of you
improving in your search results are
going to be greater so having only one
h1 tag in your post is going to be good
so remember when somebody clicks on a
link so let's say they do find a title
tag engaging and they click on this this
link here and they go to that website
you know you want to start out with
having that particular h1 tech because
the h1 tag especially with the keyword
in it is going to signal to google hey
we're organizing our page and because
it's an h1 tag it's important we're
structuring the page according to best
practices so having only one h1 tag in
your post is definitely helpful having
multiple tags h tags in your post help
organize the page a lot better so we
want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag and your header tag should be
relevant to the content so if we go back
to our example of the using dried figs
with banana breads well the title says
california fig banana bread and remember
the last segment when we're talking
about high quality content we'll look no
further than including a video into
our content so not only will this video
help keep the engagement high but it
breaks up the monotony of the page and
it's from a third-party source so it
adds credibility to the page so adding a
videos based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on google search so
following hierarchical structure that
means putting those h tags in there h2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of h1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same h1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it blase we want to make those h1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques we
want to avoid hidden texts we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your h1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long h1 tags if
we go back to our page example a short
sweet tag here california fig banana
bread it's relevant to the content it's
short sweet and breaks up the monotony
of the content and more importantly
again any content you have on the page
should always answer the user's intent
remember people are using search to
answer questions find information our
content should be able to answer that
for them so
according to john muller senior
webmaster trends analyst at google
header tags would definitely help google
for rankings in the search results so we
want to use header tags so when it comes
to urls we want to use hyphens and avoid
underscores so if we look at this url
here this uses hyphens fig and banana
bread so it's all broken up with hyphens
that's a best practice remember
canonical urls a canonical url signals
to google this is the original content
so we want to use original content and
if you have multiple sources of content
out there on say different websites
we want to use the canonical tag to
signal to google this is the original
content please index this content and
that doesn't hurt to use a favicon url
meaning a small icon it helps to break
up the monotony and help your url stand
out we can add targeted keywords in the
url so again looking at the url here i
can see we're using targeted keyword as
part of the url structure vegan banana
bread and notice the h1 tag is fake
banana bread so it's all consistent and
it flows naturally urls that are no
longer existing then we want to be able
to set up a redirect for those urls
meaning a 301 redirect is a server
response for google that says hey
google this page is no longer available
but we permanently redirected it to this
page which is now available so that's
what a 301 redirect does it helps signal
to google and all the other search
engines that if the page is no longer
there that's fine you're just going to
go to this page this is the page that's
permanently there now and another thing
we want to do here is if you have mobile
urls you want to include those in the
sitemap and we're going to hit on that
in just a minute but all urls should be
mobile friendly as well as desktop
friendly meaning take into account those
best practices keep your url short use
hyphens put the keyword in that url and
make it easy to understand want to avoid
capital letters in the urls the urls are
case sensitive so go lowercase you
should always go lower case from the url
readable urls again the rule of thumb
here is if you understand what the url
is then google is going to understand
what the url is so the shorter the url
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on google search so according
to backlink 2 urls that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those urls
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable so those are
some on optimized ways or on-page
elements that help you optimize now we
want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
write kind google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that google's
going to be able to find all the pages
so what do we mean by that create a
logical hierarchy structure so if you're
selling shoes you know you're going to
have a home page break the structure up
into men's shoes women's shoes
children's shoes then under men's shoes
you could have it by brand it could be
nike puma adidas on the women's side it
could be nike puma adidas on the child
side it could be nike puma adidas and so
you want to keep the structure flow in a
hierarchy do we want to balance the
amount of subcategories within each
category so the men's if it has nike
puma adidas the women should have nike
puma adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation in css or html
meaning we want to be able to use
something that google is going to be
able to index so most sites are built in
html and that's what google likes to
index they like to index something that
they could take back to their servers
and then more importantly build a
comprehensive structure for internal
linking so internal links mean that if
you're on a site you should have natural
links pointing to other pages on your
website so to keep the flow going and we
don't want to have unnatural inbound
things you always want to have natural
internal links to keep the flow of the
user going from one page to the other so
here i can see as an example all the
ingredients in this recipe well this has
an internal link to another page on our
site and this happens to link to a page
where somebody can buy the ingredients
so it's a natural internal link so john
doherty of credo has claimed that one of
the biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the credo website is architecture
so for example in credo john dougherty
has increased the organic sessions by 74
and pages by per session by 41
just by changing the site architecture
so you'd be surprised by changing the
site architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus non-secure so
what we mean by that is securing your
site we want to make it sure that
compliant with certain protocols and so
if we go back here we can see that this
particular site is compliant it is
secure
https means it has a secure license
meaning the site is secure so google
likes secure versus non-secure so
non-secure would be http so we want
https as our protocol and what that
means is just enabling ssl certificates
and that means when you enable an ssl
certificate that means your domain or
your protocol is going to be turned to
https so google prefers sites that are
secure versus non-secure so if you use
hsts
as a protocol that adds an extra layer
of security over the https and hsts
prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an http
website a non-secure website you should
look into
buying an ssl certificate getting your
sites flipped over to https
because what's going to happen is your
url structure is going to change when
your url structure changes google's
going to recognize that because they're
going to index your site and when they
index your site they're going to see
those secure urls and that's going to
work favorably in your favor and help
you rank higher on google search so
websites using secure or https have a
higher chance of ranking higher so https
is a ranking signal because google
indexes those pages so let's also talk
about sitemaps so sitemap is one of the
most important ways to improve your
website ranking why well because
sitemaps are a way to organize all your
urls into one file so we're basically
going to
prioritize all our web pages in a
sitemap so if you go to any particular
website and you type in sitemap xml
you're likely going to see all the pages
on your website so usually the site map
is located in the root directory so if i
type in
sitemap.xml i'm going to be able to see
all the pages in my root directory and i
can also prioritize them i can also
alert google as to how often they change
and every page is going to have a date
stamp associated with it so google can
actually see how often it changes so
remember we want our content to be
updated frequently so content's not
updated frequently or it's not fresh
then google is going to see that site
that date stamp that last modification
down so we want to be able to make sure
content content's updated frequently we
want to let google know that we changed
it frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our pages let google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a site map we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
urls in the sitemaps so we want to be
able to add all our original urls in our
sitemap and so we always want to build
dynamic urls sitemaps for larger
websites and what i mean by dynamic urls
that means that if i look at this site
map and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the sitemap as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the site map
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see
the sitemap grow with more urls when the
sitemap grows with more urls then that
means then google is going to index more
pages they're going to index more fresh
pages so they're going to be able to get
those pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
dynamic sitemaps is we want to be able
to capture all the urls just as they're
published and we want to be able to
maintain our sitemaps and so i would
always recommend a dynamic sitemap but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a tool called xml
sitemap so if i just type in xml
sitemaps
into google search here i can see xml
sitemaps generator and i can be able if
i have a small website just create a
free and simple site map on my own when
xml sitemaps creates it or your platform
creates a dynamic sitemap either way the
sitemaps going to sit in the root
directory and then what we want to do in
turn is let google know where that site
map is so in search console we want to
be able to submit the sitemap so you're
going to add the sitemap you're going to
let google know where it is it should be
in the root directory and it should be
called
sitemap.xml and when you do that google
is going to be able to take those urls
and index them so we could see we
submitted 528 urls google index 521 so
one thing about urls here is when we
create a site map we're putting all your
urls in there we do not add no index
urls in your sitemap and what that means
is that any url we don't want google to
index we're just going to exclude from
the sitemap okay so we want google to
take all the urls we want indexed and
put them in the sitemap so according to
edgy using sitemaps for seo can increase
your website's visibility and help you
get indexed why because what you're in
fact doing is taking all your urls that
you want indexed you're telling google
how often they're modified you're
telling google which ones are important
and you're submitting that to google and
so google's going to be able to take all
these urls quicker index them quicker
and when they're indexed quicker you can
get ranked quicker and when you get rank
quicker you can get traffic quicker so
that's the whole idea behind site maps
so let's turn our attention to page
speed now so when the last factors for
our website besides architecture making
it secure and adding site maps is want
to take a look at how quick our pages
load here are some tips in order to
optimize page speed because ideally the
quicker a page loads the more engaged
the user is going to be if it takes a
longer time for the page to load all the
elements of that page then what's going
to happen is the user is going to get
impatient maybe leave the website all
together or go to another page and so we
want to be able to optimize images so
any image that's of large size in terms
of megabytes we want to be able to
optimize that to compress the image so
that's one way to speed up page speed we
want to use a simple website design you
know html with css or cascading style
sheets just a simple design with simple
hierarchy and website navigation
structure so nothing fancy nothing
complex just a simple website design
with optimized images we want to
leverage browser caching and we want to
upgrade the server response time meaning
all your files are sitting on the server
so when somebody goes to web page the
server is serving up all of those files
the images the text etc and so we want
the server to respond as quick as
possible so when it comes to page speed
we can look at the factors affecting
page speed in google analytics so if i
go to google analytics and i go under
behavior and i go under site speed and i
go to overview i'm going to be able to
see what my average load time is for my
site and ideally we want our pages to
load as quick as possible so that means
anything under four seconds anything
four seconds or higher and it's likely
the end user is going to leave the page
there's a correlation be between page
load time and bounce rate and so what
google actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions in google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then google is
going to be able to tell us hey this
particular page load fast this potential
page loads slow and if it loaded slow
why is it loading slow so here we could
see the home page of the example is
loaded on average of seven seconds well
if we look here they're going to give us
some suggestions so if i click on this
page speed suggestions it's going to
load a report and a tool called
pagespeed insights and basically what
it's then going to do after it's done
running is it's going to tell me all the
ways in which i can optimize my pages
not only for
desktop but also for mobile so here i
can see for desktop or for mobile i can
look at some ways in which i can
optimize it to increase page speed for
example sizing my images properly server
response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirect so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to p speed
up page load time and all that's found
in page speed insights and all that's
found within google analytics so
remember optimizing code minimizing
redirects optimizing your images
upgrading your server response and all
of those are factors and so again you
can go into analytics page speed
insights and you can see exactly what
google is recognizing as what's lowering
or slowing down your page load time so
google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so if somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today walmart as an example
experience to decline in conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their page
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it basically
increased conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between
how quick a page loads and how engaged
the user is because if it's users
engaged they're going to stay on the
site if they stay on the site then their
chances of converting are going to be
higher so just even one to two seconds
increase and page load is low time will
make a world of difference in terms of
engagement and conversions let's turn
our attention to off-site engagement so
previously we talked about on-page
elements and website factors that affect
our rankings for search results but we
also need to turn our attention away
from our website meaning what we do on
our website and turn our attention what
we can do for our website off our
website and onto other websites so
that's off-site engagement and so let's
look at an example so that ice cream
recipes blog so
we did everything we possibly could we
updated the meta tags the title tag the
meta description we added h1 tags we
made sure the site architecture was
sound we submitted a site map we we made
sure the page load was good and fast so
we did all the things we're supposed to
do on our web page but we're still not
ranking well what do we need to do well
we need to turn our attention away from
our website into other websites we call
this off site or off page seo and we
need to basically generate links from
high quality sites back to our site so
if we've done everything we can on our
own website and we're still not ranking
where we want to be well then we need to
turn our attention to other websites and
so if we turn our attention other
websites and other websites that are
relevant other websites that are of
quality other websites that have high
domain authority
then we're going to see an increase in
rankings so it's just a matter of
getting quality links from quality
websites that are relevant that's what's
going to move the needle on search after
we've taken care of all the on-page
elements so more backlinks from high
domain authority results in higher
rankings seo is a combination between
what we do on our website meaning
optimizing the page and making sure our
website has good site architecture and
follows the best practices in terms of
site maps and page load then we need to
turn our attention to the backlinking to
improve our domain authority so
according to backlinko analysis off-site
engagement is one of the most important
elements for ranking number one in
google so you can't just focus your
attention on updating the title tag and
making sure the pages load fast you have
to turn your attention as well to
getting back links from high quality
sites that's off-site engagement and so
gaining links back links from multiple
games is vital it's vital because they
bring referring traffic to your site
they bring credibility to your site but
more importantly google's going to
recognize the relationship between these
sites and your website and if these
sites that have backlinks or links
pointing to your site and if they're of
high quality then we call that passing
link choose so it's going to bring
quality to you in terms of organic
search so if we look at an example
if i do a search for banana bread recipe
there are
241 billion results for banana bread
recipe why did this particular page from
simply recipes rank number one well we
can turn our attention to moz and maz
has a report called link explorer and so
moz link explorer report
helps us identify our own page authority
our own domain authority and how many
links we have from other quality
websites so if i put that particular url
into link explorer and notice the url
here is short even though it uses an
underscore when it shows a hyphen it's
still ranked number one and why because
off page elements help this page rank
number one why their page authority out
of 100 is 58 their domain authority out
of 100 is 82. and what does that mean
well that means that they have a lot of
good links from other domains of high
quality they have 824 linking domains to
this one domain they have 3 600 inbound
links and they're ranking for a lot of
different keywords so if we scroll down
we're going to be able to see kind of a
breakout the quality of websites that
are linking to them so they have 19
domains with a domain authority of 91 to
100 linking to them they have 15 domains
between the range of 81 and 90. so what
does that tell me between 15 and 19
that's 34 particular domains that are
very high quality linking to it and so
we could see the breakout of the linking
domains we could see the top file links
to the site and we could see the page
authority so the link explorer report
gives us an overview of what pages are
linking to ours and it also gives us an
idea of what our own page authority and
domain authority are because domain
authority and page authority both need
to be high in order for us to rank on
google search in order for it to get
high
we need links from high quality sites so
that's the whole idea behind off site
engagement so some of the offside
engagements are influencer marketing
meaning is there somebody out there on
social who has a huge following but not
only do they have a huge following but
are they relevant to our product for
example usain bolt who's a famous
sprinter if we're selling shoes and
we're selling nike shoes maybe usain
bolt can reference us on twitter or
facebook that's influencer marketing
getting people to
influencing people to buy our product we
can engage with audiences on multiple
social media platforms like facebook and
twitter meaning if we're running a
promotion on those running shoes then we
can promote that on facebook okay we can
promote that on twitter we can also
bookmark our webpage on popular
bookmarking sites like stumbleupon we
can also put our content on discussion
forums like reddit we can join high pr
quality a q a sites excuse me and post
answers to questions related to our
business like cora.com so we can engage
in sharing our content and answering
questions so there's lots of ways to get
links to your website if you have a blog
post as an example you can
make sure that maybe that content is
shared on a similar blog post so if you
have an ice cream recipe blog post well
maybe you can look at a dessert blog
post and share your content on that
particular blog post and have a backlink
pointing from that blog post to yours as
an example and you can reciprocate so
the whole idea of content is sharing the
content but at the same time of sharing
it you're producing backlinks and
backlinks help domain authority so not
only do they help domain authority but
they improve the search rankings so in
google's eyes the higher your domain
authority higher the page authority in
google's eyes that means your page is
important it's credible and we're going
to prove it in the search engine
rankings it increases brand visibility
if we have our content on a
highly engageable website a highly
popular website or a blog it's not it's
going to lift our brand visibility if we
have usain bolt who's very famous
sprinter do some influence in marketing
for us then that's going to increase our
brand visibility so anytime we can
associate with something that has some
influence or some clout or high domain
authority then it's only going to
increase our brand awareness and
visibility so again it's going to
increase our domain authority because of
the association of passing link juice
from one domain to another it's going to
then as a result increase referral
traffic because if we're on a high
quality website that gets a lot of
traffic then the chances of some of that
traffic go on our site is going to be
great and again it improves the
credibility and trust of our website and
that's what we want we want google to
trust us and a way to build trust is by
associating our website with other
websites of high equal or higher quality
so when we talk about offsite engagement
we wanna do some guest posts on relevant
websites so if you have that ice cream
blog go to another blog like the dessert
blog and do a guest post so not only
that will that improve your brand
awareness but
it'll generate a backlink and maybe
drive some referral traffic you can
participate in forums and blog
discussions like core.com or reddit get
your content out there start a
discussion about a specific topic to
engage users build brand awareness and
generate that backlink you can always
you know put your
your site on a directory like yelp for
example or yahoo directory you could
prefer testimonial link building meaning
if you serve products or offer up a
service well somebody could provide a
testimony on their website or you can
just earn backlinks from relevant
authoritative web pages like we
mentioned quora or wikipedia there's
plenty out there so the idea is to
associate yourself with high quality
websites but do it naturally you don't
want to force anything so if you're
selling a specific service or selling a
specific product look for like mining
services or products that complement
what you do and that'll create the
natural environment natural ecosystem
that will eventually give you the
benefits that you need to rank higher in
the search results pages so we don't
want to purchase any links we don't want
to cloak content we don't want to just
inject links on sites that aren't
relevant we don't want to just have
site-wide links all over the place
pointing to the same page and we
certainly don't want to be on low
quality websites or directories it's all
about quality not quantity with offsite
engagement so having offsite engagement
complements what you do on your website
for on-site together both of those
efforts will get you higher search
engine results so let's start out with
why gtm so let's just say you're sam
and you have your own e-commerce website
you want to understand how people are
interacting with your website well sam
today's world of websites contain a lot
of interactivity everything from videos
to pdf downloads to commenting
to form submissions uh to all sorts of
chat functionality interactivity going
on throughout the website so there's
just a lot that you need to track
outside of just page views and so
really what gtm does is they help you
track all these things i just mentioned
everything from somebody clicking on the
play button of a pdf to somebody
clicking on the submit button of a form
to somebody entering in something on a
chat function so that's what gtm is so
why gtm because it helps us track all
that interactivity so all gtm is is
really allows you to really place a
piece of java code which is just script
and this script that's added to a web
page to collect information so that's
really what a tag is it's just some
script that gets put on a web page in
order for you to collect information
like page views clicks etc and they send
it to third party tools okay so that's
what gtm does it it basically allows you
to take all these tags that collect
information and you can use them in gta
so
if you want to for example
collect how many people
you know enter
a
chat functionality and start chatting
well you're going to take that script
and you're going to put it in gtm and
gtm will then allow you to start
tracking that information so that's
really what gtm is it just allows you to
put tags into a container or think of it
as a toy box you have all these toys and
you want to track or you can put all
those those toys or tags in a toy box or
container and we're going to talk a
little bit more about that but before we
get into gtm let's just say
you know you're communicating with your
developer and
there's a new user request on your web
page and you want to update the tag well
your developer considering it's probably
a small
update to your website it's probably
gonna not um hesitate and is gonna go
ahead and turn around and do it normally
and so normally what happens is the
developer is gonna go to the website and
update the tag well what if you have a
few things that you wanna track all
those things i mentioned before from
downloads to clicks to
you know somebody checking out to
watching a video well your webmaster
your web developer is going to go well
hold on a second now all these requests
are going to take time i need to put
them into the work queue so to speak
well what happens is when they go into
work queue usually it's going to take
some time and
in some cases you as a marketer need to
launch a campaign and you want to get
that tracking uh added to the website in
time for the campaign launch so you want
to go ahead and quickly turn around the
tracking for that particular campaign
let's just say you're launching a
campaign and you're sending people to a
landing page that has a form submission
and you want to be able to track how
many people click on the submit button
of that form submission well if you need
to turn that around your developer's
like well i need to put that in a work
queue the timing isn't going to always
work out between you and your developer
as my point and so that's where gtm
comes in because there is a solution
update your tags faster and that's
google tag manager so when we say gtm
that's what gtm stands for google tag
manager it's a place for you to add tags
quickly and easily so tags remember are
just snippets of code that allow you to
track things on your website
interactively interactive activity and
basically when you have gtm you can
bypass the webmaster and do it quickly
and easily so
that's what gtm is all about so why gtm
because we just identified two benefits
one you could track all the
interactivity on your website and two
you can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and so that's the benefit of
gtm so the benefit you get those tags
updated very quickly via google tag
manager okay so that's what tag manager
is so what we're going to talk about
today is specifically what tag manager
is and what it does we're going to list
some of the benefits of tag manager
we're going to show you how it works and
then we're going to show you how to get
started with tag manager tag manager if
you're not familiar with working with
webmasters and dealing with javascript
and tags and all this jargon is just new
to you today okay well don't fret sit
back we're to take it slow this is an
introduction into google tag manager
again let's start out with what is tag
manager so we've already introduced it
to some degree because we already
introduced is a tool where you can put
all your tags into a toolbox toy box or
container so to speak right and we
already already mentioned that hey you
can bypass your webmaster so you're
probably thinking well if i'm if you're
not familiar with tag manager how can i
bypass my webmaster well first of all
it's a free tool and it's a google tool
hence the name google tag manager and it
helps you really that's the main point
is deploy and track tags on your website
by passing your webmaster so that's tag
manager and so examples are tags that
can be deployed
via google tag manager are numerous
these are just some examples like google
analytics facebook pixel tracking or
google ads there's no limit into the
number of tags you can track in tag
manager there is no limit you can add
any number of tracking tags and tag
manager okay so some of the benefits
well again i we just listed two you can
put any tag into tag manager and track
that onto your website and we know you
can bypass your web developer or
webmaster and what it also does is it
also allows you to test and deploy your
javascript codes quicker so remember
these javascript codes or snippets of
codes are just there to track certain
things on your website whether that be a
page view or somebody clicking on a play
button or tracking somebody who converts
or even just goes to your website so the
biggest benefit is you can take that
snippet of code let's just say facebook
let's just say you're doing facebook
marketing and you want to put that
facebook pixel on your website so that
you could track people who come from
facebook and convert well you don't need
to put that facebook pixel on your
website you can go right to tag manager
and you can put that snippet of code
right in tag manager really quickly and
the other benefit here is all tags are
managed in one place and that's that to
me is really a good benefit because when
you start adding tags on your website
and you have some tags and tag manager
it just gets very confusing so ideally
all the tracking code you have on your
website needs to be in tag manager think
about that all the tracking so if you're
doing bing or you're doing facebook or
you're doing twitter or you're doing
linkedin and you're doing google you're
doing all this type of marketing on all
these different platforms you're gonna
have tracking code for all these
different platforms and instead of
putting on that code on your website
return gonna slow down the slow time of
your web page and website you wanna put
them all in tag manager so they can be
organized and you know exactly what
you're trying to track and the other
great benefit of tag manager is there's
a versioning control so let's just say
you have added tags to your website via
gtm for the last six months well and
let's just say you add another tag
yesterday if you added that tag
yesterday and something doesn't work
well you can just roll back to a
previous version it's that simple so you
have versioning and that's that's a good
thing when you have versioning you can
control what gets published and if
something doesn't work after it gets
published then you can roll back to a
previous version so it's a a piece of
mind so to speak just because you've
added code to your site there's no
guarantee it's going to work and so you
can always control what version you're
dealing with in tag manager and we'll
talk a little bit more about that so the
biggest benefit here to me with tag
manager is you have event tracking and
so we talked about some of the things
you could track on your website from
videos from play buttons to somebody
clicking on the stop on the video or
pausing it all the way to somebody again
chatting or let's just say somebody
clicking on that purchase button on your
website okay and you want to track all
these different things these different
interactivities and buttons well event
tracking is what you're going to use to
track all those buttons and to me this
is the biggest benefit of tag manager
and i'll show you some examples as we go
along and if we didn't mention it
already i'll mention it again it is free
tag manager is free there's no limit so
once you have tag manager going you can
add as many tracking codes as you want
there's no limit on the number of
tracking codes you can add to tag
manager okay so it's free and you can
use it to its fullest advantage okay so
it's also high security meaning that it
has different levels of permissions okay
so you can have uh somebody just go in
and look at the different tags and
tracking codes you have in gtm or you
can have somebody who
is very familiar with tag manager and
can go in and add the tracking code to
tag manager and then publish that
tracking code when it gets added so
those are all the benefits let's talk
about how it works now specifically how
does tag manager work because you're
like rob okay again a lot of jargon you
know you you got tags and javascript and
and versioning and publishing and all
this other stuff well i know i'm
throwing a lot at you at once but just
bear with me here okay so let's start
talking about how it actually works so
you have a website okay whatever that
domain is you have a website and there's
chances are on your website you have
some form of interactivity whether that
be a video whether that be a blog
whether it be a form submission you have
a website with some interactivity and
let's just say you're even thinking
about getting ready to launch some type
of campaign on maybe google or facebook
and you want to drive traffic to your
website fair enough you're joining the
millions of other websites that are out
there that have interactivity that also
drive traffic to the website so income's
google tag manager and so tag manager is
important because again we know we want
to track people coming from that
facebook campaign or that google
campaign and interacting with our site
so if you are running facebook and you
are running google analytics well guess
what you want to put that tracking code
in tag manager so google analytics being
a google product works very nicely with
tag manager facebook has its own
tracking code but you still want to be
able to track people who come from the
facebook campaign to your website so
you're gonna get that tracking code from
facebook and put it in tag manager
that's generally how it works so here
information from your website is shared
with another data source through tag
manager so think about that if i add
facebook tracking code to tag manager or
let's just say i had google analytics
tracking code to tag manager tag manager
is the one that's pushing out and doing
all the heavy lifting they're the ones
that are controlling what code gets
fired and what code doesn't so if you're
putting the code in tag manager tag
manager is controlling the code think
about it that way and let's show you an
example of what that looks like so here
i am i'm in tag manager i just went to
tag manager.google.com
and here i could see a list of tags so
in our conversation we're talking about
tracking facebook and we're talking
about tracking google analytics well
google analytics is easy because it's a
google product so here if i look at all
the different tracking code i have on my
website through tag manager let's just
take a look at google analytics so if
you're going to use tag manager you
might as well put the google analytics
code in here so here i can see i have
google analytics as a tag in tag manager
now for facebook if i'm running a
facebook campaign well i can take that
pixel tracking and put it in gtm as well
and here i could see facebook pixel that
is that code is added to gtm i just
basically took what facebook gave me and
put it into google tag manager so you
can see i can add facebook and google
analytics and again i can't stress it
enough any tracking code from any
platform i can add to google tag manager
in order to track the behavior from
those sources so let's take a little bit
deeper dive into how tag manager works
so i just showed you an example of how
you could take facebook and google
analytics code and put it into tag
manager but if you're not familiar with
tag manager then how do i do that well
let's talk about the structure and how
tag manager works so when you have a tag
manager account you have a container
remember i mentioned toy box earlier you
have a bunch of toys if they're they're
code and you're tracking different bits
of code from different platforms like
facebook think of those as toys and you
have a toy box okay well that's what
this code is and that's what a container
is the code is the code and that's going
to go into the toy box or container and
so the way tag manager works is you have
tags triggers and variables so if i take
my facebook tracking code and put it
into a container i need to set up a tag
and a trigger okay so let's take a look
at what that is so first if i go back to
tag manager i'm going to have an account
and if i have an account i'm going to
have a container so here i'm just going
to click on an account with a container
and a container is nothing more than
what website you're adding the tracking
code two okay that's all the container
is we're just letting tag manager know
this is the website we're adding all
this code to so you have tags triggers
and variables that's the structure of
tag manager so tags are just what it
says tags what are we trying to quote
unquote tag well if it's google
analytics that's easy here i can see i
have google analytics added so if i
click on google analytics here's my tag
and if i take a little bit of a deeper
dive there since google analytics is a
google product it integrates already
with tag managers it's pretty easy i can
just choose google analytics then i'm
going to check page view and that's my
tag now every tag needs a trigger okay
so i need to tell tag manager how or
when to fire the google analytics
tracking code so in this case i'm going
to tell tag manager to fire on all pages
so if i get somebody a visitor to my
website analytics is firing on all pages
so whatever page that visitor lands on
google analytics is going to fire so
that's really what it comes down to is i
have a tag and i need to tell tag
manager when to trigger that tag that's
really what the structure of tag manager
is it's tags triggers and variables and
variables what we're going to talk about
here in a couple minutes but you have a
piece of code you're going to go ahead
and put that into tag manager you're
going to tag it and then you're going to
fire that trigger so let's take a look
at another example here if i go back
here you can see facebook well here's my
facebook pixel okay that's my tag so
when is it gonna fire well it's gonna
fire on a specific domain or subdomain
that's basically what we're doing we're
trying to tell gtm when to fire that
particular tag so those are the three
main components a tag okay which is
going to contain the javascript code
that you get from say facebook the
trigger so you're going to go into tag
manager and tell tag manager when to
fire that code that's the trigger and
then you have variables and so
variables are basically just additional
information that tag manager may need
for your tag and trigger to work so
that's what a variable is it's there to
get the tag and trigger to fire so
variables are divided into built-in and
user-defined variables so common use
variables include say page path or page
url or hostname or click class again
they're there and these examples i just
gave you are there to get your tag and
trigger to work think about it that way
they're just that's a component and if i
go into tag manager here and here on the
left side i can see variables so
remember i have built in and user
defined so built-in means that tag
manager already built these for me so in
case i need to get my trigger to work
with my tag i can use a variable so
those are built in and then i have user
defined so these are what i define these
are what i created and again the
variables are there to get the tag and
trigger to work okay so that's the job
of the variable the job of the tag is to
host that javascript code okay in the
case of facebook or analytics that's
where we're putting our code so here if
i click on adwords remarketing again
it's a google product so i don't really
need to even deal with code i'm just
going to select google adwords
remarketing okay so you can see gtm
integrates nicely with some of the other
google products but let's just say you
have a facebook pixel tracking code
you're going to choose custom and you're
going to put the code here so that's
part of the tag and then the trigger
again is there to get the tag to fire so
you're telling gtm when to fire the tag
and the variable is there to help you
make sure that that trigger and that tag
work together so that's how all three
kind of work together you need the tag
to put the code you need the trigger to
tell gtm when to fire the tag in code
and the variables there to help you
define when that tag and trigger should
work or how it should work so again
review tags are just small codes of
javascript or tracking pixels on your
website and so tags are allowed to
manage events like scroll track and
remarketing clicks downloads files play
buttons you name it and even clicks on
external links for example let's just
say you have a click uh or a facebook uh
icon on your site and when somebody
clicks on it they go to facebook you
wanna maybe track that you're gonna
create a tag okay the trigger is there
because you need to tell gtm when to
fire that tag so it's a certain
condition whether it's you know fire the
tag if the url equals facebook.com or
some other condition so the tag cannot
be created until the creation of the
corresponding trigger so tags and
triggers go together you can't just
create a tag and not have a trigger
otherwise your tag will never fire and
then the variable is there again it
stores the information when defining a
trigger or transferring data to tag so a
variable has a variety of data okay so
you pick and choose the variable you
want to use with that trigger okay so
you're making sure that by defining a
variable you're making sure that you're
telling gtm how that trigger should be
fired so let's take a look at another
example here of how all three play
together if i'm in this account i'm in
this container if i look down here i can
see google optimize that's another
google product so what i'm doing here is
i just chose google optimize as my tag
it's already integrated so what does
that mean i don't even need to deal with
any code i'm just going to select
optimize well we have the tag google
optimize but we need to tell gtm how to
fire that and so here we're going to
tell gtm to fire it on all pages so
that's basically a very simple example
because we're firing it on all pages so
if i want to look at something specific
again facebook here's my tag here's my
code what's my trigger well my trigger
is it's going to fire on specific pages
how do i know that well if i look at the
trigger here i could see the trigger is
a page view but i'm telling it to fire
on this particular hostname so the tag
and trigger go hand in hand
so how to get started with tag manager
so first things first you have to create
that account so you're going to go to
tag manager.google.com
or you can do a search for google tag
manager
and you're going to create your account
and then when you create your account
what's going to happen is you're going
to
set up a container and when you set up a
container you have choices so you could
set it up for your website for an app on
ios or maybe android or you can even set
it up for amp etc an accelerated mobile
page so most people by default are
probably going to set up tag manager for
their website and so when you do that
when you actually select website what's
going to happen is you're going to get
some google tag manager code in return
and so the whole idea here is you're
going to do a swap what you're doing is
basically you're saying okay google i'm
going to take this google tag manager
code and i'm going to put it on my
website i'm going to put it on every
page in my website so notice tag manager
has two scripts one goes in the head as
high as possible the other goes into the
body tag as high as possible and so what
you're doing is you're making a deal
you're putting this tag manager code on
your website and in return every code
you deal with whether that be facebook
or analytics or optimize or remarketing
or whatever it is is gonna go in gtm
okay it's gonna go into the container
you created so you need the tag manager
code on your website in order for tag
manager to work okay so when you add
this code to your website then you're
free to start adding all sorts of tags
to your container but if you don't have
this tracking code on your website then
none of the tags you add to your
container are gonna work so that's the
idea behind the container and then one
thing i wanted to mention on the account
is it's a google account so when you
create your account then make sure it's
the same account you use with say google
analytics or some other google product
that's a good best practice is always
use the same email address when you set
up your account so that it integrates
nicely across all the different
platforms meaning you can go from say
google analytics right to google tag
manager in one browser without having to
log out or log in okay so when you
create the account you're going to
create your container if you choose web
then you're going to be asked to place
code on your website and when you place
that code on your website then you are
free to start using tag manager and that
means you're free to start adding tags
okay so if you want to know more
information about installing google tag
manager
then what i would recommend is visit the
quick start guide website of gtm so
again if you're curious as to where that
code is located in google tag manager
well when you create an account and you
create a container that container is
going to have a specific id so if i
click on that specific id here's where i
can get my code okay so again when i'm
logged in to tag manager i'm going to
click on workspace but in the top
navigation i'm going to see my unique
gtm id if i click on that that's where
my code is going to be located and so
again your code needs to go in the
header and there's another script that
needs to go in the body and if you're
not sure how to add the code to your
website well you can always click on the
quick start guide here okay and that'll
take you to a quick start guide page a
reference page related to google tag
manager so let's talk about creating a
tag so once you get tag manager
installed i'm sure you're excited to get
going and create that first tag so let's
talk about how to create a tag in tag
manager so when you're in tag manager
all you need to do is basically you're
looking at all your tags if you click on
tag in the left side navigation you'll
see all your tags and there's a new
button there so you just click new and
so
basically what you're going to do is
you're going to create your first tag
and so what i would recommend once you
get tag manager installed on your
website i would recommend setting the
first tag up as google analytics so that
will get you going with tracking page
views on your website when some when
somebody visits your website okay so
ideally that's what you want to do you
want to get google analytics as your
first tag and tag manager so what i'm
gonna do is because analytics is a
google product it's already integrated
nicely with tag manager so i'm just
gonna click on google analytics it's
going to be a page for you that's what
i'm tracking and now i have to set up a
variable and so what it's going to do
it's going to ask me to sort of select a
variable and so what you're going to do
is you're going to select new variable
and what you're going to do is you're
actually going to go and add your
tracking id here that's going to be your
variable so where do i get my tracking
id and analytics well if i'm in
analytics i'm going to go to admin and
then under property settings i'm going
to see my tracking id and all you need
to do then is go to tag manager and
paste copy first you gotta copy over
that tracking id then you're gonna go to
tag manager and paste it and then that's
gonna create a variable for you and then
when you create that variable you're
gonna see it in the drop down here so
i've already created it and
basically that's your tag with a
variable then what are you gonna do
you're gonna set up a trigger so see i
have some triggers already set up you're
going to see a default trigger already
set up for you and that's going to be
all pages so ideally what you want to do
is you want to select all pages in order
for analytics to fire on all pages so
that's what we're doing we're setting up
a trigger we're basically telling tag
manager hey if i get a visitor to any
page on my website then i want you to
fire google analytics so that's
basically in summary how to set up your
first tag and my recommendation is your
first tag should be google analytics and
when you set up analytics you're going
to have to set up a variable for the
tracking id and so you get the tracking
id again from admin property settings
copy and paste that tracking id over
save it you have your variable that
variable is going to be included in with
the tag then your trigger is going to be
all pages and there you go you have your
first tag you have your first variable
you have your first trigger so that's
basically what you want to do and once
you've added that tag once you've added
that trigger then the only thing you
need to do now is basically publish the
tag and so anytime you save a tag you're
going to go ahead and submit it so that
way it gets published so again what
you're going to do is let's take a step
back here you're going to choose new tag
you're going to choose analytics from
the drop down menu you're going to
choose page view then basically you're
going to add your tracking id so you can
set up the variable and then basically
that's what you need to do okay you're
going to add that tracking id and then
voila that's your tag with a variable
and then once you've done that then
you're going to click submit so when you
click submit you're basically saying hey
i want this tag to go live now this tag
and trigger and once you've done that
then analytics is ready to go and
anytime somebody goes to your website on
any page tag manager is going to fire
google analytics so the great thing here
is you have something called google tag
assistant and that's an extension that
works with chrome and so when you've
actually added tag manager to your site
or you have analytics running in tag
manager you can confirm if those tags
are firing properly so let's take a look
at how google tag assistant works okay
so if you just do a search for google
tag assistant you're gonna see here that
it's basically just an extension that
works in chrome and unfortunately it
only works in chrome browser it doesn't
work in any other browser
so go ahead and install that extension
into chrome and when you do that you're
going to see this nice icon here in your
browser and now if you go to any website
and i click on google tag assistant and
i click on enable okay so basically i'm
loading google tag assistant and now
once i refresh the page i can see that
this particular site has google tag
manager installed and not only does it
have tag manager installed i can see
that it's also has google analytics
running i have also google optimize
running and i have google ads
remarketing tag running in tag manager
so that's what tag assistant does it
allows you to see
if one tag manager is on the site and if
it is great what other tags are firing
on this particular site so tag
assistant's telling me i have these
particular tags firing on that site and
they're firing within tag manager so tag
assistant is a great way to confirm if
one tag manager is on the site and two
what other tags are firing on the site
now another way you could confirm if tag
manager is firing on the site is you can
go into preview mode so even before you
submit and publish your tag and trigger
you can click on the preview mode so if
i click preview in tag manager so
basically that's going to put me in
preview mode and so what does that mean
well that means that now i'm free to go
to my website and see if those tags are
firing and so let's take a look at what
that looks like so if i go to the
website and just click refresh then
what's going to happen is tag manager is
going to load in preview mode just as
you see here okay so that's going to
take a second couple seconds to load up
and now what can i see in preview mode i
could see that i have gtm firing but i
also have some other text firing on this
page remarketing i have google analytics
i google optimize i have some other tags
firing as well and so the preview mode
shows me what tags are firing on any
given page and i can also see what tags
did not fire okay so here i have a
number of tags already in gtm but they
didn't fire on this particular page so
let's just say i clicked on the donate
now button i'm still in preview mode so
i'm gonna be able to see what tags fired
now i could see i have a couple of tags
that have fired on this particular page
and then i can see what tags did not
fire on this page okay
so that's the preview mode you can use
the preview mode before you even submit
a tag and trigger to see if it fires and
that's the great benefit of tag manager
so if you're not sure if something's
going to fire or not then you can always
go into preview mode um and if you are
sure it's going to fire then you can go
ahead and submit it so you can leave
preview mode and just go ahead and
submit that particular tag and trigger
so here i'm going to leave preview mode
and now once i'm done and i'm sure the
tag is going to fire and go ahead and
submit all my changes that i've worked
on in terms of setting up tags and
triggers so that's really gtm in a
nutshell so i have my tags okay my tags
are just snippets of code that i'm going
to put in whether that be facebook or
vet tracking or any other google product
like optimize or page view then i have
my triggers my triggers are there to
tell gtm when to fire that tag and the
variables are there to help those tags
and triggers work together so remember
that particular variable we set up for
google analytics okay so here it is
right here because we want to tell gtm
what property to specifically fire in
google analytics so that's why we set up
that variable but there are all sorts of
variables google tag manager has built
in or variables already created for you
or you can specifically define a
variable so variables are there to help
the tags and triggers work together so
when you set up a tag you set up a
trigger you use a variable you can
always go into preview mode preview it
by going to the website seeing if it
fires if it fires then voila you can go
ahead and click submit and that will
publish the tag and trigger and you're
good to go that's pretty much how tag
manager works and again i can't stress
that there is an unlimited number of
tags you can add to tag manager there's
no limit so you got everything from
anything from google to non-google to
event tracking okay to facebook to
anything that you want to track you want
to be able to put into tag manager and
again there's versioning that's one of
the great benefits of tag manager so if
i want to go back to an older version i
can simply do that so here you can see
i'm on version 32. that's how tag
manager works and
i can't stress that you know tag manager
is there to help you track interactivity
on the site because if you have a site
that's interactive that has a video that
has a download button let's just say you
know you have all sorts of newsletter
sign ups facebook youtube buttons on
your website just like this website does
and you want to be able to track how
many people click on that particular
button well you're going to need tag
manager and when you have tag manager
you're going to be able to track all of
these button clicks and interactivity on
your website with that we've reached the
end of this video thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
you